[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
and he definitely knows that he hasn't
made his 40 oh no
oh my goodness
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
[Music]
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
miss amigos welcome to round 11 2022
feed candidates we see our friends of
chess walking down the streets coming to
the venue it's a bright beautiful day
here in madrid we see the spanish comedy
team getting set fans getting their
autographs as they will commentate the
action that will unfold here at the
palacio de santonia the players not
quite at their seats just yet dingley
runs smaller chair is there but he's
playing quite well
i'm
really honored again to be joined by
international master almiroschenko grand
master daniel nardiski i am grandmaster
robert hess and guys almira what a great
day we had yesterday
well there was it was such a thrilling
round and there's been so many decisive
games lately so well i don't even know
where to begin maybe danya i cannot
dive into it i see putting me on the
spot early well decisive games is right
in a lot of one e4 games i am certainly
not complaining yesterday was
action-packed
really all of the decisive games were
really really cool in their own way they
all had different signatures different
characteristics starting force from
dingley wren's incredible win over
report in that crazy position you had
yamcha stuff due to playing his best
game of the tournament
and continuing to deal caruana blow
after blown of course ikara nakamura he
might have played the cleanest in the
best game of the round that was amazing
it's true and young napoli he maintains
his lead with that draw as you mentioned
young chistop duda played his best game
of the event but all lies were on the
matchup between hikaru nakamura and
alireza faruja so let's see the recap
from yesterday's action
i mean the moral of the story is you get
creative and bad things happen you have
to not be a creative player and then
good things happen i mean in round 10
hikaru nakamura rejected creativity and
chose to meet alireza farouja's night or
sicilian with the seemingly unambitious
knight to f3
this approach proved psychologically
effective against alireza as it induced
him to be overly ambitious with pawn
takes f6 imbalancing the position but
weakening his pawn structure
in commentary daniel nereditzky shared a
deep insight that hikaru is most
effective in punishing poor pawn
structure if you actually look at hikaru
structures they're always healthy look
at his pawn structure b4 c5 pawn chain
one pawn island on the king side look at
black's pawn structure this certainly
proved true as nakamura never seemed to
allow ali reza any real whiffs of
counter play in the ensuing positions
after ali reza played for an interesting
trick with knight to d4 an excellent
exchange sacrifice allowed hikaru to
establish knife f5 a tremendously
outposted pony that hikaru used to set
up unstoppable checkmating threats on g7
with the support of his queen bishop and
rook
in the final pretty position only
hikaru's queen and knight tandem
remained but made on g7 could not be
stopped and alireza resigned
with this victory hikaru fulfilled a
prophecy that he had made on stream i'm
playing the world robin and blitz i'm
going to play this video grand prix i'm
gonna win it i'm gonna i'm gonna go beat
all the rest of the candidates
well that was a prophecy that came true
we have the prophet next to us and
almirah hikarnaka more impressive game
well that was a very impressive game but
um what i thought about during the game
that i think that alireza was punished
for playing in a very unsuppositional
manner you know uh i think that uh in a
classical game hikaru had enough time to
find
the best plan in the position and to
exploit the weaker structure as dino
said
yeah it was a really tough game there
for ali riza fruga but i think we can
explain why as we bring up the standings
because ali a frugia he was not heading
towards the top and unfortunately sunk
to the bottom so danya as we look at the
standings we have yonda palmashi still
in the lead but what catches your eye
well it's interesting if you just look
at this standing without knowing the
narrative without knowing the storyline
you think fabi hikaru ding they're just
happy to be tied for second place no no
no ding is thrilled he just won two
games in a row ikaro is thrilled he just
beat alireza frozen style fabian
he is far from thrilled because he is a
point and a half behind nepo he was
tailing him throughout this entire
tournament he's going to have to turn it
around but all of that pales in
comparison to one fact of life which is
that for these standings to be shaken up
nepo has to lose a game somebody has to
beat nepo and all of the other players
are praying that that someone is named
elijah as a ferugia well almirah
yesterday you mentioned that young chest
of duda mathematically eliminated not
having a good event he just won his game
so he can shake up the standings some
more as well
well he could but i think that today
he's playing against timur ajabov and as
i might say the old habits they die hard
you know timur is a very solid player
young system was also very sorely
throughout the tournament so i think
that uh well the draw
is a very likely result today in their
in their game
uh and i also wanted to say that uh is
looking for revenge so he is going to
throw himself at yandy pomnishi
uh and this french would say the revenge
is the dish which is best served
[Laughter]
well we will bring up the pairings in a
bit but before we do we talk to dingley
wren in the studio yesterday he's a
player now tied in second place we asked
about his ambitions and what kind of
risk he would take against fabian
carwana here's that interview
depends on possession he must come very
well prepared
like before it's almost important
prioritizing the opening i need to
handle the pressure it gave me then if i
have some chance of course i will i pray
for a win magnus carlsen of course said
that he wanted to play all the razor
furuja alareza not the top of the
standings do you feel like you're second
place i know you came to the tournament
wanting first but do you feel like
you're now right and tied with second
place is that something you've been
thinking about
yes yes now i'm already tied for second
place with ikaru and
fabi yeah i think we are fighting for
the second place
we heard dingley wren's thoughts you
know he knows that second place could be
important usually second equals last at
the candidates but in this particular
one with the storyline of magnus carlsen
potentially declining a world champion
match second place could find their way
in a championship match and well
speaking of matches today we have four
great ones in store for us
amira we have hikar nakamura taking on
rich report that should be a good one
well richard airport is facing as a very
inspired hikaru nakamura because he he's
playing his second game with white
basses he won yesterday so he's
certainly going to
press today and to win another game and
richard lost two games in a row
yeah it's been a struggle for richard
report indeed and we will get to the
ferocious natural game don't worry but
let's start at the bottom there
daniel with you five-minute carwana
versus dingley wren old habits better
die if fabinho caruana hopes to get back
into a spot for first place yeah it's a
game with two players who are in a
completely differing mental state and i
actually really really like these kinds
of games fabby he's in the tailspin
second half of the tournament has gone
terribly he's had gotten half a point of
three games
ding he won two games in a row both of
them excellent he's happy he's happy to
be in second place he is looking to
score the trifecta the question will
fabby be able to push his past results
behind him will he be able to restart
the tournament because he's got the
white pieces this is a game where fabi
has to take some risk a draw right now
with white that had put him on one out
of four in the second half of the
tournament he ain't looking for that i
think we're going to see a very
combative affair today in an italian or
rue lopez well we heard from ding he
said i need to play good preparation
then we'll see if i'll take some chances
but i'll marry a player who won his
first game in three years of classical
chess team over java he has the white
pieces against someone who definitely
takes chances in yanchez of duda well
young sister do they won yesterday
against fabian nicaragua and in in
somewhat what i might call one-sided
game he played almost perfectly
yesterday but he is black against uh te
mura jabba and as you can see uh they
haven't played so many classical games
and they made two draws so i expect like
a very calm game today
okay and well all eyes will certainly be
on the match-up between ali raza faruja
and yonder pompey just like all eyes
were on a certain bullet match last
night between donya and alireza so dania
i think you'll have the most thoughts is
you played the most games against alarez
out of anyone in recent times well
qualified by saying that i think i know
leroyza the best of everyone
caveat asterisk in 30 second chests
uh but you know lareza has been really
really struggling we've talked a lot
about the fact that this is his first
candidates tournament he just doesn't
have that much experience with these
opponents the nerves the anxiety it
might be getting to him you know what
maybe a little change of scenery maybe a
little steam blowing off some steam
doing something a little lighter taking
a little bit less seriously maybe
that'll pay off maybe that's what he
needs just to take some of the stress
off
and play his best chess because his
problems haven't really been in the
opening they've been with his decision
making as a whole yesterday of course g
takes f6 it's not about him not knowing
theory it's about him getting in his own
head and making uncharacteristically
poor decisions let's see
if that little nighttime session will do
him good today and elmira i mean donnie
mentioned blowing off some steam
relaxing but he's lost two games in a
row to younger palm sheen in the first
half of the candidates and before that
in the grand chess tour event so
on one hand maybe he's relaxed but when
you lose two games in a row to somebody
doesn't that kind of spark your
motivation
well it certainly does but on the other
hand it reminds me of one great movie
that i like very much the cincinnati kid
you know and especially of the last
scene where steve mcqueen is desperately
trying to win something you know even if
it's a game of head and tales you know
so you have to understand what what is
his
state of mind right now i think he
desperately needs to win and he's uh
especially against yamni pognashi yeah
it's an opponent that we've said has a
target on his back but especially in
this matchup where jan has won
consecutive games the youngster the
teenager who's played bullet all night
he is going to look for victory for sure
and well i mean i guess now that we've
highlighted the matchups it's my turn to
go through the games pick my
potential winners i'm not going to start
with this game this game is too much to
ask from start with hikaru nakamura
versus richard report and to put on my
dandy cap to go here and vote i am going
to go with hikaru nakamura i know his
many fans out there would love to hear
that but i think that hikar nakamura is
so well prepared such a good form at
this point in the tournament and for
rich rapport he struggled at the opening
many times the black pieces so i'm going
with the car which wow oh my gosh
everybody is picking a car to win
38 to hundred and yeah only 38 people
have picked richard rapport and now
counting 622 and going up for hikaru in
this matchup between ali reza fruga and
yon napomshi it's a result that
everybody in the world not named beyond
the palm she will like to hear i'm going
with alireza i do think that his hyper
bullet session with our daniel
neroditsky will serve him well i think
will help him relax and i also think
like hikaru said that playing many games
it has you seeing tactics so i think
this will help alireza ferrugia so
yonder palm she has not lost the game
this will be his first loss going the
next one between rajabov and duda yon
chest of dudes should great form
yesterday but i think the ultra solid
team rejavo this game is going to end in
the draw and last but certainly not
least we have fabiano caron with the
white pieces against world number two
and china number one dingley wren
i'm gonna surprise everybody and
normally i think you would think the
player with the white pieces is gonna
win i'm going with dingley wren he's won
two in a row he wants the trifecta i am
picking dingly wren to win a second
second game with the black pieces so
that is my fourth and final pick here
everybody should get involved you go to
chess.com events you vote you've up
until move 10 so if you're really smart
you wait until that moment because you
have a chance at 1 000 if you're the top
guesser and here's the kind of the man
of the hour or the man of the last
couple of rounds let's say he has two
points over his last two games he puts
his jacket the way he hung it
right in the middle no you know no
wrinkles well i see maybe one okay i
think there's a little more on the right
side of the left side he needs to adjust
a little so i had a question do you
think like he irons it they do chess
players iron their shirts or t-shirts i
am a chess player and i can only speak
for myself i do like to iron my clothing
you know it's nice to
look fresh even though nobody gives me
credit for it i'm danny and fabiano but
it is uh i think something that players
increasingly so like to look sharp at
the board well i certainly think that
zing has
the wind in its uh sails as you know we
can say and he's feeling more confident
and especially during yesterday's
interview well he shared with us that he
used this opening idea which he had in
store for a while and which was very
useful against richard's report so his
opening preparation is working yeah i
think dingley wren has been playing
excellent chess ever since that first
round loss to jan napoli maybe even the
best chess the tournament it sounds very
strange to say that because yonder palm
she's a point and a half ahead but
dingley wren yesterday we talked about
what ifs he probably has spoiled the
most chances donya yeah and
i wanted to make a point on a slightly
different topic what i'm really curious
about is going to be fabiano's
preparation because dean with the black
beast against one e4 might be the most
predictable player in the tournament he
is an e5 player now i'm going to say all
of this and then he's going to play the
karo khan so just wait but 99 of the
time he plays e5 he plays
usually the same systems within the
rulopas and the italian he has an
absolutely unbreakable repertoire but
we're talking here about fabiano caruana
he comes prepared with some incredible
opening ideas so i'm going to keep a
very close eye on what contributions
fabi can make in this game to italian or
rue lopez theory or maybe he'll play the
king's gambit in honor of richard report
well we do have ollie razor fruit so he
woke up and he did wake up i'm relieved
yeah this would have been your fault if
he hadn't and yonder palm street they
have a handshake before the game but you
know normally handshakes friendly
greetings this i don't know how friendly
these players will be towards each other
young apology he said he'll be a lot
less tense when the tournament ends four
games remaining almirah i think this is
the matchup that he's probably most
nervous about well he well and as you
can see he immediately went away from
the chessboard it's like you can feel
the breath of your opponent you know so
it's it's extremely wild and this
feeling so i think that um he's
extremely nervous and if you can feel
his breath i hope he brushed his teeth
because
that would be better for all enriched
report well it would be better for all
if he plays in every single tournament
because he is such an electric player
not going his way he has lost three of
his last four games he had a win in
there but still he is on a bit of a
losing streak he will hope not to tilt
and he unfortunately has a player that
danya said yesterday
hikaru nakamura when he gets a slightly
better pawn structure he knows how to
maximize it so danya i mean we see
report at the board he's there first
although we did see a car enter the
playing hall that coffee maybe
is going to be hickar's juice
you know first of all he needs to put it
down or the cup holder is but in all
seriousness the opening and robert we
were talking before the show started the
opening is going to be absolutely
critical because
one point i want to make
yesterday report really struggled in
that rui lopez ding was very well
prepared now ultimately did richard
create chances he absolutely did but i
always feel that when you have to do
that when you have to start thinking on
your own from move six or seven and make
your way out of a difficult situation
that sucks all of the energy out of you
and then when the position becomes
really tense when you get a complex
middle game your well-prepared opponent
has all of that energy and time to
expend on playing the middle game well i
think in this game the opening is even
more critical because he carved with the
white pieces i'm expecting one e4 and
i'm expecting hikaru to go after richard
in the first five ten moves of the game
and as we talk about hikaru nakamura
mitchell report and of course the
matchup between fabian and caruana and
dingley wren it will go to show why
second place is so important in this
tournament in previous candidates it's
all or nothing you win or you go home
you do not get that world championship
match but as we see these two players
the number two player in the world in
dingley wren and fabiano caruana i
believe he's still technically number
three or four right now but fabiano who
has a world championship match under his
belt these players know that there's a
lot at stake so will fabiano take the
risks that we may think is necessary to
win first or will he say second place is
enough because magnus carlsen will not
play the winner of this canons
tournament
but if elijah wins today mathematically
there are so many players that still
have the chance well if not to win the
tournament than to share the second
place and we see ali reza on screen here
i mean everybody needs a win here's a
car seat as chair jacket is off
the jacket goes on when he either gets
cold or when he feels like the game is
coming to its conclusion but you know
that this is an important game for the
most popular chess content creator on
the planet the biggest twitch streamer
for chess and we see
young chest of duda i believe the last
player to enter the tournament hall but
somebody who has jumped out of
last place by himself into a tie with a
couple others and our first move of the
day will be played by former real madrid
striker pedro miyatovic he scored the
only goal in champions league final in
1998 versus juventus and
amongst these players they hope to score
the only goal the only decisive game of
this round because they need young
pomschi not to score and for players
like dingley ren fabiano karwana and
hikar nakamura they need to get a
victory and as we await
the start of the clocks on the first
moves i read an interview a while ago i
think with wesley where he mentioned
that the most unpleasant games come when
you're leading the tournament and you're
playing somebody with nothing to lose
alireza has nothing to lose right now
he's probably not going to come in first
probably not going to come in second
although hey if he wins all of his
remaining games never say never and you
can see him adopting a pensive pose
there may be taking a little last-second
nap
but jan almira you pointed out that he's
nervous it was clear even in the
interview yesterday that the thing that
he's most relieved about is that there's
only four games left jan is nervous ali
as a hast has to try to exploit that and
wage warfare on and off the board
psychologically as well as with his
pieces
and i think we all know how difficult it
is uh to make a draw when you need it
and especially if you play for a draw in
a very obvious manner so what do you
think robert dania
is he going for his uh
usual patrol and here we see the former
real madrid striker miyatovic again he
scored the only goal in the champions
league final in 1998 versus juventus so
he's a winner and he hopes necessarily
raise the frugia that his touch will be
good enough to allow
ferruga to win this game against yonder
pumps oh reza just wants the glocks to
be started we're about to find out if
this will be a pitcher up
oh yeah yeah because they have to make
the ceremonial first move isn't actually
the official first move no it's not you
retract the move the clocks are started
and there have been cases of the wrong
move being made by the illustrious guest
and once again a lot of one e4s to kick
off around 11. that's been played the
majority of the time here in madrid
which is where we come to it from and
that is rey enigma if i recognize that
outfit unless it's someone posing as rey
enigma because all you need to do is put
on that costume and i'll think it's rey
every single time mm-hmm
yeah no it's definitely right now you
won't if there was an imposter there's
maybe shoot out of the playing hall
pretty quickly although you wouldn't
know it's an imposter right because it's
an enigma and as we see in the top right
hand side of the screen between farouza
and yamapamshi predictions have come
true that is a petrov and aha we see c4
played after the black knight
jump in the center capturing a pawn
in the top left takara nakamura versus
richard report no move from report and
that's not because he doesn't know what
to do we've seen this from him it's a
little bit of psychological play as he
does put the pawn to c5 but he's the
player who doesn't play instantly in the
opening well he certainly doesn't but
it's also i have a feeling that
sometimes he simply comes and he decides
over the board you know should i play
the karakan or the sicilian or i play
the game against him which started with
e4 knight f6 e5 knight g8
so anything is possible in richard's
case wow i mean i i mean we went back to
farouzia and nepo there and look at
yon's face he's a little bit of surprise
he knows his knight has to move in the
top right and he brings it back to f6
but uh it's an interesting line so i'm
going to bring up that game we will get
to all four games we will not only focus
on the game between uh alireza and yon
napomnishi but the opening is quite
interesting thus far and
these two pawns here on d4 and c4 we can
now go back we'll analyze see how we got
here but when we get to the live
position i'm sure we'll talk about how
white has more advanced pawns even
though black is ahead in development
with the two minor pieces
yeah this is uh sort of always been
considered a second rate move c4 has
been around for a while this is not a
novelty this is not a move that appeared
on the scene in the last couple of years
the point is that you are delaying the
advance of the d-pawn you're waiting for
black to show his cards and then after
knight c6 which was a standard
developing move you can see here another
pretty typical idea d3 to kick the
knight away and now d4 to occupy the
center and
robert you can correct me if i'm wrong
but to me and i don't know much about
these lines the instinctual reaction for
black is to push the d pawn to d5
right contesting the center and there's
a high probability that you'll get an
isolated queen pawn situation if light
trades on d5 or black takes on c4
well i think that
we should point out also we should point
out also the idea that uh white plays c4
to avoid the symmetrical uh type of
structures in the center if you
uh he avoids the lines with d4 and d5
and robert if you can come back like at
the beginning e4 just e4 for example and
try e6 here
d4 d5
okay so the exchange french take on d5
knight
f3 knight c6 knight f6 sorry
and c4
here uh you know
with the transposition we could have the
position on the game with knight c6 but
very often here you play bishop d6
so i'm not sure that jan is uh
well he wants to get this position
because his knights were already on c6
it's a good point that the inclusion of
knight c6 may limit black's options and
as we go back to the game continuation
then at the end of uh this
sequence after c4
and extreme you see where d3 and then d4
this bishop just went out to e7 so
delaying the move d5 is yonder palm tree
which allows white to push this pawn up
to attack the knight on c6 i don't think
you want to rush that move because
anytime you push a pawn you vacate a
square for a piece and that is the e5
square for this knight offering some
trades but
donya what do you make of this opening
choice from alireza he played it quickly
he played it confidently and we're in
rare territory i like it he just decided
to get a position a relatively quiet
position
uh where both players have the room
uh to be themselves and the situation
where the better player will win
if i had to choose a side here i'd
probably choose white white as the space
advantage and robert he waited for you
to say that and then he pushes the pawn
to d5 so a very bold decision early on
alireza took about a minute and a half
on this move
something tells me that he's still well
within preparation but just needed a
moment to remember
his files because
it's not like he was reviewing them
until five in the morning yesterday and
almira as we were talking about before
the show you thought that already plays
something very concrete and he would
challenge yon in his opening this is
pretty concrete stuff
this is a very uh concrete line on the
other hand it's also very simple to play
because there are not so many tactical
ideas in this position so uh
have a have a look at this bishop on f5
that's exactly what i wanted to say that
after knight five you don't have to
exchange and knight d4 is a very clever
move
because it asks you a question where
you're going to develop this bishop
um great question
i'm not sure usually black tries to
chisel at the puncher 666 but
maybe alareza has f4 in the future like
he's just trying to go for it and we
know he can be a really aggressive
player sometimes to his own detriment as
we saw yesterday against zakar nakamura
but it's clear that he wants to battle
yonda pamashi
and
i was looking at the bishop g4 is he
going to play something like f3 here and
g4 then is it possible
[Music]
i don't think he needs to be asked twice
to choose some kind of adventurous line
i guess the good thing for white as well
is the queen can always escape towards
on the other side of the board with
queen to b3 so the flexibility in this
position for alleriza frugia clearly not
expected from ghanda palm show we
brought him up on camera here he's
sipping that tea but he's also about to
spend some time trying to figure things
out yeah i don't think jan is too
concerned here because
i think it's worthwhile sometimes to ask
well what's the worst case scenario
let's say jan just kind of develops his
pieces normally how bad could it
possibly get well the worst case
scenario is that white's going to be
slightly better if jan castle's here for
example and i do like to move c7 c6
not delaying not procrastinating and
trying to cut into as you said chisel at
white center immediately before white
has completed his development but let's
say that jan pushes that aside and he
castles instead ali reza is going to
develop his knight to c3 his light
squared bishop to e2 and he's going to
castle and the worst case scenario for
black is that he gets a little bit
cramped but it's not like black has any
weaknesses so i think alireza isn't
trying to win the game in the opening
he's not trying to deliver any crushing
blows he's trying to get a slightly
better position and just make it
annoying for yan to play potential
counterpoint elmira is that yonda pomshi
speaking of annoying he doesn't like
cramped position so maybe this is a
stylistic choice
this might be a stylistic choice on the
other hand i thought that uh ali raza
foreign is going to castle long here oh
and
actually that's what i'm expecting from
him this position
like queen and then castle even even f3
like bishop g4 he's waiting waiting for
bishop g4 to play f3 then you can play
like in an english attack in the
sicilian knight c3 bishop v3 queen d2
custom long and g4
oh my goodness i want that to be true
emotionally
i want to see that i'm just worried
about c7 c6 coming on here at the wrong
moment and then the center opens up and
the c file opens up and i don't know i i
think we need to point out because c6 is
the natural move just to gain black some
space open up this queen on the diagonal
but if this knight is kicked away from
e5 it may cost black a pawn so it's not
that straightforward which is why yawn
needs to think and he actually castled
first so we have spent a good deal of
time you could still get your vote in
it's only moved nine you have until move
ten so your predictions
are still up to you don't listen to us
you make your own prediction you're your
own boss but let's zoom out for a moment
as now ali raza faruja is on the clock
after castles i think he will continue
to take some space as we've been
discussing and he is up a few minutes so
we'll see how this one continues but
there are other important games well
this one is
the leader at play against a very hungry
teenager we have a lot happening in the
bottom right hand side between fabiano
caruana and ding lee wren that game is
already 15 moves deep we see fabian on
camera here he's looking right at us i
think he knows we're talking about him
but then he decides to leave because
we're talking about him and this is
highly theoretical territory so dingley
wren you know he has these pawns on the
dark squares
white playing for the light squares
amira what do you think about how this
opening is going
well
can we have a look at the um
at the beginning yeah we'll bring up an
analysis so we can because i really like
this position but it seems to be very
standard once again for uh
this opening especially when you play
four or three and do not play c3 and d4
okay tell me where
here like
a4 with five went for
[Music]
a4 and not the the main line probably
because dingle ring is playing the
marshall yeah
uh here bishop b7 d3 d6
and knight c3 that's the idea behind
this move order that you're not going to
play the standard plan with c3 and d4
but you develop your knight on c3 and he
started with bishop b2 and i just wanted
to point out why that is is because
knight c3 while you're trying to hop
into the center it often allows black to
quickly make moves like v4 and 95 which
i mean we see the live position that is
what eventually happened but the move
order difference allows knight a5 first
attacking this bishop yes white can
steal a pawn but you lose the bishop
pair and have terrible pawn structure so
when the white fishing was back to a2
black can play b4 and maybe even b3
sometimes you just throw that pawn away
to get rid of this bishop on its
annoying diagonal so i just want to
point that out but amira sorry yes it's
of course just bishop d today i meant
that these were the ideas of the opening
so bishop d2 queen g7 knight c3 so
knight a5 anyway because this is uh
mathematical led in this opening
um b4 knight two c5 and i just want
where the b3 no longer is good because
you can take this knot on a5 that's why
bishop d2 was played but c5
and this is a very thematical idea also
to cement at the center
knight g3 i like this move very much
it's also once again a very standard
manure
and rook ab8 i think dink is preparing
uh for bishop c6 and b3
maybe in some variations
what second game in a row amir where he
puts his
it's like do work on the queen side it's
a mysterious move but i think almeria
has a great point that the bishop's
trying to move out the way and then b3
can be an option of course this pawn a4
is targeted so
yeah an interesting choice by ding but
after the move knight h4
which brings the next knight into the
game maybe allows white to expand with
f4 as well
now dingley run is on the clock so who's
won the opening battle in your opinion
i'll maybe i'll start with you
it's very difficult to assess this
position immediately i
i like fibers position very much because
whenever you can play f4
you feel very happy sir and
i have a feeling that black needs to
play g6 here
because if i will have a 4 and establish
one of my knights on f5
the position of black's king will become
very dangerous
okay so almira prefers the white pieces
dania
i mostly agree with omira but i have to
reveal a certain bias of course i've
played the rylo that's from the white
side a lot longer than i played it from
the black side
and i also know that fabi has won
quite a large share of really really
instructive games in these types of
positions
i like the idea of the knight coming to
f5 the fact that g6
weakens black's king permanently is of
serious concern but if we look at this
line concretely after g6
if i'm reading the situation right
knight take c4 does become
uh maybe not so much of a threat but an
idea to be reckoned with so let's say g6
happens okay we'll bring up back the
analysis board to show daniel's line
g6 let's bring up the analysis board
because first and foremost we have to
consider night sacrifices on f5 they're
already in play for instance let's start
with bishop h6
okay we're just gonna make sure the
analysis board is brought up so yep
dania's line is
for now i play the concept yeah yeah
so what i'm saying conceptually is that
if a knight is sacrificed on f5
storm clouds are going to gather around
black's king but the other idea as
almira illustrated is to push that f
pawn to f4 so ding has a lot to deal
with on the king side and you might ask
what does he have on the queen side to
compensate for that and that is why i'm
pretty concerned about black's position
in the early going i'm not quite seeing
just yet what the zen of ding's play is
in regards to the queen side the idea of
moving the bishop out from b7 and then
going b3 well there's always going to be
that problem of the knight on a5 being
hanging so
we'll see we'll see the eval bar doesn't
seem concerned at least
but in the early going i like what fabi
has chosen here i have to show your
sacrifice with you you could start with
bishop h6 or not but let's say this rook
moves away and the knight comes to f5 so
most people think
what are you doing you're giving away a
knight for just a pawn but that's not
just any pawn after g takes f5 then we
just take back and you see the
evaluation bar immediately go sky high
because the plan is simple queen f3
queen g3 queen g7 with checkmate we have
that knight that knife symbol the knife
out again make that sound the knife on
f5 the bishop which is uh kind of
playing archery from back there towards
the enemy king as well and the plan is
so straightforward for white so there's
nothing that black can do to hold on
here without pieces defending the king
so your knight f5 sacrifice it's a
viable option
yeah it's definitely something that ding
is seriously contemplating you don't
play the move g7 g6 without a very
significant amount of thought and you
kind of have to keep this dark square
bishop because you don't play g6 open up
the dark squares and then lose this dark
square bishop that seems like it would
be a strategic mistake but
playing with bishop d8 here elmira just
feels kind of uncomfortable so your
first instinct was you liked white's
position i'm i'm agreeing with you and
also i wanted to show that if in this
position you can also play bishop f8
let's say but even this uh after bishop
f8 let's say book of it the simple idea
like queen d2
might be immediately on the spot i don't
know like if if it is tactically
justified but
and then
king chad yes the only move probably
here yeah you probably have to go here
and this queen is coming up and it
doesn't lead to immediately immediate
checkmate but with this bishop still
aiming this way and the queen coming in
it is starting to feel uncomfortable
isn't it
that's unpleasant this is not fun and uh
dig has to be very careful
in the next four or five moves i don't
think there's any objective reason for
concern yet
but these ideas like knight f5 and
bishop h6
fabi he knows these positions so so well
and i know that ding knows that
and
i think for that reason
he's taking extra care not to let the
situation get out of control early i
agree with you completely because look
at zing he realized that this is like
the first critical moment of the game
and he takes his time and his time
management all throughout the tournament
has been um
very
well very
i know i just you said in french i was
like i got you
oh
so i well
and he plays g6 though so i think amir i
get what you're saying because we saw
him go down the clock against hikaru
nakamura and he understands those
moments when he has to think all right
this was a critical moment because if he
doesn't play g6 and then knight just
gets an f5 without eventually being
kicked out of there that could be a
problem so dingley wren has already made
15 moves now probably made his 16th and
he does he will have time remaining
after spending an hour or so over the
next bunch of moves but it feels like
dingle and he just he's
really a believer in his openings he
doesn't even point one other thing out
go for it which is that fab you might
still be in his preparation the speaker
that you played bishop h6 again not a
move that you play instantly unless
you're familiar with the position and if
he plays knight hf5 right now within
like a minute
i'd be even more concerned for deng
because that would mean he's still in
his preparation
upon sacrificing his knight that's never
fun to deal with but you're absolutely
right ding believes in the overall
health of his position he believes that
he can manage even if he gets out
prepared in any particular game
and you know just judging by honestly
how little time you spent because the
lines we were just looking at they seem
very scary for the black king so you
don't make these decisions lightly to
push pawns where your king is so g6
move that he thought about he just
simply slides his rook over and
fabiano plays knight h to f5
okay ding loren now on the clock and
this is a really really big moment
because uh i think the natural
temptation
oh my gosh he's just so awesome
he's so good because
i'm gonna show this on the analysis
board i think
the natural temptation was to bring the
bishop back to f8 but the problem with
bishop f8
is bishop to g5 and this knight has
nowhere to go it's not something you see
very regularly and not only
does that have nowhere to go so you have
to protect it knight h6 check will be an
annoying threat with this bishop aiming
at the f7 pawn and you have to give up
that dark square bishop your king side
will be in trouble for the rest of the
game so bishop d8 going away from your
king it actually keeps your king safer
in the long run because you get to help
control your own dark squares by leaving
this bishop on the board
wow this is really fascinating i'm just
processing all of this
and i'm yeah i'm so interested to see
when each of the players is actually
going to exit their preparation elmira
go ahead well i was thinking uh how
should we continue here like if we were
in five shoes maybe queen d2
okay and f4 next or
and i guess for dingler and he has this
choice at bishop c6 we mentioned that a
few times you could even consider d5
right trying to blast open the center
because white's attention is firmly on
the king's side and something we've
talked about in previous rounds and is
important to reinforce is that when
somebody is attacking you on a flank in
this case the king side you can often
combat
that pressure by playing in the center
distracting white's forces and
what
knight g7
knight g6 shadowing the knight
but
attacking the rook so rook e7 or rook f8
is the big question here for black this
move actually makes sense to me robert
yeah but if i move my rook are you going
to bring your knight right back no
knight g3 maybe the other knight's f5
i'll mirror oh if i go this way you
bring or you be queen f3 because your
knight's not protected the contact
between the bishop on the end and the
knight on f6 has been severed but queen
f3 knight g4 oh
so right here rookie 7 queen f3 knight
g4 there must be some sort of a tactic
here
no but that's why i wanted to play
knight 3 f5 so you you don't have this
move knight g4 but even here knight f5
looks incredibly strong
i don't know which probably this one
because in many versions the king would
be attacking this knight and you still
can't take here because your king is
ripped open no it's important to put the
rook on fa you need the services of the
bishop on d8 you need that bishop to
operate at its full potential
it's just kind of uncomfortable to put
the rook in line with the bishop but
you're right rook f8 seems to hold the
balance and we could see
a draw by repetition this would be uh
force black probably to bring the rook
back to e8 and the knight going on a
wheel from g7 f5 the rook sliding back
and forth between e and f8 wow that
would be a shocking turn of events
that's impossible
i would still prefer to play uh dania's
move h3 which he like predicted
yesterday in hikarus game
so here the
like knight g7 rook f8 and then h3
okay
if you want to play knight g4 and i will
simply deprive you of any counter play
what a position a knight on g7 you
almost never see that
i mean i can probably count on one hand
especially in a rulopa is like this that
this is nuts and that knight is actually
quite safe the reason it's safe is
because the bishop on h6 is safe right
and the reason the bishop is because of
the pawn that we just put on h3 to stop
knight g4 so the big question right now
is maybe fabi went for this line in the
hopes and this happens at the high level
you go for a line and you know that
there is an equalizing response but what
you say is if my opponent finds five
seven accurate moves in a row i'm going
to give them the draw otherwise i'm
going to get a big advantage i'm taking
a gamble maybe fabi's doing that but
omira maybe you're right and fabi just
wants a very complicated position he's
going to play a slow move in response to
rocafe what i was thinking is that can
we do we have time for a slow move in
this
position we know that b3 is a typical
idea even if we sacrifice upon for
example if black plays b3 c takes b3 and
knight c6
uh what should we do sacrifice this pawn
once again
and play b4 to open our bishop it's a
really big decision there because yeah
this bishop is not
much of a bishop of the pawn in the way
but playing b4 also has some risks
because
hi everyone i'm sorry but we're a better
punch
hi everyone i'm that dingley red move
quickly and which remind everybody as we
catch up to the live board here with
rook f8 he plays zachary move that
dingly wren has a pretty monster score
against fabiano caruana throughout their
history fabiano has beaten him just a
couple of times whereas ding i know some
of the games were from childhood but
dingley wren has beaten him
much more often so
it's i wonder if that weighs on fabiano
but you say childhood and uh
amira you are the fabulous fur he plays
age three but just complete the thought
really quickly a couple of days ago i
was analyzing an opening
and i looked at the games list and there
was a fabby game from 2009 or something
and i was like that game doesn't count
then i looked at his rating he's like 20
60 80. i'm like 2009 that was 13 years
ago these guys have been gm's forever
but age three amazing
well the same is true for richard report
we showed you his game yesterday and we
said like it was played eight years ago
and who's over 27. there's over 2700
that's like how strong they were when
they were young
yeah no i mean we still got to count
those games as we see their head-to-head
history how they match up against each
other we see that there are
uh five wins for dingley ren two for
fabiano they are the same age and so
those first couple games those first
couple wins for dingler and happened in
these world youth events when they were
young teenagers or maybe not even in
their teens but still dingley wren 2806
we know that he's the number one player
from china number two player in the
world playing in his third canyon
tournament but maybe the most
interesting stat of all is that last one
where fabinho has beaten magnus five
times and dingley wren despite being the
next up in the rating list has never
taken down magnus in classical chess
by the way i wanted to bring up the the
topic of the tie breaks because we know
that for example if those two players
will share for the second place
how are we going to decide because there
are tiebreaks which uh
well in in the regulations uh which are
supposed to be if in case of the time
the first place but how are we going to
decide who is second
they actually don't have a tie break
match for second place in this
tournament so there will be three
different criterias they they use the
tiebreak criteria which you know you
don't come into the candidates expecting
that you need to decide between second
and fourth place in any meaningful way
if that's you know where we stand at the
end of the tournament so
it might be another topic of
conversation where people always want to
see ties played out over the board and
chess why not you just set up a board
you go play a quicker target chill and
that's that and that would happen in the
event that somebody catches up to you on
the palm street but not in the event
that these two players or hikar nakamura
they're sharing that second place so
that's gonna probably be a big storyline
if in fact magnus carlsen does not play
the world championship i think that for
the moment fabiano caron has the
slightly better tie break if he dies for
the second
oh fabiano then he should be uh happy
about that but the last three rounds
have not gone his way so i'm guessing
he's not thinking about tie breaks just
yet but it is something that we'll need
to keep an eye on and as we look across
the four boards we see that in the top
left hikaru nakamura he has the white
side of a sicilian defense in the bottom
left we have java and duda they're
playing a battle in the center with the
d4 pawns and c5 pawns staring at each
other but in the top right by the way
the c6 and take on d5 has happened as
has your
movement f3 clearly not trying to trade
light square bishops but let's go to
that game between hikaru nakamura and
rich report
nakamura enters the day tied for second
place and well
these types of positions extremely i
wonder what opening this was uh
definitely wasn't a sicilian not at all
but as a standard in many sicilians the
d5 square is white's for the taking but
black has this dark square bishop
unopposed on the diagonals but staring
into thin air they're playing one of my
favorite openings yeah
like i was playing it for so many years
and
makes me very happy that it became
once again very popular recently but
hikaru has chosen a very solid line once
again
so he's saying okay let's
get at me
yeah he's in whites and richards
for a dance and we could show how we got
here bring up the analysis board to
start from the beginning where we had a
sicilian we saw richard played that move
and
richard has by the way played knight c6
very often in this event and others and
we see the quick move e5 so this is a
committal choice we saw in the game
between hikaru and alireza the knight
went back to f3 but that was a slightly
different position and that's important
because white can take advantage of the
fact that d6 square is currently
available to his pieces although robert
may i interrupt you for just a second
uh the reason he car took some time uh
instead of knight db5 which for decades
was considered the only move recently
the ridiculous looking move knight de-2
has been making appearances at the
highest level followed by knight g3 so i
feel like hikaru
may have
thought about taking this onto an
offbeat path but then thought better of
it and decided to go down the more
conventional
cuff path right go on so he says let's
go knight to b5 d6 play to make sure
that knight isn't going in there which
would force black to give up that dark
square bishop
bishop g5 this is all well known theory
and black plays a6 because the last
thing black wants to see this knight
landed on d5 and then a knight lands on
c7 and you see the fork for the king and
the rook speak for yourself i want that
you certainly do not knight drops back
to a3 we see b5 after knight d5 bishop
v7
takes
bishop takes back
no g takes f6 in this game and then we
see c3 so white doesn't actually want to
take this bishop as we scroll to the
live board white kind of operates around
that bishop playing natural moves like
g3 bishop g2 reinforcing the center here
and after
this move report has been thinking for
five minutes and 45 seconds because it's
not entirely clear what black's plan is
right you can think about f5 you can
think about 97 to trade the pieces but
elmira you said you've been playing this
position your whole life
what do you make of it so far well i
think the most natural move in this
position would be a5 actually because
you want to play knight e7 but you don't
want to the other knight to jump onto
the g5 square so first you
just show and your point is that this
knight replaces the other because he
cannot play knight e3 because i will
most certainly say bishop b3
so that's the point behind black's place
so you start with this very important
move a5 he just played by the way he did
in fact play a5
oh he already played it's okay so
and then uh you play 97 bishop e6
with a very comfortable play for black
okay and donya almira is liking this
from black's perspective what do you
think how's the car feeling
i think hikaru is feeling fine i mean
the move g3
and you know i'm pretty rusty on my
parentheses feshnikov theory on all of
my theory but
uh as far as i know g3 is not common at
all i know that a4 is elmira you can
correct me if i'm wrong but i think it's
the sort of old-school and most
established way of playing trying to
strike at the queenside g3 to me
is a clear indication that dekara wants
to take this game off the beaten path he
just wants to get a position a position
where he isn't risking too much where
his king is perfectly safe
and where he's shooting for but a very
small edge i really like the move a5 i
think if richard can solve the problem
of the d5 square if he can successfully
get in 97 and bishop e6 and then maybe
he should play bishop f6 and take with
the g pawn
ali reza no i'm kidding
but if he can solve the problem of the
d5 square
he'll be completely fine and his pawn
structure is totally and completely
healthy i
like the way it's looking for him so far
position is equal i think and nikara
spent more time so that leads me to
believe he wasn't
expecting this today or wasn't as well
prepared in this opening as he was in
others and if we're honest with
yesterday's game and hikara himself said
this he had no advantage after the first
dozen or so moves it was only until
alariza took it upon himself to make
things complicated unnecessarily so so
maybe he's relying on that again amira
where he's saying richard likes spicy
chess he doesn't want a positional
battle he's going to throw his piece at
me at some point and i can take
advantage of him overstepping exactly
that's what i meant that he's enwines in
him for a dance maybe
flamenco you know who knows but
i wanted to um underline that hikaru has
a very healthy position so yes
in this
well he has a very interesting idea up
his sleeve is to play h4 what i wanted
to show because you
you ask this bishop a question because a
very typical idea in this opening would
be to play 97 bishop b6
bishop this queen g7 and then bishop d8
and bishop b6 but after bishop h6 you
know this is no longer possible so you
have to switch to another plan with g6
and f5 maybe so
this is a very complicated position but
i think that um hikaru well wants to
take it slow
and the good thing for a car is here is
like five different moves that all keep
the status quo which maintains the
evaluation bar where it sits but i like
what you were saying that black's plan
is actually quite clear knight e7 bishop
e6 and so often times people place
bishop h3 and it says that black's
advance has a bit of advantage after
bishop takes ether and rook takes h3 and
the reason why is elmira's move a5
without this move let's say this knight
came to e7 don't take my knight we're
gonna pretend you can't take my knight
on before okay i know the evaluation bar
is gonna go down but if you can't take
my knight and have to take this one
instead this is like the worst possible
scenario and this is the
player who's playing the white side of
the sicilian's dreams playing as a dark
square bishop even if it was on e7
looking a little bit better but the
knight on d5 cannot be touched it's on
outpost so it doesn't look like hikaru
can establish that in this game
not for the moment but this is certainly
your dream position so
maybe even if you trade a few rooks so
you can take with uh maybe a rook on d5
and
one another idea behind the move h4 is
that
the d6 spawn is
such a weakness that
you want to have a bishop to protect it
so after bishop h6
you can double your rooks on the g file
simply castle first so play knight queen
g3 rook d1 and
could be a bit unpleasant although i
still feel that the position
is
very balanced that's such a good point
though that the d6 pawn is behind that
white knight on d5 so we don't always
look at that we just look at the square
that we love that d5 square but a large
reason why is because you can stop that
pawn in his tracks and then go after and
hikaru decides to castle instead of
playing h4 first
he can't play h4 later just because he's
castle squad doesn't mean it's out of
the question so he and said castles and
maybe at some point can even look at the
move f4 though that carries its own risk
i think the one important thing to point
out here is that in many semester graph
positions black wants to shove through
f7 f5 as quickly as possible i don't
think this is one of those situations i
think this would fully justify the
placement of picardo's bishop on g2 if
black plays f5 here white says thank you
very much takes on f5
plays knight ce3 and black hasn't really
squeezed a lot out of that advance so
here it's very important for richard to
focus with a single mind on the
elimination of the knight on d5 and to
do so while as almira pointed out
keeping the d6 pawn well protected and
richard looks extremely focused and
we'll leave him for the moment trying to
figure out what to do because we have a
big move as we bring back the bird's eye
view see all four games and if we look
in the bottom right hand side of our
screen dinglin has in fact jettisoned
the pawn he pushed it to b3 where three
white pieces cover the square and only
one for black but we were showing the
point right it shuts down that bishop on
a2 and it is now causing fabiano to
think so that game will remain very
interesting it's such a unique position
with a knight in enemy territory but the
solid structure that black has
definitely keeps him well within the
game but maybe we should go to our game
between rajabov and duda we haven't
looked at that one it's the only one we
haven't checked out yet so i'm going to
pull that one up there only 11 moves in
and i think almira our predictions of
it's just going to be a pretty solid
game
it seems like our job of not taking
tremendous risk what what an exciting
opening to us all right that's the
answer that i wanted to take
it might be time for it but
i wouldn't say that it's like a dead
draw or anything like that
but you guys it's not without venom it's
not without venom that's a good of
course queen c2
already creates a threat yeah of course
there are ways to create threats in the
position but
our reaction is because look at the pawn
structure it's pretty symmetrical except
for the fact that
white has fianchettoed on both sides but
the bishops in the long diagonal and
black has a bishop on c5 not really
doing the maximum in fact that bishop
can often be a target for white's pieces
so i do believe that timor isn't just
playing for a draw he's playing to have
a risk-free position where he can try to
outplay young chistov because let's not
forget that a couple of rounds ago when
young chiseled was black against dingley
wren that also looked like a harmless
position where perhaps duda shouldn't be
in so much trouble but
uh dingley ryan was able to increase the
pressure move after move and score a
really nice victory that he even talked
to us a little bit about so
with rajab of ahead in the clock and in
a comfort zone of his this is his style
of opening maybe he is waiting to pounce
but isn't going to do so in the first
dozen moves robert and uh please have a
look at this third move already okay
we'll bring up the announcement to
rewind in this game and show how we got
here that the third move here was b3 by
timor so hey if hikar can play b3 why
not timor
but that's quite an unusual move order
i would say if
probably he's trying to avoid
the main lines of the queen's gambit
so b3 d5 bishop d2 first striving for
somewhat like double fianchetto what
happened in the game
and only then he develops his bishop
second bishop in g2
right
and it takes on d5 at this moment and i
say this is actually a pretty
instructive moment because knight takes
d5
we usually recapture pawns with pawns
but after e takes d5 the problem becomes
that whether you play d4 now or after
castling black plays the move c5 to gain
space and then when white plays d4
you're either going to be left with
hanging pawns where i'll just make a
move to show that that this kind of
structure
is not always easy to defend and anytime
you push a pawn you leave a square
behind same deal with this pawn you
leave the
c knight h4 to f5 becomes a very nasty
idea in such positions all sorts of
possibilities here or if you don't want
hanging pawns you'd have to take on d4
or
you know let capture the piece in c5
you're left with this isolated pawn on
d5 so pawns want to be near each other
and that's why instead of capturing the
pawn
he takes the knight and just develops
and plays c5 in this move order saying
you had two pawns in the center compared
to my one now i'm eliminating your pawn
with
mine so
and it's very important to play c5 here
otherwise white simply takes the center
right you know why can you think about
playing e4 and just
i mean you have two pawns in the center
so c5 challenging
takes bishop takes and i guess one point
we could have made and no longer is
really there is that white like in the
game between farouja and caruana you
don't often want to make this e4 move it
gives black squares this pawn is
covering the very important d3 square
and a common idea is actually for a
knight to get to d3 that if this knight
goes to e5 it often backtracks to d3 and
black's open file isn't going to amount
to much with this
queen on date trying to use it so it's a
really actually interesting kind of
technical battle it's not as clear as
like oh threatening checkmate but
putting a knight on f5 things like that
but the nuances become extremely
important well i think
this was a very important point about
the knight on d3 because very often this
the two knights of the
if you would trade the bishops
are
a little bit stronger than blackstones
and
what i think uh
timur tried to obtain against zinc here
is somewhere more realistic he's he
would try to
um
to squeeze something out of the c6
square in a long-term battle
yeah that's important right because
there's no pawn that can defend that
square so that's a place where maybe a
knight will go or if we can kick this
bishop out eventually use it for a rook
and this bishop is just worse than the
bishop on b2 right that bishop has the
entire length of the board it's the best
diagonal to be on and so that's maybe
going to keep the job with a slight edge
but uh you know right now is where
java's move he needs to prove it that's
the thing is you can get an advantage
the computer can like your position but
if you don't actually create some
threats at some moment
black just neutralizes it and maintains
the equality so not the
most exciting game yet but i do believe
that it could heat up in the future and
timur is investing a significant amount
of time in this position
uh precisely because i think he realizes
that if duda goes knight b to d7 and
then rook c8 and then queen e7 all he
really needs is like three or four moves
and he's completely consolidated so
the last thing i'll say is that queen c2
was a very appealing move to be
initially and maybe we could just very
quickly show what thread it creates if
you play queen c2 and then random moves
such as a6 there is the incredibly nasty
knight g5
and if bishop takes g2 the point is you
have this crushing inter mezzo bishop
takes f6 with the mate through it on h7
but
the reason queen c2 isn't quite as good
as it looks is because of the simple i
think knight bd7 and when the knights
are connected the sting is taken out of
any bishop takes f6 move so knight g5 is
no longer dangerous and what's more
is that the queen on c2 can be targeted
i'll let you finish showing the line but
the queen on c2 can be targeted by a
black rock on c8 and sotimur
has decided to delay that move in favor
of preparing the queenside expansion
with a3 i like that approach and we will
see if beyonce manages to complete the
neutralization of any small edge that
two more might still have in the next
couple of moves
and we saw you just to play an a5 type
moving stingley wren but that comes with
consequences after you move the pawn to
a5 the b5 square often can become white
for the taking and this b6 pawn will be
a target if this bishop ever had to
leave so it's a big moment as well for
young chistop he will have to make a
concession either with the bishop
forced back or with his pawn going
forward but leaving squares behind but
we will leave this one behind just for
the moment we won't lose sight of it
completely we have uh to pay attention
to all of these fantastic players but i
i mean we have to have our eyes set on
already frozen's clock against yonder
palmishi the board is interesting but
the clock he's up 20 minutes against
perhaps the fastest player in the game
how many games have you played yesterday
how many games did we play exactly 250
oh my gosh but they were 32nd games yeah
that's not as much as it sounds
the interesting thing is playing
exclusively d4 against me so maybe he
was uh
suspicious of a certain jan napomnishi
using those 32nd games to prepare
and here he doubles back in place one e4
but the only other time as far as i
remember that jan was down
a significant amount of time near the
opening was against fabiano caruana and
he ended up getting a very very dubious
position
in that game jan does not like being
down
20 or 30 minutes on the clock so
this is a promising sign for ferruccia
as far as the position is concerned
i don't really know if we can talk about
a realistic advantage for him unless he
plays
very very accurately here and maybe f3
f4
is a serious candidate move that he
should consider but i'll argue that this
is the type of position farouja should
have been looking for throughout the
entire tournament that when he played
the game with the white pieces against
five-minute carwana he played a catalan
that he never was comfortable in and so
he's been trying to mix up his openings
trying to catch his opponents by
surprise but when you do that and you
haven't historically played those
openings you can find yourself in a new
position that your opponent is familiar
with maybe not the exact move order not
exactly you know the piece in the same
squares that you looked at in your
computer but you have a good feel for
the position so i would say that
honestly for both of these players
because janupamshi
he is a very energetic player himself
that i think this suits both of their
styles
well let's say that yesterday or tonight
uh there's a shook off like some of his
rust you know because
it's
very difficult to make decisions over
the board when he didn't play for such a
long time and hikaru
criticized it he said that it was a
big mistake
so let's see if those 250 games will
help there's uh to
to play
more precisely today to see tactical's
ideas
and i do like this move f4 which is very
concrete
once again uh
because
what to do here in
knight c4 probably
yeah as we analyze the position the
knight i guess has to
venture into a square like c4 and i
attempted to kick it to hope the knight
goes backwards but because the knight on
c3 is a little bit loose maybe you can
get away with this
adventurous 93
and even that doesn't tell the full
story white can take the knight
black returns the favor and then this
bishop slides back let's say to g1 this
queen is in the line of fire this rook
while it's seemingly well placed it
could you know maybe get even trapped if
this bishop comes to c4 and the rook is
losing squares very quickly this is a
complex position
yeah but at the end of the line black
has queen a5 in this position we have on
the board
and i'm quite concerned
with the health and safety of white's
d5 pawn and if you lose that pawn you
may start to lose your grip on the
position it's a super super complicated
situation but if we go back to the
position after f4
i also find the move knight e5 to g6 to
be quite natural
and of course pushing the pawn to f5 is
highly inadvisable because it gives up
the e5 score permanently
and here ali reza would have to find a
way to get his dark squared bishop out
of the game because if you develop it
immediately you drop b2 if you say ah
let me play rook b1 first that's a tiny
mistake
because of a certain rook takes c3 move
and you lose a piece you can't really
move your queen and defend the pawn
because the knight on d4 is going to be
hanging so alireza has some logistical
problems when you've got a big space
advantage these problems tend to arise
because you have a lot of stuff that you
have to supervise and a lot of pawns and
squares and pieces that you have to
watch over i think objectively white
probably has a small edge but ali reza
is going to have to be very precise in
the next couple of moves and that's why
you learn from hikart nakamura and you
make rook pawn moves like a4 and that
was a similar theme as his game against
five-minute caron that queen was on g6
and a car played h4 but the point if as
daniel was mentioning this b2 pawn is
always targeted so let's kick that queen
out of there and if you make the move a5
you hand over the b5 square for the rest
of the game and white has two knights
and a bishop that all would be happy to
sit there so yeah it's a really fun
position honestly this bishop on e7 not
looking very good um black's knights for
the moment they're
fine but they don't necessarily have the
clearest future but this d5 pawn i think
that's really one of the big story lines
here is is that a pawn that has gone too
far
no it looks like you know the roman
empire like with all its borders right
which is which potentially could be
attacked you know from
every side
right the gods from from c8 and the
visigoths from e8 and
um the ostrogoths from b6 so
white is
white is having some trouble keeping his
empire alive i like that comparison by
elmira and i think alireza is doing the
right thing
uh taking his first significant think in
this position
it's not an easy one to
figure out to parse through all the
details and you know he wants to play f4
to kick that knight but he is concerned
about the knight going into c4 it's
probably his first thought in the night
going to g6 as you mentioned also seems
all right but as we look at alareza
the impact of a long night of hyper
bullet chess i can't quite tell if uh
you know he's feeling exhausted or if
he's feeling rejuvenated because
sometimes i've seen you can i slept two
three hours when i was 19 and
felt completely fine i could take six
exams the next day and then play
you know three classical games but this
is the candidates we're talking about
but it's no big deal yeah for you it
could be rejuvenating for him i mean you
could maybe see him a little sleep in
his eye it depends on the occasion but i
do think my ultimate point was that
having fun can often be the best form of
preparation because sometimes and this
is true of any discipline and from
people i've spoken to whether
mathematicians or writers that if you're
just you know in the weeds non-stop and
you're spending 14 hours a day doing
that
there's something called writer's block
right and sometimes you're just like i'm
not enjoying this and so when you get
that joy back it can actually help you
play even better or whatever the other
profession is and do that better
i agree with you but this uh is so
different once again from what i've been
thought to you know yeah the the model
uh
is completely different now than it was
like 20 30 years ago so you wouldn't
sacrifice everything
on the hotel of a chess game so
i think
bringing the joy and the element of
pleasure is very important when you do
something even on such a high level
yeah and i have one last thing to add on
that topic
i think there will definitely be people
who
hold it against let's say eli raza for
quote-unquote not taking it seriously
enough or quote-unquote self-sabotaging
the rest of his chances you know he
doesn't care because he knows he can't
win the candidates i think
to be completely frank that's that's an
absurd accusation
and i think none of us can possibly
imagine the pressure that these players
are under we're literally in madrid
we're like 100 feet from the players
we're breathing in the smoke of the
tournament and yet we still can't
possibly imagine
all of the influences all of the
pressure that these players have to deal
with morning to night from the moment
they wake up and step into the shower to
the moment they pull back the blanket at
6 00 am
and lie down for five hours of sleep
before playing nepo so
i don't think we need to always take
everything so seriously i think it's
it's a given that all of these players
want to win more than anything in the
world because this is what they do they
live and breathe chests and like you
said sometimes having a little bit of
fun
two hours of levity two hours of just
blowing off steam
sometimes that can be helpful and
you know i think we should be
we should relax i think the conversation
would be different if janna pump she was
doing it oh yeah because it's true all
the seriousness that already has been
given this tournament has been working
out
so he needs to change something and if
that something is just playing online
blitz then you know go for it but if
yonda pomshi had been playing
30 second chance all night we'd be like
what are you doing you're about to win
the candidates uh that's not good
preparation so i do think that it
depends on the person we have alireza
frugia on screen here he's working hard
at the chess board he will try to take
down yonder pomsching in what is a
really
interesting game with chances for both
and
well
he's
going to be working for a while so i
think it's a perfect time for us to go
on our first break of the day but don't
worry we certainly will be back with all
the coverage from the 11th round of the
2022 fide candidates and this tournament
it's ongoing but we have many other
great events even when it concludes we
have the i am not a gm speed chess
championship we have eric rosen the
stalemate king taking on james canty the
third who's been razor sharp in his
battles recently so that will be the
finals of the i'm not gonna speed
championship thursday july 7th 10 30 a.m
pacific
uh 7 30 p.m central eastern european
that's european not central eastern i'm
on eastern time in new york so that's in
my head it's european time right here at
chess.com be back for more from the
palacio de centonia in just a few
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botes gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com
insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
[Music]
we always say we are a family the people
who come here
say that it is like being home
everyone is very comfortable here
for
[Music]
the defending champion jan napomnishi is
back at the candidates affecting his
second straight bid to challenge for the
world chess championship
one of the more experienced players nepo
brings to madrid an aggressive style
that is both challenging to face and
entertaining to watch
two years ago nepo made the most of his
debut in the candidates with a round to
spare he won the event in convincing
fashion
that's all he needed yon napomishi is
the 2021 world chess championship
challenger
that victory led nepo to a world
championship match with carlson and also
secured his return to the candidates in
madrid this year
despite being one of only two players in
the field to have won the candidates the
expectations for nepo were not
particularly high this time around
however his confidence from having won
here before in addition to his years of
competitive experience
may offer him a shot to turn some heads
if nepo should pull a major upset and
face magnus carlsen again the two know
each other well
nepo has competed against carlson for
decades ever since the two prodigies
were 12 years old
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing the
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines
there are more than fifty thousand chess
puzzles and a whole library of
entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kit helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh that clip always makes us laugh
there's already a frustration we have a
special guest in the studio
robert told me my microphone working
it's
it's honestly mono to be here you know
it's um my plans you know i was supposed
to be in zagreb
but um you know
candidates are going on you know my
flight scene it was diverted too much
readable places and um i found out you
know robert doing commentary and decided
you know
to step in for a little bit you know
well i'm glad that huge chair didn't
did prevent you from coming here how
many people believed it
i don't know how many people believed it
but it's funny every time this is
international master elmira scripchenko
grand master daniel nerditzky i'm grand
master robert hassan we are here at the
2022 feed a candidate's tournament yon
napomshi is the leader he is taking on
that player that you see on your screen
in front of you that is ali reza faruga
the 19 year old iranian french player
who has the world in front of him in
terms of his chest but this tournament
has not been his event and as we pull up
the standings remind you of where we sit
heading into today jan napomshi at seven
out of ten he has been playing out of
this world but there are three players
trailing him who also are competing with
each other for second place
well first of all i wanted to say that
yanni pomneshi is on the verge of
winning his second candidates tournament
this is
already historical achievement but
back-to-back win
i think there was only one player that
achieved it
it was vasilis masloff we were talking
about the tournament so
his
chess was simply
brilliant at this tournament even if
not perfect at times but i think that uh
he he managed to uh
well to um
well to deal with everything
in
the best way possible
yeah i mean dania he's been
incredible and again we look at that
right hand side of the screen zero
losses for yon napomshi he says that's
what it takes to win the tournament an
unbelievable performance and i want to
repeat something so you have to exit
kasparov mode and he goes you know an
unbelievable and unbelievable
what was i going to say scratch that
what i was going to say before
is that and i think i made this point
after the second or third round or that
i was commentating
this is often the wrong foot but
basically after jan lost to magnus
a lot of people succumb to this kind of
recency effect where they look at a
player's most immediate tournament
performance and they make all
conclusions on the basis of it and they
say well young got crushed by magnus
he's done for he has no chances in the
candidates what are you saying jan is
one of the favorites he's played well in
the candidates before he plays well in
very important tournaments he has a
track record of playing well under
pressure yes he had a bad world
championship he wasn't just playing
anybody everybody has had a pretty bad
world championship against magnus maybe
save for fabiana carolina but even they
succumbed under pressure when push came
to shove so let's not jump to these
conclusions and let's realize that while
it's incredibly impressive that yon is
playing as well as he is i'm not all
that surprised it's freaking young upon
you for god's sake well somebody who
never jumps to conclusions is the man we
see on screen fronts five minute caruana
he always calculates before he makes
decisions he doesn't speculate he's not
somebody who will
take a decision lightly and in his game
the position has in fact changed from
where we left it we saw that the pawn
was pushed at the board by dingley wren
and now we see a pawn structure for
white that is
quite ugly but white is a pawn ahead so
we will rewind just a couple moves bring
up the analysis board here to show you
how it happened but it was a big
decision for dingley run to play b b3
and perhaps even bigger decision by
fabiano caruana to take with the bishop
on b3 almira what do you make of
fabiano's choice actually this is a very
important positional decision because he
doesn't want to play the position with
cb3 knight c6 he prefers to exchange
this well very bad bishop
uh against quite a powerful knight
and bishop b3 is
once again a very important decision in
this game
although i have the feeling that
the position is somewhat still balanced
uh because stink sacrificed the pawn but
he has superb bishops which might become
become active
at some point
so he
he will be able to activate his bishop
also via bishop a5
not immediately but
he has this
possibility
and daniel we were
kind of praising this knight on g7 what
an interesting gallop to that square but
maybe that's a horse that's not going to
be able to get out of the stable i'll be
honest i think it's time to start
thinking about
getting off the board and repeating
moves with knight f5
rookie 89 g7
because the reality is that white is
essentially out of fuel on the king side
the decision to play b3 i think was an
excellent one not only from a positional
point of view and from the point of view
of eliminating fabi's strongest attacker
on a2 but also from the point of view of
ruining the queenside pawn structure and
tying down the queen to the b3 pawn
anytime you play queen f3 now you have
to deal with the total destruction of
your queen side and once again ding
putting his queen's rook to incredibly
good use and with every ticking second i
feel like fabi
it's getting likelier and likelier that
he might just admit to the fact that his
opening experiment hasn't really been
successful and half a point is better
than zero points although it looks like
that admission might come even a bit too
late because after the move rook e7
no longer are you telling me knight f5
isn't good here there's no longer the
same pressure and then move knight to f5
hoping to just make this draw it seems
that black can simply take on f5 and
after knight takes f5 that this rook can
come up to e6 there's no bishop stopping
it from going there and queen f3 there's
98 i think the rook slides over to g6
that's right perfect defense here for
black's pieces
okay
i'm here too late for that if fabiano
can't bail out
are we starting to sense that he might
be in a bit of danger
could be i was also looking at the move
rookie 7 queen f3 but you might as well
have their knight e8
right you're attacking my knight i move
my knight and i may not win your piece
but after the simple trade there is no
attack at all for white this bishop may
look scary but your queen is never
getting to f6 with my bishop covering
the square and as we've been
highlighting b3 b2 all these problems on
the queen side exist
i mean at least strategically speaking
the position is actually horrible for
white and with the queen on f3 you even
have this possibility of playing f5
oh my goodness 5'4
yeah this is nasty
wow
so
this could be a problem for fabiano
because when you get your knight into
enemy territory as we've been
you know looking at this knight on g7
you also want to see can i just go back
and forth make a draw if i need put that
in your back pocket continue calculating
it doesn't appear that he can easily
just make a draw with knight f5 and
knight back to g7 as we were just
looking at so
as
fabiano now
he's spending 15 and a half and
more minutes on this move i think he's
recognizing the danger of his position
and
well we're going to take a step back
because somebody else who
may not be recognizing the danger of his
decisions is alireza for ruja if we look
at the bottom right hand side of the
screen amir you were talking about
putting that pawn in g4 but it was with
the king on the other side of the board
and safe over there with that king on h1
alireza pushes the pawn up to g4 it's
clear that ali raza came to play he
didn't come just to sign score sheets
make a draw have a peaceful game no he
really really wants to win this one that
exactly illustrates dana's point because
it's not so easy to chase those knights
so he decided not to start with f4
he started with a
more dangerous move g4 because it's a
very uh committing move
so um
he wants to play g f4 and g5
and take even more space advantage but
it
could easily backfire
yes this is a move you can't take back
because whenever you push a pawn
unfortunately the rules of chess
stipulate they don't get to return to
squares they previously occupied so
g4 a really big decision we see yan and
alireza out of their chairs dingley wren
not seated the board hikaru nakamura not
at the board is there anybody
have they even playing i i don't think
young chistov duda i see his blazer
behind five minute carwana he's not the
oh no he is the boy just leaning in i
was tricked but timothy not there so the
players i think they're taking their
mid-game break maybe getting a little
snack taking a stroll but they
most of them are not robert
where is it being held is it the
velocity of the center
miss amigos yeah and why didn't they
invite their because we're not their
amigos we're not leaving a legacy no
we're not here to leave a legacy but g4
will leave a legacy and
the thing is this would be a great move
in a 30-second game this would work like
a charm in a hyper bullet game
my question is what alireza plans after
h6 because
hi everyone i'm sorry but we're
experiencing some technical difficulties
here in the studio i hope you'll be
patient with us as we get things in
order
because if you play g5 anyway
obstinately then black will take on g5
and don't forget about that v2 pawn
which is still hanging
hi everyone i'm sorry but we're
experiencing some technical difficulties
here in the studio i hope you'll be
patient with us as
maybe he wants rogue g1 after h6 but
this kind of reminds me of g takes f6
yesterday robert it seems like he's
trying to force
hi everyone i'm sorry but we're
experiencing some technical difficulties
here in the studio i hope you'll be
patient with us as
it is very very clear that he is playing
to win
and i'm going to predict that this game
is going to end in a win for earlier as
our win for yan
hi everyone i'm sorry but we're
experiencing some technical difficulties
here in the studio i hope you'll be
patient with us as
g1 after h6
but this because f4 just drops the pawn
on g4
hi everyone i'm sorry but we're
experiencing some technical difficulties
here in the studio i hope you'll be
patient with us as
he's not gonna just make a move quickly
because after knight e3
you have to give up the piece but you
give it up here that way you get b2
h3 is hanging d5 is still weak and
it is
a mic
hi everyone i'm sorry but we're
experiencing some technical difficulties
here in the studio i hope you'll be
patient with us as we get things in
order before we return back to the
broadcast this video will now play on
loop
hi everyone we're experiencing some
technical difficulties here in the
studio i hope you'll be patient with us
as we get things in order in order for
the broadcast to return this video will
now play on loop
hi everyone
you know we can see the evaluation we're
going up but the major point is that you
can keep files closed from rooks so h6
has just been played by jan but it's not
a decision he took lightly
well let's say
white plays f4
okay
what other move candidates do we have if
not knight g4 knight c4 yeah the
knight's going to one of those two
squares knight c4 g5 and then there's
total pandemonium on the board
but yawn is very good in such positions
like this is a very concrete position
you know how good yon's calculation is
but not just calculation in general
calculation in these incredibly concrete
chaotic positions you don't want to mess
with nepo in these situations and
farouza
i'm starting to get a little bit
concerned this move g4 robert oh mira
i'm i'm a skeptic
until proven otherwise
yeah maybe it just looks so attractive
because of the idea of g5 also knight f5
is not out of the question you want to
bring your knight to
an attacking square and if it's captured
i mean i'll just put that on the board
if you catch this knight because it's
annoying you and the pawn takes we've
also opened up the line in front of the
black king so there's no immediate
checkmate nothing like that but white
has the bishop pair an open file to go
out for the king and maybe alireza's
looking for something like this as well
of course and i was thinking that
well dinah said that what would happen
if eliriza wins this game but if janua
win this game this secures him the
tournament victory basically
and then they're going after me
yeah everyone will be mad for alleriza
staying up all night but alireza comes
in this tournament as one of the highest
rated players in the field we see that
he was third in the world before the
tournament started but when this
tournament ends it might be yonda
palmachi with that world ranking despite
entering at number seven and he has a
winning record he has won two in a row
against alireza fuja so yanda pomshi
with his second canon's appearance he
might be making his second candidates
win and he has beaten magnus four times
unfortunately for him zero of those wins
came at the last world championship
crazy that he's beaten magnus four times
anybody who's been magnus like more than
even once
that already says so much about them
and every time that i look at jan's
stats and his play in this tournament
i'm honestly just amazed that he didn't
give magnus a better fight i feel like
that was just an anomaly but that's what
makes magnus magnus like magnus
he circumvents and supersedes any stats
any form it doesn't matter magnus is
still going to be magnus yeah you know
you could say if game six the what ifs
if game six had gone differently if you
hadn't uh lost that game after an epic
struggle of eight hours of chess then
maybe he would have put up a better
fight maybe he even could have won the
match but as soon as game six that
result was in the books jan de palma she
is the story's been well told he's he
collapsed after that well actually i
don't agree with this analysis because i
think that a yen
went until after the game two
okay because uh
he had the winning position but once
again from the human perspective which
was not an easy win
and magnus sort of outplayed
him in his own style
and i think that this one one of the
most important moments in the match oh i
don't disagree that was important but if
you know if he did if he draws game six
it almost certainly is a different
storyline maybe magnus still wins but
you know whether it's uh game two game
six i think dyna's point is a good one
that you know yonder pomoshi against
magnus carlson
it could be a very exciting match even
though we all know we're not going to
pretend otherwise that magnus carlsen is
the heavy-heavy favorite no matter who
he plays in a match he's just that
strong and perhaps that's just one of
the reasons that we keep talking about
he might not want to play anyone that's
not alireza because for him it could be
what's the point
well those matches are very tough and i
think it's this is also one of the
reasons why we're why we are trying to
preserve the chess tradition
in determining who is going to be the
world champion after like a
cruel in march like before they were
playing like 24 games like till the six
wins now we increased the number of
games till the 14th but i feel that this
is very important to preserve this
tradition
yeah no i agree and well alireza
ferrugia you know he hasn't been alive
long enough to experience that tradition
but he's trying to create new ones new
you know let me speak of legacies he's
already is just stellar but he's looking
to
go to even higher heights it hasn't been
his event thus far he is calculating
against yonder pomshy he is throwing his
pawns forward and attacking
but
i mean i'm just looking now at the
bottom right because if ali reza faruja
can pull this off i mean it's really
these two matches and we will get to the
hikara game right after but dingley wren
i mean he has been
unbelievably strong
in
in the last couple of games he just
brought his king over after
we were left off here
five brings his rook towards the middle
of the board and after king h8 his idea
is very clear
knight g8 is about to attack this bishop
and the bishop ever moves the knight on
g7 is left unguarded almira this is
starting to look very problematic for
fabiano caruana
but
isn't it a bit suspicious what is
happening after 96 like it's the first
movement in queen e6 and bishop a5
and bishop a5 they did i mentioned later
before okay so you get your bishop just
to show everybody exactly you did
mention this two pieces are attacking
this rook so if the rook moves the
knight can get rid of itself for this
bishop so we're just gonna take the
knight on e6 giving up our rook now
white is ahead by a rook and a pawn for
just a bishop after bishop a5 double
attack rook on e1 bishop one f8 the
bishop would have to retreat it looks
like to h6 and after this this queen on
d1 has to go and capture the bishop
which means the b3 pawn falls and once
b3 falls guys
uh oh this is looking really problematic
for fabiano yes those pawns look like a
very beautiful greek ruin you know like
a4 b2 d3
or like dust and a parquet floor that a
vacuum is about to pick up
queen a423 rugby two ninety four nine
following mike flies you're going you're
going historical references i'm going
for the
yeah
this is bad
i mean the dark squares on the king side
do afford white a measure of counter
play but how exactly do you
squeeze something from these squares
because knight g8 can come at any moment
chasing that bishop out of h6 and
black's king seems to be pretty
satisfied i think as fabiano
considers his move he's visualizing
positions like this and even though we
can see the evaluation bar as only you
know half upon approximately better for
black he might just assume this is
losing right we talk about this every
single round the players they are using
their own assessment they usually have
very good evaluation functions but there
are times when they look at a position
and just say no
no way i'm not playing that because from
a practical human perspective it just
looks losing
and
you know if i can ignore the evaluation
bar for a second this looks
really terrible for white like way worse
than minus 0.4 but i had a crazy idea
here once again
white might play d4
and then e5 oh
okay so it takes an e5 just blasting
unfortunately i think there's queen d5
there's also obviously yeah rookies i
guess
i was considering rookie but
that's an idea which is in the air
for sure it doesn't work in in this
exact position
but with the opposite color bishops you
need to open some diagonals
and it goes also to show that maybe
white's position is feeling desperate
already trying to open up the diagonal
you would like to get in the dark
squares you only have one piece this
knight can always slide back to g8 and
we're on an analysis position but this
might be what fabiano has to do because
if we go back to the live board and
analyze other variations then move
knight g8 like that's coming just to win
this bishop over here so if you make
some random move like well that's bad
because the bishop can come to a5 let's
make a more reasonable move like
what
queen t2 or something knight g8
then that attacks this bishop and if
that bishop has to go the knight is
dropped and if you try to do the same
tactic now i can take your bishop over
here and when you take my rook i just
move my queen over and your knight is
just getting trapped on f8 has nowhere
to go it can take a pawn but two minor
pieces for rook that's gonna be great
for black and there's another issue if
we go back to the current position
white can also try to evacuate via f5
knight g7 to f5
but black can play either rogue g8 or
but i like rick e8 and the clever thing
about this move is that if you play
knight e3 and you say well now my
knight's out of danger all of a sudden
your bishop's in danger and the knight
on e3 cuts off the escape route from the
bishop knight g4 f5
slicing and dicing at white's pieces and
white loses a minor here
so
that does not promise too much relief
either
and fabiano's down now 22 minutes about
on the clock and he's already burning
nine plus minutes on this move this is a
really bad situation from this second
half of the tournament has been
just miserable he started a half point
behind yana pomshie after seven rounds
he had five out of seven that was a
great performance he lost to hikaru
nakamura in round eight he drew young
napashi who he needed to beat in round
nine in round 10 he tried too hard to
win with black lost to yanchez of duda
now here in round 11 against dingley
wren
it's not looking good for the 2018 world
chess championship challenger
not at all
this is a tough situation the loss of
the white pieces would be a complete
disaster for fabi
and an incredible result by dings
somebody predicted a hat trick
i i just felt that something like this
could happen where fabiano he feels the
pressure to start winning again and he
takes a risky decision that he wouldn't
if this was the middle of some other
tournament that's not the candidates and
we see the position there's a knight on
g7 that should intimidate the black king
but king h8 by dingley wren just a very
calm move to try to go knight to g8 so
you know there's a big reason why we're
highlighting this matchup because the
fight for second place is so important
as you see on the graphic in front of
you there are eight players in this
event you should know their names very
well not just because of the candidates
but for every tournament they play from
here on out but only the winner
gets the right to play the world
championship match
but if magnus declines the top two play
for the world chess championship and for
fabiana caron it seemed like a certainty
earlier in this event there's no way he
could get worse than second he said
himself as he sat in dania's chair this
is a two horse race and
maybe he just spoke too soon and
something almer i don't know how to
you know figure out what it is but
something has just been off with him
well yeah we've seen this in his
latest games in this tournament because
there's always something which didn't
work and i feel that he's like his
energy is down you know uh his style is
uh consumes a lot of energy so as i said
he calculates a lot he goes for very
complicated positions sometimes he needs
to remember a lot of lines even if he's
going for a very dubious ones but
this means that you spent so much time
at the chess board and this is not just
a simple position a healthy position
where you're executing one plan you have
to calculate everything on like
every move so i i feel that he he's
really exhausted
yeah i i completely i think it's a
wonderful assessment
to some degree of course all players
striving for complex positions but for
fabi almira i agree he especially goes
for these incredibly tense positions
usually with all of the pieces still
remaining on the board i mean we saw
that here
and when his opponents are well prepared
and confident and when fabi starts
getting tired
that really backfires but i just can't
get past how quickly ding is playing how
confidently he's playing and with what
mojo and tactical awareness he's playing
yeah and a few things here i mean for
fabiano i believe he's in the mindset
that it's first or best i think he
believes that magnus carlsen will play
the world chess championship just by the
way he's playing right he took
unnecessary risk if he was just happy
with second place against jan schuster
yesterday he didn't have to play like
that so i really believe that he is
looking at first place and nothing else
and that's why he's willing to play in
such a style that we normally don't see
from him and then on the from the
perspective of dingley wren
if he can win this third straight game i
think the question that everyone wants
to answer to is
why not in the first half why did he
start three out of seven and in the
previous candidates he also struggled
mightily and then had the best
performance in the second half he beat
jana palmache in the final round he had
other great games so
to this point in his third candidates in
the second half of the tournament he
scored six wins with only one loss to
anish giri in 2021 and then
a bunch of draws so
plus five in the second half he might be
a slow starter but he is now trying to
catch up and it isn't necessarily too
late but i guess that's the big question
for dingley ren is
what happens in the first half
well and also i have the feeling that
now i've said it before his opening
preparations works and i i also think
that this is true for this game that he
has analyzed this position that's why
he's playing so quickly how do you think
he actually had it analyzed well maybe
not before this tournament but as he
said yesterday that was an idea he had
in well in store for a while yes and
he's very confident now
he um
i i also feel that there are different
types of player and thing is one this
type of player which increases his form
like which gets his form after a few
rounds
so maybe he needs
those rounds of warm-up you know
well he's certainly warmed up and it's
not
happy for fabinho car wanna he he looks
nervous right we talked about this
during the rounds that
he changes his posture when it seems
like he's nervous when he's confident
he's perched over the board he's you
know always ready to make his move but
he seems nervous he looks nervous and
it's going to be a struggle for him and
somebody who has benefited from
fibonacci struggles is hikaru nakamura
hikaru beat fabiano in their
head-to-head matchup hikara lost the
next game to timor-rijaba bounced back
into alareza ferrugia and now he plays
the man we see on screen who
he looked a little perplexed about
what's happening in his game so it's a
pretty big moment for richard report a
knight just came forward to attack his
queen we don't think that richard is in
the business of blundering his queen but
he's trying to figure out can i just
take this knight and f5 which of course
will be recaptured though
often times we assume and we said you
can never assume especially the
candidates that this is just equal it
doesn't look so equal to us does zamira
well first of all we got a very
important piece of information that
richard airport is playing this opening
for the first time in his life so that's
why maybe hikar was a little bit
surprised and it took some time in the
opening phase
and what
come to us maybe as natural you know
richard has to think about those
decisions you know in order to
get to total grasp on the position
because we might think and say like well
bishop f5 is out of the question because
this bishop on g2 is of course much
stronger than the bishop on g5 even if
we're talking about the opposite color
bishops
uh well
swashnikov player who played already
hundreds of games he will just brush
away you know this bishop of fight
movement i will say you know i certainly
will do something with my queen play
queen c7 and
bring the rook on d8 and
but on the other hand
richard doesn't like to be under the
attack
so he
he doesn't like the idea of keeping this
knight on the fight
and this pawn on d6 which you had
highlighted earlier is now under attack
twice so it might cost the pawn to move
the queen but i believe we agreed danya
that taking on f5 looks worse for black
even if the material remains evil i
think this is kind of a crime against
humanity when you have the option of
moving the queen but i i think the
question to which richard is dedicating
his time is
where he should put his queen and
there's a very interesting tactical
detail here move queen d7 at first
seemed
to me to be the most natural the point
of this move is that queen takes c6
seems to be impossible on account of
bishop takes f5 but if you extend this
line again no assumptions you got to
keep calculating there is the sudden
queen takes e5 skewering the two bishops
which are both undefended on the fifth
ring black loses a pawn
at a minimum and compensation is scant
so after queen takes d6 i think black is
fine but black might actually have to
trade queens here and seek compensation
in the end game now you want to play b4
in this position maybe you should start
with bishop g5 to e7 to get rid of the
knight and then play b4 i feel like with
that queen side play coupled with good
rook position and on top of it the
bishop on g2 which is really lame owing
to that e4 pawn
unquestionably gives like full
compensation for the pun so if anything
i think richard might actually be
looking for a way to put hikaru under
some pressure here yeah i think it's a
great summary because as almira was
mentioning that it's
rapport's first time playing this
fashion cove and if you don't know the
ideas you could just say you know i'm
gonna take on f5 of course he is a top
10 player he is fantastic but going down
a pawn is not an easy decision it does
appear that thanks to the queen side
play black can and should give this pawn
away on d6 and well somebody who knows
that kind of decision making well is
almera who's played this opening uh
throughout her life so you have to be
willing to give material and i think
richard is the type of player who's okay
with that well he's willing to give more
than the d6 pawn i think what he's
worried about actually like i think that
any queen moose is possible in this
position queen d7 queen c7 queen a7 uh
you know
pin in the f2 pawn so you want to have
this f4 move but what do you do let's
say i will play queen a7 uh how do you
continue after h4 i still want to play
this move
i guess i have to go back to
maybe not the most pleasant square and
here i have this possibility of playing
knight e3
so maybe he's trying to assess this the
resulting position
yeah and i think that the
little eval shifts are not important
because you know this b4 c4 this type of
position is really not clear but i think
the big problem for white is that this
bishop gets to wrap around to b6 and
takes advantage of all of these dark
squares that are now vulnerable you
don't have pawns to cover a d4 or c5
square that's a very important maneuver
if you don't play bishop d8 bishop
b6 in this position you are worse yes so
it's very important to have it like at
all times
and you know that this goes with the
understanding right
uh if you've played this position you
know that i need to get my bishop to
this diagonal even if it was on g5 we
have to go d8 b6 all that stuff and
richard doesn't look comfortable like he
keeps squirming in his chair he's trying
to figure this out but
i don't know if he's feeling as
comfortable as he should given the
true evaluation of the position of
course but
there's another idea he might not like
after knight s3 uh white uh has this and
not well another option like if we
simply get to the position which we had
on the board let's say queen knight
seven
h4 bishop b7
knight 93 if we just make some random
move uh my next move will be bishop f3
and bishop g4
so i'll just show that you just move
your king and the bishop gets up to g4
that's what white really wants is please
trademe we were talking about this
earlier so i'm glad we can show i
promise to be nice if you take my bishop
one sheep
right yeah right just take it i won't
hurt you with the queen it's not plus
almost two or whatever it is because
there's checkmate it's because you have
permanent control over this light square
against a dark square bishop so uh if
the bishop does in fact go to g4 in any
position
black often wants to leave the bishop
here and take back with the pawn but
it's very clear that the bishop one g4
is much better than the bish1 g2 stuck
behind its own pawn yes and all these
factors my
might influence richard
like towards which position he will lean
yes
yeah i mean i have a more general point
that i want to make really quickly
which is that
richard is playing this line as a
lumiere pointed out for the first time
in his life and that's a pretty big deal
um because he chose a very important
arena to play
a very committal opening for the first
time in his life but nonetheless we're
not making a very big deal out of it and
i don't think it is such a big deal but
50 years ago if he had done this this
would have been a huge deal if smithslav
in the 1953 zurich candidate tournament
had played the night or for the first
time in his life it would be the talk of
the town for the rest of the tournament
how could he do that that's such an
irresponsible decision but nowadays it
just shows you how much things have
shifted you can get a good sense of an
opening as report slides the screen back
to d8 interesting decision we'll get to
it in a second you can get your handle
on an opening in its ideas
literally in one evening i mean that's
all you need with the internet and the
fact that everybody has a team of
seconds that between them play every
opening
available and every opening that you can
play it's just fascinating how these
players just at a moment's notice can
change their mind and play an opening
that they've got absolutely no
experience with makes chess so much fun
to watch these days i'll push back
against that a little bit all right go
ahead as ali reza he played uh that
sicilian against yonder palmishi and he
had some preparation but as soon as jan
sidestepped that preparation he was in
trouble i agree that's the danger that
is the danger right and rapport i guess
he in a way benefits that he doesn't
really have openings he says himself
he's like i show up at the board i'll
play something that feels good my
openings from the black side in
particular they're very shaky i get in
trouble so sometimes having that
flexible style is awesome because you
don't feel the discomfort of someone who
you know is consistent with their
opening as like i know for a fact this
is bad and i feel
like it's worse than it actually is
whereas for richard he's seeing things
for the first time and he may be eyes
wide open like i see some pluses in my
position i don't know all the minuses
but he's doing okay and you use the word
committal and someone who made a very
committal decision is alireza ferrugia
so we're gonna zoom back out and go to
look at all our games because ali reza
faruja has not moved after h6
so when you play the move g4
amira
and then you don't move after your
opponent's response that's not a good
sign
this is certainly not a good sign but
on the other hand the position is about
to become very concrete especially after
f4 so this is where you need to recheck
every line so if that's the line that
he's calculating right now f4 especially
uh we've seen that after knight g4
knight f knight tg4
white has this
very interesting move h3
and then
black has to sacrifice well temporarily
sacrifice a piece
right we were looking at this exact
variation before where black has two
pawns the knight on c3 is under attack
the d5 pawn's in trouble the h3 pawn's
in trouble the white king
was probably less safe than blacks even
though there's an open g file so
this is a position you don't get into
lightly and alireza i mean he played g4
so his i don't know his instincts or his
desire told him that he should launch
some kind of attack but after yon's h6
which took away the g5 pawn push
now he's on the clock and
that has to be troubling where he spent
nearly 25 minutes only moved 16 and
throughout this event he has found
himself in immense time trouble
well maybe there is a hole in the line
which he was calculating so he's trying
to find the second best option
and
you know sometimes we read too much into
body language but
he's slumped over a little bit here i
mean he's trying to work through the
position but he missed something and
that actually could derail you
completely when you feel like you made a
good choice by thrusting your pawn to g4
going for an attack and then your
opponent plays a response you probably
thought was impossible or not good and
now you're like oh
that was maybe not the right choice and
he's still thinking yeah you swam five
miles into the ocean and now there's
kind of no way back it's it would be one
thing if he had moved a minor piece and
then realized oh i kind of forgot about
a detail let me move that piece back
sometimes that's not the end of the
world right
my old judge gregory kaidanov would call
that saying sorry
uh you can say sorry and play g4 g2
unfortunately that would also be illegal
so alireza has already made all these
weaknesses he didn't think it through
well enough i think that's very obvious
given the amount of time that he's
thinking and his body language i think
it's likely that he missed knight g4 to
e3 in the event of f4 although what
surprises me is that after f4 black also
has knight c4 black literally has more
than one option
so
yet again for the second game in a row i
think alireza has made a mistake that is
very very similar to g takes f6 against
ikaro he's forcing it he's coming to the
game with an agenda that agenda is to
create tactical complications and rather
than letting the position come to him
he's trying to impose his will on the
position when you're playing somebody
who's in as good of form as yonda
pamishi and hikara nakamura you can't
get away with that and i think he's
learning that in a very very painful way
in the serious candidates
but i had another question dana don't
you think that those games actually
illustrate the very important points
that maybe
he's lacking something in his chess
education here like g takes f6g for for
example those who would study it between
chess school probably would never be
admitted
in the first place
of well if he if but winning would have
a glance at those games is that this is
not possible
that's true although bavinic also looked
at casparo's games and i think he said
that that kid has not not a lot of
potential but i would agree with the ole
mirror if i didn't have as much
experience playing him in blitz and
bullet as i did now you might say what
can blitz in 30 seconds just possibly
tell you about a chess player's
knowledge and education but you know one
thing i would always say on my streams
when i started playing alireza and he
still wasn't a gm is like this kid is
what 1415 at the time
and he plays like karpov like he plays
end games in a one minute game
in a way that i wouldn't be surprised if
a gm played in classical like he's
finding positional ideas in a 30-second
game that always impressed me about him
and i've made that point many times that
i think what separates him as you can
sense the frustration there he kind of
banged the table there what separated
him from the other juniors was his
gradual positional concept but amira i
agree with you and in this tournament i
think he's departed from that completely
he's tried to artificially change his
style and this is the result frustration
losses impulsive moves bad calculation
and just uncharacteristically bad play i
think his blessing was his curse that he
won too much
that he became so strong so quickly by
beating everyone in his path and you
have to recognize and of course he does
he sat in the chair and told us how much
he respects all the players competition
but you have to recognize that the
players here
are not necessarily the players you beat
along the way and he's beaten some great
players and there's zero disrespect that
says every single time i feel like i
need to
emphasize this that a 2670 player 265
those are great players obviously in our
elo system but they're not these players
and when you play them for 14 rounds in
a row and you come into game one against
timor java with the black pieces you
sacrifice an exchange you get yourself
in big trouble and then a few rounds
later you play against yonder palmishi
you play a really sharp opening with
some preparation as soon as jan deviates
from your preparation your position
falls apart then you play against
fabiano caruana you play an opening you
don't play and fabiano handles it pretty
normally nothing too
extraordinary just kind of good moves
and then again something happens where
uh alireza frugia mishandles it so i
feel like like i said maybe the fact
that he won so much that he's historic
and he is historic alireza farouja had
made history as the youngest player to
2800. he was hand-picked by magnus
carlson he said the pressure doesn't get
to him and maybe that's true in a sense
but i have to imagine that when you win
so much you expect to keep winning
because you're dominant but you can't
play that same way against this field
because the most important thing as
yonder palm she said time and time again
not losing and because jan hasn't lost
and some of these other players have
dropped a few games that's why yan's in
the lead i think alireza
his success has been his struggle here
at some point oh at the same time
well he said it so when he was in the
studio like i think it's so important
for him to prove that he belongs here he
did he belongs at the top level so
he would beat strongest players uh well
at the moment
uh that maybe this adds up
an extra pressure in him not winning the
tournament and he
he wants to prove that he is legitimate
yeah so you you would say dania that
those moves are mostly sign of his
impatience because he wants to win so
hard yeah i i don't think it's
i think it's exactly the fact that he
has departed from
his usual style if you look at his games
from todd of steel for example one of
his more successful performances
lots of brilliant positional wins i
remember a game he played against david
anton guiharo
that i showed my students quick queen
trade
literally yesterday in a hyper bullet
match i made this comment to myself he
trades queens every game he's out
playing me in these equal end games i
was playing the king's indian he was
taking on e5 95 of the time again what
can thirty second chess reveal about a
player's
chess personality well it reveals your
instincts and his instincts are in many
ways positional
yes he loves attacking yes he's young
yes he calculates well but he's departed
from who he is as a chess player this
tournament i think that's really hurting
him yeah and he looks like he's hurting
a bit because i think he's fiddling with
a pawn but his position now because he
pushes pawn up to g4 may be difficult 52
minutes oh my goodness he's going to
play a really important role in this
tournament i mean of course some of his
games already have been uh impactful for
the standings but he's in the middle of
his game against yondu palmistry right
now he plays young child stuff dude with
black but look at those final two rounds
he gets the white pieces against dingley
ren he gets black against five-minute
caruana a player who we struggle with
throughout his career zero wins three
losses and that can really
impact who finishes in second or even
first place
yeah
these are going to be critical
and hey this next move is going to be
critical this game is not over yet let's
be completely clear this game is still
going he's thought for over 30 minutes
but he has to avoid imploding his next
two moves are going to
determine whether he gets a worse
position that's defensible with maybe
some king-side chances or if he makes
another mistake he could lose this game
in five moves
which is it gonna be
well that is up to him he is on the
clock for over 32 minutes he's had some
big thanks in this event and perhaps
none bigger than right now against
tournament leader jan napomishi but we
can't only focus on the game between
alireza and jan three other really
exciting games i guess if we're honest
the bottom left game between teamwork
with java and yanchez of duda the pieces
are being traded that looks
level but still some chances for
both sides honestly because it's a
knight versus bishops that introduces
some special dynamics and
well if we look at the game between
caruana and dingley run that move knight
e6 was in fact played by caruana out of
necessity rather than any sort of fancy
tactics and
how many hyper bullet games in 30
minutes
well the average game takes about one
minute so
30 games yeah i don't know why in 30
minutes i was i was asked to ask you
that but that was pretty simple math
yeah that wasn't the most difficult math
yeah i mean or even more 30 35 games i
would say
yeah i have never played like a single
bullet game in my life you're not
missing much no you're you're this is
better fully yeah i'm serious your life
is better off this is even more
degenerate yeah this is 30 seconds you
don't want to do that you don't even
want to watch it
well it's like i played well actually a
blitz match against the lyrics i like a
few years ago and
well as you said everything comes so
natural to him like i barely so moves
the print on the board you know he
played so quickly and
i'm so happy that i won one game
i was dancing all around you know
the apartment so wow i mean alireza
she's still thinking here
and we we're analyzing some of those
possibilities between caruana and
dingley ren fabiano down almost 30
minutes on the clock and he's played
that 96 move dingly wren he looks cool
as a cucumber he's won two straight
games he's now looking like he's about
to make his move but maybe he didn't
expect
96 or there's something that he's
calculating more deeply because you
would think after 96 he would recapture
the knight but perhaps he's even
thinking about f takes e6 is there a
universe where this happens
i think there definitely is
the you know the drawback of f takes c6
is that it kind of creates more king
side weaknesses i think you will take
with the queen right just to show
your point is that the bishop still goes
back and once we get this position where
bishop takes and queen takes over here
that the rook comes down to b3 and the
pawn structure is less healthy rather
than the queen coming down into the open
well he has spent over 10 minutes here
so amir what do you think c6
likely i don't think so no no i don't
like this move at all and
i think he's
well he's simply calculating the line
with queen e6 queen b3 and
trying to assess
if he has like winning chances there
yeah we saw alareza sit for a big think
yesterday i take with a pawn rather than
with his queen
i don't expect dingley wren to fall
victim to the same fate but the more he
thinks the more i have to wonder like is
he
going outside the box but he can
comfortably play for an advantage with
queen takes e6 i think you're right that
he's looking deep into the position and
you know as
we highlighted and we've mentioned many
times now dingley wren he's a very
objective player so when we see a clash
between caruana and dingley rend there
are a lot of similarities there of very
well prepared players typically they
don't tilt although right now fabiano we
especially if this game doesn't go his
way we could call that tilting for sure
but these players have
not played all that many games between
the two of them but i i think they've in
many ways stabilized as a top five
player unquestionably well it's such a
different tournament trajectory yeah
those players before this game so
it certainly influences their choices
but i'm a bit worried here i cannot find
anything else than queen e6 bishop of
fates and bishop
a5 um
could you keep the square bishop on the
board and search for some compensation
or this is too much yeah i'm and also
dean just grabbed his head so
i mean maybe he's
he thinks he missed something
yeah he is
hmm he doesn't look comfortable all of a
sudden and that should give fabiano
caruana a little bit of breathing room
because he instead of being responding
instantly to every move that he plays
now he's sitting and thinking what
to us seems like a very natural reply uh
but
okay
we're gonna again zoom out for a second
here while dingley run thinks because
ali raised a farouza he threw his next
pawn up the board with h4 and yonder
palm she instantly replied with the best
move a very principal move rook to e8 so
oh my goodness he's just throwing all
the pawns forward holding nothing back
i don't think any of us are really
believing in it
he could lose this in
literally seven moves i mean i think
he's gonna play rook g1 yeah exactly i
think he's going to play rook g1
but then already black could start
invading the queen side with knight e5
to c4
and it's that fundamental fact that
white's pawns white's so overextended
here and to that
you know
very nasty soup
ali reza also added the fact that his
king is now wide open so if he plays g5
in this position the critical details
that black can take on b2
c3 hangs and if you take
after queen b2 gf you might say oh i'm
up a piece because i'm attacking e7
big deal bishop takes f6 and white can
resign because literally everything
totally collapses here
every piece is under attack literally
there's zero attack for white against
black's king so
this would just be a done deal
this is crazy this is the candidates
right here
first place on the line and you know
there's been a lot said about players
against yonder palmishi not necessarily
playing their best but jan always
deserves credit he
is
not necessarily taking risks but he's
making the most of those moments when
his opponents do too much so
ali reza he came today clearly looking
for result in chess you need to be
objective rather than subjective and
when you play for result you lose that
objectivity elmira
objectivity out the window and here come
those pawns but i don't think they're
coming soon enough
one jan is looking very calm once again
this is what impressed me uh
most during this tournament not only his
opening preparation it's also that he
navigated through the troubled waters
you know what
well he uh
forgot his preparation against hikaru he
um
he got poised once again so he saved the
game and
saved the game against also fabiano so
um
here he he knows already that he has the
advantage
and that's why he's playing very quickly
and i'm
i'm trying to look at the very direct
line what happens if uh white plays g5
immediately
so my h5 probably yep would you do if
playing knight g3
oh goodness another square to invade and
if rook to g1
and now you continue
assaulting the king side maybe with
knight e5 to g6 also preventing f4 oh
gosh look at these squares on the king
side f4 g3 h for e file d4 b2
it's like one of these uh
games where you just are playing hope
chess you're like i'm gonna throw my
pawns for and i'm gonna checkmate you
and then your opponent makes two very
regular moves
and then you realize that you can't just
checkmate someone because you want to so
for
all there is a ferruga where only 17
moves into this game he continues to
burn clock but more importantly he's
burned his bridges and there's nothing
he can do about it because his pawns
can't move backwards his position is on
the verge of collapsing and
i mean we've never really seen this kind
of dominance from a player in the
candidates and jan napomishi he made
history in the first half
he's looking to win another game
well this is certainly true but i wanted
well once i wanted to have one last
glance at that position that we analyzed
because if he's going to sacrifice
everything so g5 knight h5 okay we'll
analyze this just one second because i'm
trying to find a reasonable chance to
continue that did he make a move by the
way
sorry to interrupt mira i was just
saying g5
okay wow i
just wanted to um
to be sure about that line knight h5
rook g1 okay we will analyze this
position
yes my g6 and maybe well he simply takes
on h6
and b what did it mean
yeah although it seems completely lost
to me yeah yeah i could probably just h
knight g3 is a huge threat
everything is coming right i mean just
the attack is
there's no attack for white the zero
it's not like oh if i do this this and
this you know i get to your king give me
five white moves in a row and you still
can mate the king
what is it that elirez is even hoping
for here hope jess has to hope for
something i don't even know what he's
hoping for or is he hoping for knight t4
then not she takes h6 yes maybe
well
this is a different possibility this i
think is a more resilient chance i agree
and this at least keeps the tension over
here maybe
g6h6 is happening next
um i don't know if i can afford taking
on g5 but i'll look at it because if you
take with the bishop on g5 not only are
you losing sight of your pawn on b2 but
if i trade this f4 square is just a
problem you will have rookie four also
uh let's exchange sacrifice i'm gonna
have everything right like i can just
bring my knight into the f4 square
either night um
and there's just never attack even if
you push this pawn up to h5
oh that actually looks a little bit
annoying so maybe i shouldn't allow that
but it still is good for bill black has
many that's how good the position is but
i can bring my
knight into f4 over here
and
what happens then if i take with the
h-bomb
h3g5
but now the gentleman not with the
bishop ah okay before so here just take
yeah you could do that it
seems like it closes down the king side
so black's king is feeling much safer
and
bishop of fate
yeah bishop f5 just looks really strong
and nepal played in instantly i think
what'd he do
he took it took on g5 okay so
and then he's going to go knight h5 he's
going knights five and knight g6
transformer
yes
now nepo in the body language the speed
it's not that he knows he's gonna win
this game you never know whether you're
gonna win the game but
he's completely in control of the
situation i feel like he has this
position figured out he understands that
ali reza is playing hope dress he
doesn't buy it for even a second
and he senses that with a win
this tournament comes very very close to
being over he plays in that h5 he's up
32 minutes on the clock he's gotten up
from the board
what a disaster in the early going here
for ali raza and al eresa recognized it
as well and so will the other players
and it looks like dingley red in the
bottom right he did capture the queen on
e6 he has snagged that pawn on b3 so
we'll see if he can snap on the other
pawns in white's position still looking
pretty level in the game between yanchez
of duda and dingley wren you know just a
minor piece battle knight versus bishop
i would say white is probably slightly
better which java can play without any
risk whatsoever because the long range
piece and then in
nakamura against report it's an extra
pawn for hikaru but with that queen side
play and an active rook it looks like
rapport should be able to hold the
balance so with all that in mind we will
leave you with the games but we are
going to take a break and just remind
everybody of the upcoming
chess olympiad it's from july 29th to
august 9th in chennai india the
countries will send their best players
competing against one another for gold
medals it's a really really exciting
event happening from between july 29th
august 9th 2 30 a.m pacific time and you
know you can look up your time zone if
you are elsewhere
so it's going to be fun we're going to
get back to the playing hall here in
madrid there is a fruit on the clock
we'll see if he can dig deep find any
chances but it's not looking good this
is the 11th round defeated candidates
2022 coverage brought to you from
chess.com live from the palacio des
antonio
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botez gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
apparently this is the horse she rode in
on literally queen isabella herself on a
night a noble steed you know changed the
world forever it's why
everyone in madrid
knows the game of chess
they know that the candidates is here
they know that uh that this is
one of the capital cities of our great
game and it's all because of that lady
right there on that noble steed now
that's annoy thank god for queen
isabella changing the rules right and
giving the queen her powers
i know that in the filming we're really
running with this but in my head it was
the queen of france so that begs the
question who is the chess.com historian
and can i fire them um
well you'd have to fire yourself i think
yeah that's a good point
that's uh call that's an out take i
believe they call it him yeah i'll take
so mike's gonna say was the queen of
spain next time he knows yeah he knows
yeah we gotta find more about this lady
and find more about what the people know
here
[Music]
you guys excited for the candidates
hey can we talk for a second about this
here we go
to the plaza we go
which way's the plaza
you guys play chess yeah yeah yeah
there you go
are you excited for the candidates yeah
yeah
yeah
you know what it is you don't know what
it is
okay what is it we've watched the
queen's game oh you watched the queen's
game of it me too okay you guys actually
play chess like on your phone
what are you playing chess.com yeah
you're about 1300 on leachates so it
means you'd be like 900 on chess.com
actually yeah give me your username i'll
give you a diamond membership
not kidding he's going to be a contender
in like three years
he's up and coming so i'll give you a
premium membership and then you won't
have an excuse then you can use that
i'll go back to it yeah all right man oh
you're an am that's me man
yeah so this tournament decides who
plays magnus carlson
so the next challenger comes out of this
tournament all right guys enjoy thank
you so much have fun so much see a great
trip guys there you go no drinking no
drinking
still no drinking that's true you guys
are connected now yeah no we're buddies
on we're gonna send each other some
ticks do you think they already talked
and then we'll
we'll talk about it is that your phone
buzzing they are there they already yeah
they're already hitting me up for my
digits okay yep maybe wearing a pager
wasn't the smartest idea to fit in with
them
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chests or
mini chest variants and with any
starting position you want club arenas
are the most flexible tournament format
on chess.com try one out today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates the most important tournament
in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
and he definitely knows that he hasn't
made his 40 oh no
oh my goodness
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
[Music]
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
and what a legacy these players are
leaving at the beautiful palacio de
centonia the artwork is incredible we
see sculptures we see paintings and we
see beautiful chess games played the art
on the board
all around this palacio we have the
spanish commentators we have sculptures
and
bronze statues
but we have great chess and that's what
we're here for at the 2022 fide
candidates tournament ali raza farouja
when we left him he looked dejected now
that we're back
he looks even more upset about his
position i think he feels that the end
is near
well
this is one of the toughest moments for
him in this tournament once again
[Music]
well i i don't even know what to suggest
in this position because
the
play for black is so obvious 96 we
we proposed this move once before and
white's position will collapse sooner or
later
yeah well one game is actually about to
include i just caught in the bottom left
the game between rajab and duda they've
traded those minor pieces that was the
only imbalance so they will just shuffle
back and forth and make a draw that
results is in zero doubt but the other
three games
i would say
have a lot of life left to them and we
might even catch this handshake right
now i think we will between jan chistoff
and timor so with the black pieces john
schuster after a win yesterday he's
simply going to make a solid draw with
black today
yeah we're watching them
make the final moves of the game they
are going to find i think a three-time
repetition and generally
when there is a rule against offers the
players exchange eye contact there's a
slight smile and that essentially is the
unspoken agreement to start repeating it
was rook c7 rogue b2 or something
or rogue b1 rook c3 rook b8 in one way
or another
yeah you just you just pick a square
your opponent picks one and there we go
you just make the draw i think for java
just picked a and b8 dudas c3 and c2
and the handshake is imminent
a very even game between these two so a
draw is a fair result my job of looking
at the scoresheet he's like can we just
make the draw we don't need the arbiter
now just let us shake hands and
well we're java this is it this is
always good to see though right when the
game ends like was there a moment where
i could have pressed you a little more
rajab was talking to him about a moment
earlier in the game where maybe he felt
like he had a slight edge
well actually i found another argument
in favor of having the score sheets and
sign on them i think that if you refuse
to sign the square question at some
point
and if you want to make an appeal
this is actually necessary because when
you sign the scholarship this means that
you admit the defeat
if you want to make an appeal so you
should delay signing the
well they didn't needed to they were out
of there they're like i'm done with
today
all right let's go let's go grab some
gazpacho and some we'll put a guy and
gonna go rest well somebody who is
leaving the rest of the field behind is
yon napomashi he smells blood he is
trying to win this game and a couple
moves have been played by alireza
farouja but his position not looking so
good in the bottom right we have fabinho
caruana against ding li ren we've been
really liking dingley ren's position so
why don't we head on over there to see
what new has
uh transpired on this board and
oh okay
actually somehow it looks really good
for black but
bobby's queen on a5 if this pawn falls
we might get an outside passer
well actually i was looking at this idea
when we analyzed the variation with
queen takes b3 that was also another
possibility to play queen a5 there and
to activate the queen
you know do you remember we analyzed
here queen b3 and we were looking for
a possible counter play for white so
queen f5 existed even in this position
with the idea of playing queen c7
and queen is seven or uh taken on d6 so
everything is hanging from that c7
square
but at least here you would have queen
b6 i think that actually is the reason
why queen takes b3 is better ah because
offering the queen trade if you do in
fact trade queens here is a big problem
because now b2 a4 both under attack and
you're never worried about getting
checkmated without the white queen
he played bishop b7
ah he played knight g8 first yes to kick
the bishop out and then bishop b7 but
the worst is behind fabby
you know and in fact i'm not sure who i
would prefer to be here the queen is
probably going to drop back from a5 to
d2 its job has been done it's time to
defend the pawns
and then the rook from c1 can slide on
up to c3 in order to smoke out black's
strongest piece that work on v3
so when i look at this position i look
at the knights the knight on g3
dominated by the pawn three squares away
and i'm looking at this knight on g8
which did kick the bishop on h6 that's a
job well done but i would love to get my
knight to c6 and maybe the d4 or b4 so i
think both players need to figure out
how to improve their knights this knight
would probably like to be on a square
like c4 something like that so
eventually it's gonna maneuver over to
the queen side but as
we've been indicating two pawns are
under attack fobby plays queen d2 to
defend them both
and it's a very important move because
not only you defend the two pawns but
you can also transfer your queen to the
king's side and you
can play f4
yeah that idea still exists rook c1 to
f1 if black falls asleep followed by f4
and white comes pretty fast right on the
king side wow that's a surprise to see
that white actually has an attack after
all that it felt like dingley wren
he should be the one putting pressure on
fabiano but you're right f4
they're not too many pieces defending
this black king so f4 especially with
this rook over on b3 not somewhere in
the center it's a good opportunity for
five on the strike and neither player is
in their chair and we see
the size difference between those chairs
i mean i can't get over that that's
honestly really funny i don't know
what's more important to this game the
chair size difference or the time
difference between the players
oh my goodness so dingleron especially
requested that i think there was a large
chair sitting there and he said let me
get a normal sized chair do you remember
that tournament i don't remember which
tournament it was there was a tournament
where the players got to choose their
own chairs i was the candidates the last
time it was the last candidate but it
looks so weird there was like a white
shirt of black dirt a short chair and a
tall chair everybody had a different
chair at least here we have a measure of
consistency well why do they have such
tall chairs yes anybody like tall chairs
and this isn't just a culture it is a
it is like the size of robert wadlow you
know tallest person in history i know
why they
have the tall chairs they did it for the
memes so that we could get that uh clip
going with gary you know with the
massive chair at the end what is the
purpose of that back i don't know i i
don't make chairs is it made for just
sit in them i don't know bob on mariano
they are really really large but
uh you know that's of lesser importance
than the games being played while the
players sit in those chairs and
well dingley run he's now trying to
search maybe he can find a second
advantage after it seems like the first
one that possible avengers escaped him i
don't think this one is going to escape
jan napomneshi because the last move
played by ali raza farouja bringing his
king
closer
to
black's pieces that seems to be a risky
choice but jan
he pours that t
he makes a face or two but when all is
said and done and he calculates this
through i think
he is going to find a way to break down
white's resources
well and look at their postures
it's
so obvious that eliza is looking more
than someone who is
well going to
[Music]
wouldn't say to lose but to endure
a very difficult game
and jan is very confident once again he
uh well he's calculating knight g6
what can we um
well knight six is actually the i think
the only
legitimate move for black and then f4
the point is again this knight sacrifice
on four and it's the b2 pawn that kills
white in the end yeah refreshing show
that f4 is a big threat for white
because both knights will be under
attack so uh knight g6 removes the
knight from the center and we'll analyze
this
here for you so the knight on e5
it's getting the boot anyway so knight
to g6
it aims to go to the f4 square so
uh as
white you want to stop that right after
you have to cover it but we keep
highlighting this i can take
once you take back but not with that at
that piece
now you've left this pawn on b2 the
bishop had an important job so the queen
just takes on b2 this knight is hanging
this knight's under pressure this
bishop's under pressure this bishop is
under attack and the white king doesn't
have too much shelter
right jan has made a move and it is
96. for a second i thought he moved to
rook just by like that yeah yeah yeah
same i didn't think it was knight g6 at
first
but it is and he's obviously aiming for
this line and i was thinking for a brief
moment that elireza might want to take
on f4 with the rook
um the point being you're at least
getting rid of black's knights but after
bishop f4 queen b2 94
i thought okay white's got the minor
pieces in the center but there's a
beautiful move here rook c8 to c4
exploiting the pin
skewering three pieces on the fourth
rank and after bishop e3 another blow
bishop takes you by bang and everything
collapses i mean three minor pieces in a
row first on a rank now in a file and
everything has been a problem for white
and the king lacking shelter is the
biggest issue of all that is
an absolutely gorgeous sequence there
just white's minor pieces are
just
falling apart
uh robert and
if we come back to um to our previous
variation which we started with the 494
queen b2 what happens after
94 here
i guess roxas is the same
no but i have is rook c4 is still
possible it's incredible i and bishop b3
bishop g5 here still works same deal wow
this is such a beautiful geometry
i mean dania just pointed out so i was
like oh let's try it again if it doesn't
work we'll take it back but a queen sack
might be necessary here because why can
go rugby one in this position trying to
forcibly dislodge the queen off of the
second
ah queen a2 rook a1 so you know i can
make a draw back and forth if i want it
but if i want to play for a win bishop
takes c3
oh my goodness and then you take on d4
and even though at the present moment
black has
only one piece for the queen i still
think black is completely winning
well it's a
one piece and how many pawns like four
right but look at why it's king it's
wide open right if you try to save your
queen somehow with a queen move i just
take on uh e4 probably
this rook i don't know if it matters but
this king on g2 is in harm's way and the
king on g8 is very safe and that's the
thing about material imbalances
you know we can count the piece value
and say that four pawns and two minor
pieces uh that's actually better than a
queen but king safety is the most
important thing white king out in the
open with all sorts of checks and
attacks and the black king
can't touch this actually it's so rare
that we get such positions with all such
positional imbalance what do you think
that
will he go for this he's going forward
look at it he's not even here he didn't
think john didn't have to think he
immediately took this pawn on f4 and
we're going to see
these variations jan has worked this out
and for alireza
even the fact that after knight takes f4
he's still thinking is
a bigger issue so we have a comment mike
stanley saying 8 out of 11 if nepal wins
looks like a title tuesday score not
scoring the candidates
yeah eight of eleven is a really massive
score and so it's a spheric score it's
unheard of it's crazy and if nepo hadn't
revealed it in the interview yesterday
you wouldn't know this guy is nervous at
all i mean he's so calm he's sipping his
tea he's playing quickly
he's being himself he's being who young
she is at his best
he's every aspect of this tournament has
been a success for him from the openings
to his middle game play to the way that
he's handling these tactical
complications just look at his form it
is supreme although he arrives a better
take on four with the bishop because if
he takes with the rook he loses
immediately due to that rook c4 move
right but it is good to be nervous but
nervous because you care not because
you're scared so you know having those
jitters it actually motivates you it
makes sure that you're not complacent
you're continuously thinking of how to
improve and so jan has been honest you
know it's clear that this tournament is
very stressful he's tense but the way
he's playing is very loose in a good way
not in like i'm just going to throw my
pieces away and do that but he is
playing just for the position so jan
napalm she deserves a lot of credit i
hope he's been getting it from all
around the globe because
a lot of people coming to the event said
oh yan that was a fluke he lost a magnus
it wasn't even a match all the things
the naysayers said were kind of
unprompted and maybe not totally fair
but he came back to his second candidate
and said
sign me up maybe he's just only playing
the candidates his rating will go
through the roof that's right he'll be 2
800 plus soon
i think that tiana is also a player that
need those adrenaline rushes you know it
makes him feel alive so when he starts
playing the game of chess
he um well he needs these jitters as you
said
but
coming back to the position they have
enough another
you want to analyze some more so bishop
before queen b2 i wanted to go knight b5
then okay like i'm running out of
options so knight cb5 is this possible
okay so if i take you on
b5 well knight b5 then you simply take
some thick on g5
i think i do
oh this is painful
and on the intermediate rook b1 you
still have green a2 i mean before taking
right places so this doesn't work either
oh it's just
this is as clearly losing as it gets and
alert he recognizes it when somebody
plays knight takes hf4 after you put
your pawn there and you have to think
no good
no good this is i mean already i don't
know if he's just not seeing things
today or if he
bluffed with his pawn pushes or if he
really did believe in his attack but
he's the one about to get attacked and
his king is the one in danger and he's
about to lose several pawns and with the
the game yeah this was this was a
complete collapse and and i think we
you know yesterday we were inclined to
give him the benefit of the doubt when
he took on f6 of the pawn because he
hadn't yet lost a game on account of a
decision quite like that but once he
lost yesterday's game and once it
backfired we were a lot less likely to
believe him after he played g4 and i
think our
viewpoint has turned out to be correct
g4 was a complete bluff
it was very poorly thought out and the
fact that he took 35 minutes afterward
tells us that he's just doesn't have his
head screwed on straight today no
and you know as we look at him on camera
he's going to continue searching for
something right but
you know even the best splunkers in the
world are not going to find something in
this mess here he just position's going
to cave in yeah it really is i mean it's
just
it's out of his hands at this point if
yon de palma she doesn't find the
knockout that's one thing but we know
that these are the types of positions
jan thrives in so we have full faith in
his ability uh but as we zoom away for a
second from alireza and look at the
remaining
games we see that in the bottom right
500 karwana has in fact pushed his pawn
to f4 so he is gaining space in the king
side and i think he feels like he has
some chances here and in the top left we
have hikaru nakamura taking on richard's
report and in that game report he he's
you know sitting there he's trying to
find something but the material is now
even before white was up a pawn after d6
fell now it's even material so
it's looking like rapport has done a
great job yeah rook c8 i think in that
position on the top left
um
and you have mutual destruction
of the queen side i think if somebody
has to be careful it's probably black as
we pull up
the game here because the knight on e3
still has potential access to the d5
skirt but
in reality richard absolutely no
problems he can also shift his bishop
from e6 to d7 a slightly more passive
approach
but because there's only one target to
defend
and that target is
counteracted by white's target on c3
i'm
going to anticipate with 95 certainty
that this game will enter to drop pretty
quickly
i think roxy iii would be like c8 or
there would be five for c3 you still
have to be careful because
you have this possible target and this
is the e5
so if i will be able to play bishop g4
comfort let's say i would exchange those
bishops
uh
there still would be a draw like in the
rook and game yeah
but
you'd get tortured potentially
yeah this is a possibility
no it's looking like with
so few pieces remaining that this
should be
a position where neither side is feeling
any real pressure and that seems to be
the absolute most straightforward line
just bring your rook to attack the pawn
keep up your opponent on b5 and if we
just go back in this game because we
left off after queen d8
hikaru grabs that pawn on d6 we see a
queen trait on black's turn i like that
move g6 a lot by the way attacking the
knight forcing the queen trade bringing
a rook to the open file and the next
bunch of moves h4
kicking the bishop back now the knight
comes e3 just a nice idea to make sure
that the bishop couldn't
ruin white's pawn structure and after
rook d2 b3 a4 was played and a very
instructive moment by a car he did not
take on a4 and try to keep his extra
pawn with movie a3 these don't look very
good the bishop can always slide back to
put pressure here the rook comes the b3
so this would be playing for a loss
rather than playing for a win
i still feel that queen d8 is a small
inaccuracy in this position and i don't
like queen d6
i would still go for h4 here
and 93.
right so no matter what knight to e3 and
amira is still
trying to press for a win by controlling
this d5 square
not really pressing for a win but uh
well as you rightfully point it out
those end games after you sacrifice your
pawn
uh
might eventually uh get better for black
yeah i mean richard
tried effecting something like that but
you know as we've come to expect a
karazhan game play with stellar
and i don't think
either side had any realistic chances
once they got into this end game yeah so
this one is looking like it should be a
draw we are going to back up
and go to
the game between fabiano carwana and
dingley wren because so much has changed
here and we are praising dingley wren's
play the fact that he'd won two games in
a row but as we look at the position as
it's evolved this is looking really good
for fabi all of a sudden the person who
was previously in second place who with
two losses in his first three games in
the second half one draw sandwiched
between them now
if he brings his knight up to f5
he's going for an attack a t5 once again
yeah i mean if we backtrack here f6 was
played and after f4 we saw a trade and
dealer and playback very funny
move
but it's concrete he's trying to go
after the b2 pawn yeah in fact it does
look kind of good for black at first
glance you hit the knight and the pawn
on b2 is under attack so dingler must
have thought that this would be good for
him but if this knight jumps into f5
after rook takes b2 do i have this
opportunity to play d4 perhaps
but before i have ah
d4
is a very pretty move rook takes d2 i
guess it's forced yes right because i've
cut okay circulation d e and just maybe
rook d3 and somehow black is holding
rook d this is a very important move
here because you're making contact with
the bishop immobilizing the knight
my thought was that if you move anywhere
else right even rook to e2 then i take
on d6 and i have a passenger going but
from
a ways away
didn't quite see that rook d3 was so
strong keeping that pawn stuck in place
and so after
he takes d6 his bishop takes an e4
this knight is under attack bishop is
under attack and it seems that when all
is said and done uh after knight g3
you try to take this bishop then the
king comes to f2 first i take the bishop
back and
okay it's looking like anyone's game
wow that's a cool line but if we come
back to the position before d4
the eva of r clearly seems to believe
that
following rook takes p2 there is some
sort of
tactical idea now that i do notice that
the queen on e5 and the king on h8 are
unforkable squares
so is there a move like
knight takes d6
well the fans are rooting for a move
like knight takes g6 a lot of i think it
worked cheering for fabi it's actually
quite simple rook takes d2
is forced because if you take the knight
you lose the rook right and the threat
is the bishop but more importantly than
i have seven check so rook takes queen
go around take the queen king has to go
and now this rook is under attack so you
can't just take this knight on e5 but
the critical final move you might say
wait a second rookie two and both of
your miners are hanging but you can move
the knight and simultaneously defend the
bishop and black is simply lost here
because you're going to drop the c5 fund
black's position is just completely in
shambles ding might have missed knight
d6 wow this is such a beautiful motif
yeah
i mean it's also
coming out of thin air like if we just
look at this if we go back
just so to around here when ding was
calculating this position he saw that
the bishop could take and for now the e5
square is covered so he just saw a
double attack which looks so normal in
this position to see that this knight is
going to take the pawn with the fork of
the queen right this is how mistakes
happen as the players search several
moves down the line is that they just
don't see
the uh
the distance they don't go the distance
seat the horizon and then after g5 it
looks like a simple fork unfortunately
things for ding not so simple thanks to
this
really
nasty tactic with knight takes d6
wow
but even if let's say
i don't see
knight d6 in my calculations
previously after rook b2 i think that i
can simply play
queen e1
that's why i didn't like this g5 move
because it gives me the opportunity to
jump on the f5 square and
well to seek for something
for a long term initiative we have a
bunch of
people chat rooting for dings so we had
some floppy fans also plenty of ding
fans but you're right amir that you know
even if you don't win on the spot this
queenie one move it'll keep up the
pressure against this king over there on
h8 so
i'm with you this
f6 g5 maneuver
it's odd i don't think it is cohesive
and i don't think it works with the
situation of the black king and the fact
that all these pawns are really weak
even without the tactics right d6 is
weak f6 is going to become a target so
yeah this looks like a wrong choice so
you know fabi very well what does his
body language
say now
like depends on whether he sees knight
takes d6 yeah he'll see it
no this is for fabiano this is uh a
piece of cake
because at this point it becomes
increasingly obvious like if he sits and
he's diving deeply right we're
suggesting moves bouncing around seeing
the eval bar he doesn't have there's no
one alerting him that's why i always say
the difference between playing a game
and doing a puzzle when you're doing a
puzzle you know that there's an answer
there if you gave us the five minutes of
puzzle he'd solve in three seconds but
he's not on alert that there's a tactic
and i've been a cruel coach in the past
where i give a a puzzle
quote-unquote that's just equal and so
like so i've had students sit they
calculate they do it like after a while
they're like i think it's just equal
nine to five on the board by the way but
they go it's just equal and then i'm
like good you solved it and they're like
what why would you give me a position
just equal i'm like because you need to
use your brain you can't make
assumptions like we've been saying all
event so now that we're here it's much
easier to see but also if you showed
dingley run this position and
then gave him an option to go back he
would never play g5 because now it's
really clear and as dingley wren sits at
the board he's going to look at that b2
pawn but he probably won't take it
because of the repercussions of knight
takes d6
i have a funny story on the subject of
puzzles being equal but i'll
save it for a little bit later i wanted
to put forward a hypothesis
um and we don't have to do any specific
analysis about where ding lost control
of the game i actually think it was
before g5 remember that moment
when ding took a while on queen takes e6
i actually think that
in that position he might have
mis-evaluated the situation and he might
have thought that the dark squares give
white a big initiative he might have
started souring on his prospect and i
feel like
that might have influenced the
subsequent course of the game if he
didn't like his position that might
explain why he didn't take on b3 with
the queen he might have been holding
himself back and thinking that he was
already on the defensive so if you ask
him after the game
i think that he might say that he
thought that he was already worse and so
he might not be too surprised now that
he's actually worse when in reality if
he had played queen takes p3 only black
can be better in that position so a
mis-evaluation may stand at the heart of
partially of what went wrong for ding
here in the middle game after an
excellently played opening
yeah now that very well could be the
case because you start seeing ghosts you
start worrying about your king and you
say my king on h8 a dark square a
darkstar bishop right in front of it
there could be a checkmating attack if
i'm not careful so you keep your queen
towards your king which is what he ended
up doing but unfortunately for him it
was the wrong choice and it gave father
not just like new life but the very
rapid play he opened the position up and
it's not like the king is that safe but
i mean
i'm looking at the top right here
alireza farrugia yonda panmashi we see
those three pieces in line the knight on
d4 and e4 and bishop and f4 will jan
find these ideas with rook to c4
it's obviously well within his
capabilities but he's he's double triple
checking he's verifying that it
actually is the right choice because the
last thing you want to do
is make a quick move
your opponent actually doesn't give the
pieces back and now you're down material
without a checkmate and you're like
that's not how this should have gone
what a complicated position we were
analyzing rook c4 but
this idea of the queen sacrifice i think
you guys would agree with me is very
very hard to find
when you're looking in your mind you're
saying okay rook c4 bishop d3
now yan will definitely see bishop takes
g5 that moves pretty obvious but after
rugby one it is really really hard to
determine
uh
that black
does well with the queen sacrifices if
bishop takes e3 after queen a2 rook a1
it's genuinely really really hard to see
maybe jan goes for this and decides to
make a draw maybe he goes for this
knowing that a draw is in his pocket i
think that might actually be the most
prudent approach and then slows down and
finds the queen sack that's a good point
that when you can put the draw in your
back pocket and then think about playing
for more that way you know you don't
actually carry risk because you can
always bail out with the half point uh
but almirah you know yonder palmishi
giving up his queen for all those pieces
it's got to be easy for him right well
i'm not so sure once again we were
talking about these unbalanced little
positions where
the material is so
also strangely uh divided i would say
that uh
growing up um
and studying a lot of classical games so
i would say that you know you wouldn't
see this very often
and this is a pure computer line for me
so he needs to be careful and you were
talking about seeing ghost it's very
important not to see a ghost in while
calculating this line
yeah i think that's fair it does feel
engine-like but if there is a player who
can calculate like an engine gianna
pompsie he'll be one of the first people
you name because he has this style that
is ambitious but also one where if you
put him in a tactical melee he solves it
right he has that's the correct style
for it whereas a player who typically
plays more solidly we've talked about
java throughout this event where he
likes
more quiet positions and then when there
had been certain moments it feels like
he doesn't take the risky approach and
it may just be a feeling rather than a
fact but i think for jan you know he
knows not just senses he knows that he
is winning here and that i think will
help him find the right path forward
well but another player who is training
for a tactical skirmish is a leader
zafiruja that's true so
is there a
could is there a possibility that both
of them could be
blindsided by something sometimes you
believe your opponent you and you don't
go for the variation
yeah i mean the position is incredibly
complex i think
that chair is doing a good job keeping
that was jacket on wrinkles that's the
reason why the chairs are told is to
keep the jackets under inkling how did
we not think of that the spool master of
course would
indeed but
the position is incredibly complex
there's this idea of rogue b1 or k1
and we've seen crazier things happen
nepo's win is not guaranteed he needs to
find
three or four more very precise moves
and i'm sure that ali raza is remaining
hopeful he's on to his second hour
you could totally see napo spending 25
30 minutes here and
polly russell can get him below 30
minutes i think that we might
uh we might be talking about a comeback
here but let's see what nebo chooses in
this position this is a critical moment
can he find rook c4 or bishop e7 to d8
which seems to be the other move which
preserves a massive initiative yeah
backwards moves are the hardest to find
in chess and we've had plenty throughout
this tournament bishop d8 we've been so
focused on the rook coming up into the
action bishop d i mean that might in
fact be the best move because the knight
on e4 is under attack behind it is this
bishop on e2 but it also walks into a
fork so i think this is
a much harder move to play even if it's
good the evaluation bar says hello black
is winning this knight says hello to two
different rooks over here and that
already looks wrong so the reason why
this is i guess so good for black is you
give up even more material if the queen
takes on e2 then you take on d4 this
bishop is hanging his king is wide open
we can see that black's pieces are
swarming but if the knight takes on e2
and the rook comes down here
if we just pause for a second
white is actually up a rook for two oh
just one pawn
so
yeah this is not an easy variation to go
down not at all
no and the line goes on like rugby one
and now if rook takes c2 check you slide
the king back to h1 and apparently rook
takes knight check is a mistake taking a
piece with check
so this game is far from over
and i agree with you robert bishop d8 is
a tremendously difficult move but and
before it is there was no way he was
playing
c4 is definitely the more human of the
two moves
rook c4
bishop b3 is forced
and that's the thing for all the reasons
he has no choice right he has to play
bishop e3 so he's thinking because he
feels like he's in trouble but he's
going to play bishop e3 right now and i
i'm curious how quickly
our tournament leader john de palma will
respond to bishop e3 because if he just
comes back to the board
doesn't even sit down and just plays
bishop takes g5 we'll be like jan sees
it all if he starts thinking that's
where you question
john you know it's the right thing to do
to think but you're like maybe he
doesn't see it all the way through well
bishop b3 is the only move in this
position once again so you cannot start
the line with bishops with rook c4 and
then think after bishop b3 so
i
i think that he
calculated at least till
point where he knows that it's a draw
and then he has a choice and we just saw
there was a yawn at the board so i
wonder why that might be a late night
of bullet chest not helping his
exhaustion levels and yana pomshi he's
looked fresh throughout the event he
really seems to be in good shape he also
hasn't played that many moves relative
to his competition and you know you
often expect if you're winning games
there have to be long battles against
the opponent you grind them down but
many of yon's wins have actually been
before the time controls so
he is a player who is in good form he's
just
kind of just crushing some of his
opposition and it's mesmerizing i used
that word before but it's true
because he spent in his three days in
his bed
right he said that's what he said yes
exactly this is pure discipline
yeah he knows what he's here for and i
think also when you're
nervous you know you've got
four rounds left or five rounds left and
you know you're leading the tournament
somehow the sites of madrid bishop takes
g5 instantly there's our answer seem to
be a little bit less beautiful than if
you're here as a tourist and i think
otherwise is going to play rogue v1
almost instantly
well he looks like he's about to think
and while he does so if you're new to
chess you didn't watch the last world
chess championship you might not be so
familiar with jan napomashi the top
russian player in the world so here's a
little profile you can learn a bit about
him
the defending champion jan napomnishi is
back at the candidates affecting his
second straight bid to challenge for the
world chess championship
one of the more experienced players nepo
brings to madrid an aggressive style
that is both challenging to face and
entertaining to watch
two years ago nepo made the most of his
debut in the candidates with a round to
spare he won the event in convincing
fashion
that's all he needed yon napomishi is
the 2021 world chess championship
challenger
that victory led nepo to a world
championship match with carlson and also
secured his return to the candidates in
madrid this year
despite being one of only two players in
the field to have won the candidates the
expectations for nepo were not
particularly high this time around
however his confidence from having won
here before in addition to his years of
competitive experience may offer him a
shot to turn some heads
if nepo should pull a major upset and
face magnus carlsen again the two know
each other well
nepo has competed against carlson for
decades ever since the two prodigies
were 12 years old
[Music]
well yonda palmashi the expectations
might not have been high from some of
the prognosticators but his performance
is through the roof we see his upcoming
schedule he looks like he's in the verge
of victory against alireza fuja then he
gets double whites against ikaro
nakamura and richard report before
finishing the tournament against jan
chistov duda
he can't be stopped
i mean if he wins today against sally
rosa i think his strategy is quite
simple i think he's going to try to make
draws against icaru and richard
um that is slightly risky strategy if we
think about it he wins this game today
he might jump to a two-point lead
so
draws are going to be perfectly
sufficient to preserve
a huge lead going to the final round if
he doesn't win today as alireza plays
rook b1 i think we're going to see him
changing his strategy a little bit and i
think we're going to see him taking a
little bit more risk against icaru i
know what i want selfishly
but either way this is a great final set
of pairings for yon he's comfortable
against all of these players
man oh man this guy is a beast
now we were discussing this before the
round started how difficult it to make a
draw with black when all you need is a
draw but on the other hand you want to
have a playable position so this this
fragile balance between having an equal
position and not a very passive one so
you
well you wouldn't be doomed you know
right well at some stages of the game
but here
uh it's probably a much easier task to
do so with whites especially when you
have
well two games with wyatt so
um
jan is really very close on
winning this tournament he is and he has
the white pieces the next two games he
plays so if he can convert this
advantage
that means that he doesn't have to worry
himself with the players who are trying
to chase him down because he just keeps
sprinting faster than they can run so
yonda palmashi he won the last
candidates we see him here on screen he
is calculating after rook to be one uh
this queen sacrifice line if he doesn't
go for that
then he might not win this game but he
he has step one taking on a2 and ali
raza almost certainly will play rook to
a1 i don't think that there's another
choice here right because just to bring
up the analysis board
and show
some
lines quickly the queen that was on b2
attacking this knight on d4 it may seem
like this knight is safer here so okay i
don't have to worry about that knight
hanging with my bishop and my pieces can
start going over here but the problem of
course is this knight is also hanging
and then this knight d4
is sandwiched by the rooks and this
bishop on e2 i mean everything falls
apart as black's rooks get into the game
so
okay alerisa has to play rook a1 i think
he will and then the only question i
believe is will yan just slide his queen
back and forth and make some kind of
draw or will he find the queen sack
which is available to him right now well
we are about to find out
rookie one is on the board yep you might
repeat once but i'm also curious if he
does sack his queen how long he's going
to take this is really going to be a
reflection of his level of confidence
now the game is not over even if he
sacks the queen
so it's true i am trying to read his
eyes though like he's clearly folks in
the center of the board he doesn't want
to oh yeah he's aware that he can sack
his queen i mean it's an obvious idea
what's not obvious is the evaluation of
that idea here we go
great camera work there as jan
sits back in his chair getting some tea
and a little sympathy you know what that
means he's satisfied with the moment
he's got a draw in his pocket is
anything coming out of the thermos
it just happened and has anything come
out in the last like three times that
he's poured it so alexis
[Music]
well as he drinks tea or not tea we have
a funny video to show you from yonder
palm sheet earlier in the
event jan
he pours that tea
he makes a face or two but when all is
said and done and he calculates this
through i think he is going to find a
way to break down white's resources
and the three of us had not seen that
video before so that was very funny uh t
might just be his secret weapon
clearly
are we sure that's tea and not coffee
that's a pretty dark color liquid yeah
it's definitely tea jana is a tea
drinker
yeah and i don't know who drinks that
much coffee in a thermos during a game
of chess uh speak for yourself you don't
take any coffee do you bring a thermos
of coffee during i have brought a
thermos to caffeine during the year
during my last tournament i was ringing
a thermos every morning
so like you should do this again i was
like stop this
i don't drink any coffee so for me even
a sip of coffee is too much but um
thermos is for tea
that's uh you know that's yon's
specialty ooh
didn't mean that pun and i regret it
immensely wait thermos is for tea
you're on special tea oh
how do you come up with all these
horrible puns and then when someone
makes one you took like 30 seconds to
get it and you're on a mission
you're hurting my feelings here do you
think we can compete with those
argentinian football commentators you
know that we're on the verge of becoming
you know that's famous
with ours
[Music]
oh my god i didn't knock him oh he
doesn't yeah
here i'm still interested
i have not that
voice ringing my ear
right exactly he's like the chess
version of that
jan though
big big moment here because he can
it's not officially over mathematically
speaking but he can send a message to
players who are trying to catch up to
him saying no no no don't even think
about it and
he sacrifices queen but he took on d4
with his
transposition
or no
oh so what he's doing is he's giving
himself an extra option
after ali raza takes the queen
nepo could play bishop g5 takes e3 as we
pull up the analysis board and transpose
him to the position we were looking at
but he can also take alireza's queen
and get to a position where white has an
exchange for three pawns so rook takes
rook takes
now you take on e3 you don't take the
knight because the bishop was hanging
knight takes d6 after something like
rookie five
why could get mated here
yeah just because the queens are off the
board does not make the king any safer
and this is bad news but
after rook takes d4 if we just analyze
this live position you can take on d4 in
two different ways we see the downside
of taking with the queen that leaves the
bishop under uh not under attack just
hanging with check and then all of
white's pieces will fall including this
bishop next and then black just wins so
if we take with the bishop on d4 that
means that jan saw queen takes d5
hitting this knight pinning it and look
at this position right if i move my
bishop somewhere unfortunately bishop f3
will run to knight h4 check black is
down a rook
for five pawns black isn't even down
material though why there's no puns left
that's amazing and once you take on f3
you take on e4 next because you have two
attackers and then you're
i'm gonna put this in air quotes down in
exchange but you have five pawns and a
bishop for a rook no no no this is just
unbelievable stuff i don't think i have
ever seen a game on the top level where
like
well white or black didn't have any
pounds left for it
it's crazy some
material
wow and look at
ultra precisely the rook takes d4 and
bishop takes e3 first that looks more
normal because this knight is protected
two different ways and you can take a
hanging bishop and then take that knight
we don't have to worry but he instead
goes rook takes d4 and
as we get
oliver's move rook takes a2
is he going to take the bishop or is he
going to take the queen
another big decision i think both moves
have their pros and cons
bishop takes e3 takes some some serious
guts to play though maybe rook d1 is a
more practical and more pragmatic
decision
right because that way you don't have to
worry about the queen being on the board
and the imbalance i think that you're
right on mirror the rook takes d1 it
makes sure that you don't really have
losing chances
after rook takes d1
i mistakenly said rook takes white
should take back with the bishop
in order
so that after bishop takes e3
at least knight f4 check doesn't come
with like a semi fork
okay jan has indeed taken black's queen
so we might just get this exact
variation so jan takes the queen on d1
and he just
comes at the board only to make his move
right then gets up again
yes
it's the pressure because you wait for
your opponent's move here like
it's the
the waiting time you know he can't stand
it at the board
and
bishop takes d1 play by alareza who
looks very unhappy with how things have
gone in this game
but the game is far from over if alireza
defends accurately he does have a passer
he is up in exchange
and if he manages to get a pair of rooks
off the board
you never know if you can set this d5
pawn in motion i'm very skeptical he's
got no time
but
yon can't relax just yet
right you're saying this pawn on d5 and
if you try to do the same thing with
rook e5 this is not going to go so well
because already rook takes f7 is
available and with the rook still in the
f file this changes things so i think
that what yawn is going to do is just
sit his rook on a square like e7 and you
are correct though it's three pawns and
a bishop the dark star bishop for rook
that sounds like too much but there is a
pass pawn and that changes the nature of
the material imbalance
so you think that offers him a practical
chance to save the game i would put this
at about 20 80 but not 000.
i i would put it
very heavily in jan's favor and it's not
just because the board the body language
has said a lot throughout this game
where alareza you know he's looked a bit
lost
and i don't mean that from a win-loss
perspective but he's floundered he's
pushed pawns then he had thought i
played g4 john pretty quickly responded
to h6 and he started thinking again so i
feel like the way that alireza has been
his posture hasn't been great but he is
sitting up now and i mean look at him
right he's got his hand on his face he
just doesn't look very happy
no he's not
but i knowing eli reza decently well
he one i think one of his greatest
strengths actually lies in end game
defense like he can save some completely
lost position so i don't think we've
heard
you know i don't think he said his last
word yet i think he's going to put
uh
nepo through force him to jump through a
couple of hoops but in general i agree
with the body language the the the time
left on his clock the fact that nepo's
play is pretty straightforward the
knight from g6 coming to f4 all of that
taken together should give nepo enough
to win this critical game and yam looks
like he's hunting i mean the way he's
staring at this chessboard right he is
not going to let this one slip out of
his grasp he's kind of like a hawk you
know he he sees that the prey is there
let me go take what is mine and this
could be his second consecutive
candidates win but let's
take a step back as we've been focused
on this game two others are still in
progress we have in the top left hikar
nakamura and richard report that game
looking quite level richard needs to
play a few accurate moves but the game
does seem like it should be
heading towards a draw and then in the
bottom right somehow fabiano caruana
opposite colored bishops against dingley
wren but with a much safer king it
should be a nice edge for him so will he
be able to convert it that would be
really huge for his tournament after a
couple losses in the last three rounds
so
we'll leave fabiano to it we'll leave
you on to it and in the meantime we're
gonna take a short break but when we
come back it is more of chess.com's
coverage of round 11 of the 2022 v-day
candidates
so we're here today at the candidates
we're in the media room with dingleren's
notoriously large chair and farm master
mike is having a battle of his own to
become food master mike we're gonna see
how he's getting wrong
lydia don't make me anymore
this is like a pizza simul please be
done
at least get some water or something
it's terrible here
this is going to be a real time
breakdown of danny wrenches games all
time on chess.com uh that's
cool oh
in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less actor than them in every stage
yeah and that that's angelo you should
do the more game review okay yeah thanks
a lot okay so tuesday sucks i gotta stop
playing cats on twitter oh it's cause
it's final tuesday
[Laughter]
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number
best
let's go to
uh tactics
mates
we'll probably need to work on these
ones yeah
every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found no
one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do
that's correct
these are literally the night forks that
you i missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taken
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against pets
there for rookie two
and he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness i'm awful
the feed day candidates is the most
important tournament in chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion in
a world chess championship title match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition they now
head to madrid spain where everything
will be settled over the board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger yon napomnishi
would love nothing more than a second
chance at the throne but he has to get
through seven other great players in
madrid first
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feed hs.com
grand swiss
ali rezafaruja won the grand swiss
turned the heads of everyone in doing so
and has become the youngest player in
history to cross the 2800 evo rating
barrier he would become the youngest
world chess champion of all time should
he win the candidates and ultimately the
world chess championship match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss the u.s
number one and third highest rated
player in the history of our game is
also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlson
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
priest cycle
grand master hikaru nakamura is a former
world number two a blitz and bullet
chess legend and the most popular chess
streamer in the world
he was joined by gm richard report the
hungarian number one is one of the most
creative and dangerous minds in the game
today and nobody is looking forward to
facing him in madrid
fide awarded one of the eight spots to
the wild card invite grand master taymor
rijaba
raja missed the 2021 candidate cycle in
consideration of covet concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
[Music]
and finally
two spots go to the top two finishers of
the world's largest knockout tournament
the absolutely grueling feed a world cup
young christoph duda the polish number
one punched his ticket by ousting none
other than world champion magnus carlson
in the semi-finals of that event
dude would ultimately defeat karjakin in
the final to win the world cup
however karjakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grandmaster dingley
rent
dingly rent takes the spot due to being
the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 fee day rating
list
so that's how each of our eight
competitors earned their bids to madrid
inside the palace of santona it's about
who can sustain the mental endurance to
secure the coveted slot as challenger
for the world title
but we're not sure who that will be just
yet we do know this
we'll enjoy watching every minute of the
candidates with the chess.com community
as we see how the most important
tournament in chess plays out together
[Music]
want play chess online or learn how to
improve join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
in isabella
what a legacy she has left this amigos
queen isabella
just like
the candidates here in madrid they look
to leave a legacy as like the one she
left behind influencing our royal game
of chess and somebody who's gonna
influence our game for many years to
come is the player you see on screen in
front of you that is grand master ali
raza farouja the youngest player to ever
crack the
rating threshold unfortunately for him
in this game against yonder palms he's
struggling but miss amigos is correct
thank you pablo morris to reset to
remind you of who we are this is
international master almiroshenko
master daniel naraditsky i am
grandmaster robert hess and we've been
treated to some great games in the 11th
round here at the feed a candidate so
alireza maybe hasn't been such a great
day for him but the other games are the
players are still slugging it out well i
wanted to say that i'm not sure that we
will know who we are at the end of the
tournament
it's getting more and more difficult but
i think that
fabi has
a very nice advantage
yeah look at those pawns
f6 g5 d65 if he will get to
to them whoa and a big development in
the top left of our screen here hikaru
nakamura is up a pawn in an end game so
i don't know what went wrong for rich
report we can actually dive into that
quickly before we get to the other games
as some of the players are nearing time
travel five or nine minutes left but
right now it's white's move and hikara
just stole a pawn in the center of the
board well i want to say i told you yeah
you were correct
i'm going to drag us back we'll bring up
an analysis board but hikaru nakamura i
thought that his chances were out the
window and
let's see what happened here we left off
around here so we we left off here and
we thought
uh-huh but lemire was right bishop g4 is
a very unpleasant move but still it
should be a
ah maybe bishop takes g4 was a mistake
allowing the knight to sink its teeth on
that e5 pawn
yeah maybe bishop c5 was actually very
forcing but after bishop takes vision to
c3 bishop takes e3 though this doesn't
look that clear with moves like bishop
d7 going
yeah but it's uh ultimately should be
equality so he didn't go for this but
elmira you called it bishop g4
this capture happened now e5 is a target
and report decided to give up his b pawn
and played rook to b5 thinking he'd win
this eventually and maybe you'd have
time to protect it but hikaru made this
amazing move and not for the first time
in the tournament has he used the h-pawn
a great effect
pawn to h5
this is a very nice move and i i wanted
to tell you that i've been there so many
times
uh the feeling that you get when you
equalized that's where like you're
starting to lose threat
and that's what happened to richard
report in this game he assumed i believe
that his next move would be h5 kicking
the knight away from the pawn in the
center of the board and then this pawn
would be recaptured so h5 stops that if
you want to take on h5 you're not going
to be very happy because after the
knight goes to h6 with check the king
goes wherever it wants to go this knight
goes to f5 this would be the second game
in a row where hikar nakamura would have
a menacing knight from that square
yeah and what's amazing is that
rapport's assumption that the b4 pawn in
the words of robert has is not long for
this board
are true you can play rook takes before
and the funny thing is that black is
actually up upon here technically but
after rook c2
is a yeah first of all the pawn
structure is terrible but mainly the
knight totally dominates over the bishop
this is a
incredibly thankless defensive task
so after quite a bit of thought richard
decided that the lesser evil was to go
into this two-on-three knight versus
bishop end game
and during the break i was trying to
figure out how i mean
i know for a fact that this should be a
draw
i don't think any of us are is arguing
that with best defense black should be
able to hold the problem is that when
you look at the engine you see 0.5 you
think it's pretty easy you know that
means white can't make progress
we're talking about ikar nakamura here
he can always make progress richard
report is in for a very long evening
we are in we are which means which means
that we are in for a very long evening
and i think that every fan sitting at
home is okay with us having a long day
here in madrid if that means that hikaru
nakamura can win his game richard report
has made so many new fans and already
had plenty to speak of but hikaru
nakamura you know the biggest chess
content creator the biggest streamer on
twitch for chess and so he's looking at
this position glancing the side
and
just i say that we have a nice uh
chat about uh richard report but knight
d3 i mean
you can like report all you want he can
have your heart but will he be able to
save his game that's a different
question wait up i think the move f7 f5
might be
uh the way to go here for black
immediately immediately
well that's okay well i can try to
explain why
okay go for it
first of all
all things held equal
two on one is easier to hold in such a
position than three on two so if i takes
on f5 black recaptures brings his king
to f6
and i don't think that white has any way
to make progress in such a position
because any time that white uses his
king and knight to chisel away at this
f5 pawn the bishop drops back and either
checks the king and pushes it back
toward f3 if you get the situation king
f4 bishop d2 check
and the knight by itself cannot dislodge
black's king from making contact with
the f5 pawn so this i think is basically
a dead draw but you might say well wait
a second after f5 doesn't white have e5
right in establishing a protected pass
pawn but after e5 i think black's king
is able to reach
d5 in time or maybe you should start
with g6 g5
and if white plays f4 you get a
situation eventually where if the black
king makes contact with the e5 pawn and
the knight moves black will be able to
sack the bishop as you're showing on e5
i don't know if that made any sense oh
that's a very important defensive idea
it just looks so counter-intuitive to
give your opponent a protected pass pawn
but the issue is even if this king gets
up to f3 very quickly and then his
knight is free to move your knight and
pawn alone
can't promote right the knight is not
actually lending a hand you need the
king to come up the board as well so the
king will be tied down to this pawn even
if this knight eventually goes out
somewhere to try to push this one so
yeah no this is a good end game to show
very instructive and i think richard
report he understands that he has the
draw otherwise he wouldn't have
sacrificed the pawn in this manner he
would have played that worse end game
where the knight was on f5 if he felt
like he's going to lose this but f5 is a
very very nice move here for black and
it should secure a relatively
easy draw
and if you place f3
so
we'll just leave
right the pressure you don't want to
take i think that's your point because
as soon as you take we now have a clear
passport it says table base still is
going to
should be a draw but it's more difficult
with a clear-cut past pawn
okay and there he goes and f5 is on the
board and a great job of report to take
his time and not just automatically
bring his king up
yeah really nice move so report he has
plenty of time remaining and they're
about to reach the time patrol hikaru
look in this position hoping that he can
play for a win he plays it after he
moved to prolonged nakamura
and whoa in the top right of our screens
and we're definitely going to have to
look at the game between karwan and
dingler but first
car wants time trouble that's the story
line but the advantage is growing for
yonder palm shame that knight on b7
what's it doing there just like fabiano
tonight on g7 earlier now there's a
knight on b7 and as we show this game
here
uh this is a problem napo is finding
every single move
everything literally sees everything
so we were talking that there is a
february is the human version of alpha
zero so what does it make yam depending
this tournament is it makes yon deep
mind and pulled the plug on the alpha
zero
all right now i'm the one who's the boss
or he pressed uh some sort of a button
yeah that
that button didn't do very good thanks
to alpha zeros algorithm so what if
knight d6 what if you try to evacuate
the knight back yeah i think that your
knight has to move oh ricky i guess
because bishop b5 is already a pretty
big threat to win this knight on uh
b7 but as you're pointing out rook e3
comes knight h4 check or bishop h3
no this one this one's over this one's
done
so
you try to save your knight you lose
other pieces here yikes and bishop h3
right can't play rook f3 because of
knight to h4 with the fork oh goodness
can't catch a break me oh my
what
an insane game
that's what happens when you go all in
and see what happens when you play
bullet all night
i was gonna blame you this time but it
looks like as we approach
time trouble for all the razer frucia
and we approach move 40 that's the
magical number is move 40 because at
move 40 the players get the additional
hour on the clock still no increment
until
after move 60 but that gives them ample
time to think and try to work through
the complications of the positions so
move 31 has just been played by yon
napoli i don't think
mu 40 is that big of a deal in this game
because i don't think other is making to
move 40.
no there's no i don't even think he's
making his move 35.
yeah he might just resign a couple moves
that's true oc3 basically primo
and you can't even stop it because we
just talked about how rook f3 runs into
this fork over here and if that's the
case then as you said basically a
pre-move and d6
one important detail there's bishop c6
check because without that
a bishop would fly into f7
yes that is true that that would be the
one hope is that this pawn on f7 would
fall and perhaps that's something that
alireza didn't fully appreciate several
moves ago but now that he's here well
it's very clear d6 bishop c6 is check
and then this rook will take this knight
over here and
well two minor pieces for a rook but
it's two minor pieces and three pawns
for a rook too many
maybe the fatal mistake was
taken upon on b7 did he still have
like a small practical chance here after
knight f5 oh no you take a knight h4
so i think i think bishop b3 yeah bishop
b3 he had to maybe go rookie too
exploiting the fact that after knight f4
check
there's rook takes that force that would
be a horrible blunder
loose rooks drop off as they say
and if you played rookie 2 i think that
the game continues
yeah it's still clearly not good black
just plays b6 and if you try to can't
even go rookie one because knight f4
check now so
black has three pawns and a bishop for a
rook it's just too much material though
with chances remaining that's that's the
number one thing is refrigerant he
needed to keep chances alive even if the
position remained bad so alareza he's
thinking he might be thinking about
resigning here and
well that's bad news for the rest of the
tournament and while
he sits and thinks we have two other
games going and fabiano carwana
you know he's looking at that game he's
like please alireza please do something
that's not just bad news that's
unthinkably disastrous news for the rest
of the tournament it is and i'm in the
position for dingley wren in the bottom
right hand side of our screen
five minutes four minutes 30 seconds but
he just made his 38th move and dingley
ren's position is extremely unpleasant
and he brings his work back to tort c8
going completely on the defensive and i
think that is the most prudent option
he's got to go rook c8 to f8 that f6
pawn
is a catastrophe a really really bad
weakness like can't white just
keep piling up and play on both sides of
the board i wanted to say that you could
play bishop c3 and queen c2 takes g5
that's how bad i see
that's
depending on how you look at it that's
uh definitely maybe something like
quincy tour
or queen f2 yeah queen g3 then with the
same way too so many options here for
white and this bishop on b7 not playing
in this game it's stuck behind this pawn
on e4 and
maybe at some point black needs to think
about playing d5 but that carries its
own risk especially with a move like e5
for white so the move played by fabiano
he needs to move quickly he does in fact
play bishop c3 rook f8 is absolutely
forced
played quickly by ding
and fabi on his final move it's the 40th
move of this game
he has just three minutes and 20 seconds
and while his position is advantageous
this is those type of moments where you
throw away all hopes to win not
necessarily he will do that but i've
played countless games where i'm about
to make my 40th move i need to do
something quickly and i say whatever
that looks fine and then my opponent
responds and i'm like well it's just
equal i can't win anymore those are very
painful memories
i think white's advantage is
pretty stable here because
black's not really
ever going to play f6 f5 which would be
the only way for black to eradicate
uh
his main weakness so as long as white
keeps the f5 square under pretty decent
control uh white can enjoy life the
question is enjoying life is enough you
also have to make progress and you kind
of have to use the principle of two
weaknesses here i think because just the
f6 fund black can somehow defend if
white can play b2b4 at some point or
maybe h3h4 and create a second weakness
and that's when black's position might
start to crumble
for sure but if black gets this move d5
in at the right moment then maybe
there's some pressure going the other
way and that that's i guess what we're
talking about we're totally right you
need to create a second weakness because
maybe if you don't do it now you won't
get the chance and if black gets that
move d5 in and trades off some pawns
that's where you're like oh gosh my best
opportunity is behind me so fabiano down
under two minutes i know it's only one
move so of course he will not lose on
time but he's worried that he's going to
lose his advantage here but is it
realistic for black to think about queen
e6 and king g6 aha you really want to
play f5 now not only i want to un-pin
for sure
and queen e6 also supports any kind of
d5 push so
i don't think any of us see any kind of
conclusive threat unless you
don't see what i'm going for and blunder
upon on g5 immediately but you're right
i mean king g6 queen e6 and you sit on
the position it's better for white but
if this queen goes here and this rook
goes to f7 then you're asking your
opponent how are you going to beat me i
actually still have everything under
control
i quite like the idea of going of
throwing an h4
because if you throw an h4 h6
the point is that any time black plays
f5 then the g5 pawn
is going to
end up a lot weaker so then maybe you
can get your queen from c2 to g3
and preemptively aim at that g5 fund to
further discourage black from preparing
f f6 f5
for sure and i like queen f2 because it
also plays well with your b4 idea and
you may say well your queen just went to
the king side what are you talking about
b4 but this queen may want to sneak into
this b6 square especially if a bishop
ends up on b4 and that's the type of
thing that you need right the principle
of two weaknesses create another target
and that target could be d6 there's
already targeting f6 one on g5 and
fabiano he made his 40th move here queen
f2
and
the position you know it remains good
for him
i think that black as you were saying
don you don't really have too many
choices you kind of have to shuffle
because the move d5 would probably be a
little bit too risky but as we get back
to the other games we see in the top
left nakamura and report have reached
time control it's three pawns and a
knight versus bishop in two that one
seems to
be one where richard can hold the game
with best play and it looks like hikaru
recognized that but alire is a farouja i
mean it's over 30 seconds for eight
moves he won't even make it now all the
hyperbole practice
maybe would come in handy but
i i don't think it's the speed
that's going to catch him it's just the
position because
you still can't ever play d6 i know it's
black's turn but white has no threats so
whoosh
this is not a position anybody would
want
king h1 is a nice move though
because it preempts it prevents bishop
h3 check
right and rook h3 will be met with
rock h2 so
it's chess nothing is ever guaranteed
and you have to have the discipline to
remain
uh to remain fully attentive and
vigilant until the very end especially
when you're playing someone as tricky as
alireza so jan
in his mind is not
thinking about which restaurant he'll
celebrate with
uh you know
tonight or which bottle of wine he's
going to order he's thinking about how
to
uh how to exploit this advantage as
quickly efficiently
and to give alireza as little miracle
chances as possible
well he's
fully focused of course but i cannot
find those miracle chances yeah i can't
find them either i would say for yon now
it's all about bringing more pieces into
the attack
so
rook c3 it gets rid of white's only
threat of trying to open up the diagonal
we understand that it's difficult to do
so regardless because if you push the
d-pawn the bishop gets a c6 but playing
rook c3 then bring my bishop to g4
trying to get my bishop to f3 the white
king has no shelter because it has no
pawns
and if you play rook c3 knight d6
there's
simply should be c5 somewhere i think
bishop obviously h3 so he attacks the
rook
okay so rook b1 i guess
is that the only it's like the only safe
square
yeah where else do you go i guess c1
you could go rook c when that's true
but
then that rook on c1 i guess could be
susceptible to some sort of bishop b6
the e3 later i'm not sure exactly yeah
rook c1 i mean it just feels like i
should go after this king over here
through v1 then you can play bishop
which honestly bishop f5 might be the
response no matter where your rook goes
so you're right that rook doesn't want
to be on b1 i think he's played rook c1
oh gosh this just
it's it's very painful you're already
threatening a checkmate right like your
threat is rook over here probably make
some random move like rook h3 check
if you play rock h2 i bishop e4
checkmate man oh man he can't catch a
break no
and he played rook c1 so bishop f5 is a
response by yon napomnishi
there's nothing that can be done
actually there is the knight coming back
to d6 so that might be what alariza is
counting on but i don't think that it oh
you trade on h2 and go bishop c7 what a
line oh my goodness just to show the
king doesn't have the g1 square because
the bishop if the king goes to g2 the
knight comes in with check so the crook
blocks but after a swap swap
there it is
pinning and winning this night that'll
be 200 pieces a couple pawns for rook no
that's
that's done so
wow
bishop fbi men's it that's the killer
move will young find it he's got plenty
of time his time management this entire
tournament has been nothing short of
superb
he's going to find it and he could play
probably bishop g4 as well but i like
the bishop being a bit further away from
the white pieces that way you can
deliver that check on e4 without
worrying about a possible trade
yeah the interesting thing is that
technically black is only you know black
has two pawns for an exchange and yet it
feels almost like lionel messi's on the
soccer field you know it feels like one
side has 20 men and the other side has
five
and bishop f5 played so
wow
f1
okay so stopping
the rook from coming to h3
what just bishop before and bishop takes
pawn
gosh you just take this one attack
no oh you attacked the rook too so
that's why rook b2 was actually the
accurate move
oh no no that had nothing to do with it
i apologize that's the other rock we're
talking bishop g2 rook h3 maid is just
sick he's going to resign right here
my goodness and he's stopped the clock
and resignation and jan nepam yeshi
is a man on a mission
he has scored his eighth point in this
tournament out of 11 games the highest
score ever in canada's history is eight
and a half points out of 14 and he
already has eight points after 11 rounds
i mean just an unbelievable display by
the winner of the previous candidate
cycle and now alireza ferrugia
the 19 year old
he has a lot to figure out because
yonder palms you know has his number
he's won three straight games against
ali reza and for farrugia it's a second
consecutive loss first takara nakamura
now to yonder palmashi
the disappointment it's written all over
his face but alireza graciously
continuing to analyze with yon all of
these players are professionals
but what absolute ice water in yon's
veins the confidence the speed the
accuracy he left nothing to doubt the
moment alireza played g4
what a
performance and there's doing that chess
player thing right talking about what
could have happened what should have
happened but that's not the hero there
that didn't happen what did happen
though is
another sip of tea for yon there's
nothing in that cup there is guaranteed
nothing in the thermos nothing in the
cup he's finished all of the tea and now
he'll have an entire evening to refill
his thermos
and it'll be the sweetest tasting tea
that he's had in a while i like your
comments you know
these images shows show us that eliza
remains elegant even in defeat
so he will certainly leak his wands at
home
analyze his games and
come back even stronger in the next
tournament
and something i mentioned earlier is
there's no guarantees you ever make it
back to the kin it's as strong as all
there is is i mean we all expect him to
but maybe expectations are what's
causing problems here that the weight of
everybody else's
thoughts and prognostications and the
critics and also the people who believe
in him right it's just like so much has
been thrown on his teenage shoulders and
there are never any guarantees because
some of the strongest players in the
history of chess have only made one
candidates and maxine vashilograv has
actually qualified for zero he played
last time that's because rajab of
saturday and who would have thought that
maxime would have never made it
by his own tournament play
yes but uh if you remember bobby fischer
was even younger when he played his
first candidates and well he didn't win
it and
how many attempts have he has he made
well until he won the candidates
tournaments and had a shot at the title
yeah no i
he of course is such a powerhouse and if
he makes it back but that's the thing is
the if we we all
would be surprised if he didn't make it
back but there's no guarantees
considering how hard is for the players
to even get here in the first place and
i guess that's ultimately my point that
these eight players i mean they fought
so hard through such great opposition uh
top ten players levano rooney and wesley
so chakri or mahmoud of aneesh geary
they're not playing here but if they
were like okay that makes sense just
that hard to qualify in the first place
and there's going to be a lot of talk in
the coming days and weeks a lot of
armchair generals and monday morning
quarterbacks criticizing ali reza's
playing the tournament suggesting that
he's overhyped overrated and all of that
talk is going to be impulsive it is
impossible to judge on the basis of one
candidate's performance his first
whether or not alireza is override
whether he has it in him to become a
world champion
so
if you're a informed
chess fan you know i would encourage
people not to draw permanent conclusions
it was a bad tournament it was a
performance that ali reza is going to be
deeply disappointed by but he's going to
be his own worst critic he's not going
to let himself slide after this
tournament as elmira said he's going to
analyze these games very carefully and i
am expecting a big time bounce back from
ali reza to start
uh the next season of chess tournaments
yeah well
this that season will start after this
event and this event has been all yon
napomnishi two games are still in
progress here but yan he has the lead
he's eight points
and fabiana carwana hikara nakamura
dingley wren all those players who
entered the round with five and a half
time per second they're still battling
on the board to try to chase down yonda
palmership i mean five wins
zero losses for
napomisi incredible stuff well and three
players are still in the race for the
second place
i think
well their result depends uh mostly on
who has more whites in the last three
games
right first move advantage is real and i
think we know who that will be that
dingley wren he's playing with the black
pieces today so that
means that he's going to get white in
the future games and i mean he won
yesterday with black he gets the second
block in a row he'll have two whites at
the remaining three games and that
second place
finish i mean we keep talking about it
because it's so important because we
don't know if magnus carlsen will be
playing in the world championship and
even he was tweeting about this very
topic when he said uh in
response to some
twitter user
who said i'll bet my car that you'll
gladly play against netbo and you should
magazine can't let you do that buddy i'm
an ambassador for responsible gambling
and that's because magnus carlson he is
sponsored by univet one of the biggest
uh online gambling
sites but
gamble responsibly he said don't bet
your car that i'm going to play because
chances are i won't
well magnus always had this great sense
of humor
but i cannot imagine him not playing you
know this is
something
which
well i couldn't believe even would
happen
when i started playing chess of course
like we were talking about historical
examples like i cannot compare this to
when bobby fischer profited his match
because he was ready to play but he made
a few claims he wanted to change the
system and the rules of the match so
maybe when curious didn't get to play
against him you know because of the
world war two this is also a very uh
difficult situation so i don't even know
how
what to believe
maybe
and i think there's a possibility that a
lot of people haven't factored in maybe
magnus doesn't know if he wants to play
maybe he said that
and he hasn't decided yet i think
everybody thinks that magnus is a very
clear
idea in mind and everybody's guessing
and he's keeping people guessing maybe
he doesn't know maybe he's going to
decide once he figures out who wins the
candidates
yeah i think that there's a lot to
figure out and lots of unpacked with
what magnus carlsen has said i do not
think he's trolling i think he's very
serious
i don't believe he's like said i'm never
going to play and there's nothing you
can do about it but i think he wants
change and
if we're you know talking about the
bigger picture
some of the matches in previous years
have had prize funds that are less than
the world champion match of the 1980s
and that's probably unacceptable to
magnus because chess is
already a beloved game and the
viewership is increasing and there are
some demands that magnus probably once
met and some of them you know i don't
know what they are so i'm just speaking
broadly about this topic i think that
the world champion is such a great
ambassador for chess and if he doesn't
play the world championship match i mean
will anyone even really consider the
other person the world champion i won't
no i mean by title sure but magnus
carlsen is by far the best player in the
world so you can strip him with that
title give it to somebody else but
everyone be like no magnus he's the best
he's the world champion in you know our
hearts our brains because until someone
beats him in a match
then
or just you know plays better than he
does in all these tournaments that he
just wins left and right
magnus is the best well maybe the
consequences of this decision would be
dramatic but on the other hand it could
change simply change the system yeah
so maybe we'll have the same universal
system as
well the
tennis association has but we need
we need to unify our tournaments so
everyone has equal chances into
qualifying
and
getting uh shot at the number one spot
and i guess you know magnus from even
before he was world champion he's wanted
to say in the system right and what kind
of system is used and there is no
players association in chess and tennis
they have that in most sports they have
that but in chess there is no players
association so i think if
magnus is serious which i believe he is
that he needs to
discuss it with other top players you
know form a player's association that
actually uh makes a an impact and
requests certain things because
otherwise there's just a an
organization that is all power pulls the
strings and the players they're just
have to opt in or opt out without any
creative control i agree and i think
you've said this the impact the positive
impact that magnus has made in the game
of chess and forget that the impact that
magnus made in advancing the level of
chess players as a whole i mean he's had
the same impact that stephen curry has
had in the game of basketball he has
changed chess and i think the least that
we can do the least that bidet can do
is to
listen very carefully to what magnus's
demands are and to work with him and to
have the ultimate goal of doing whatever
it takes to make sure that magnus plays
the next world championship match it
might not be possible to institute all
of the changes that magnus wants
immediately but a promise that fide and
those who have the power to change the
system
uh in the world championship system a
promise that they will listen very
carefully and work with the top players
i think will go a very long way toward
convincing magnus that everyone has good
faith and toward convincing him that
playing in the next world championship
match
is going to be meaningful
yeah and the world championship max
matches are very taxing and we've talked
about richard report style and he's
still playing at takara nakamura magnus
has been in you know commercials he's
modeled he's done all these things that
have helped we love using expression
grow the game and there's been no better
ambassador
for the game of chess than magnus
carlsen but as a return here to see
which of these players might be magnus's
challenger or might just challenge
somebody else here in the candidates a
reporter struggling but dingley wren
he's not having much fun either all of a
sudden earlier in the game we really
liked the number one chinese player's
position the number two rated player in
the world was playing well defending
accurately against whatever pressure
fabiano hoped to get on the king side
now we're in a situation where fabiano
can play for two results right he has
the opposite color bishop dynamic he's
the one with the safer king and he just
played the move b2 to b4 trying to
create another avenue of attack well he
combined both uranus he played the h4 so
first queen of two h4 and b4
trying to create a second weakness
in the clearance camp
will it be enough
what's the same because whenever
whenever you attack the dis exponent i
will shift my rook to date well if you
will come back to c3 i will come back to
f8
but now there are two weaknesses i
mentioned the principle of two
weaknesses i feel like
there are now two weaknesses and there's
also an open c file
so you could already conceive of an idea
like queen b6
rather than queen b4 in order for the
queen to protect the c7 square paving
the way for the rook to travel from c1
to c7 so
ugh i don't envy ding here this looks
like a really nasty position but as
olmira said if you don't take on b4
then white can take on c5 and soften up
black center and then moves like e4 e5
are in play
and
this is no fun either
it's a really difficult choice for
dingley wren because
it looks bad no matter what you do and
you just have to pick one of these
options and
i'm just going to throw a position that
we could have had
back here with queen takes b3 and if you
compare the position on the right side
and the analysis board to the live
position
he was the one who looked like he was
ready to seize control of this game take
the initiative attack all these pawns
and then
things have just gone downhill for him
so that trajectory that history of the
game that weighs on you is probably very
unpleasant for dingley wren
but while you know he sits and thinks
he's plenty of time an hour and a half
remaining for the next 20 moves we had a
great interview dina valencia did with
team over jabba
asking him about his game and talking
about farouza if he cracked under the
pressure
timur thanks for joining
facing young schist of today uh what was
your mood like
no my mood somehow i was fighting i mean
compared to the game that happened so i
just went to this for this line that is
uh generally usually very playable but i
was more concentrated focused on the
e-takes d5 which is the main move there
and
95 is much more rare in general i saw
that this line i mean i saw it a bit but
i mean d4 c5 when i was taking on c5 and
all this knight d2 stuff um after 97
there's ideo was 94 and queen d4 coming
so that that was the usual thing so when
he played knight f6 somehow i didn't
understand what white is doing i mean
what is the way to uh proceed and to get
the advantage
so uh i didn't want to waste much time
so i just played fast but fast was just
uh
not a good way of playing in this
position probably i had to sing how to
you know to proceed and try to play for
the sissic square which is usual sink in
this positions so i made one or two fast
moves and then i was very upset about
the fact that i didn't think a bit at
least how to put the pieces there and
try to press
so yeah that was a bit surprising what
he played and uh
no the mood was good but uh the play was
bad perugia made a long break from
playing online to prepare for the
candidates and this this night he
cracked so uh
do you think it was uh
a right way to release the stress
i think he correct already on some
previous nights
because in general i mean the thing that
he played today is because of the result
because he's not fighting for the
highest places
and then you don't care anymore and you
just play
i mean the way he plays also today he's
playing like bullet a bit so in general
i think that it's just
the way of
you know
the state of mind where you don't care
simply because i mean the the point here
is the first place
and um
if you are not uh going to take it then
you are just playing i mean you are
enjoying chess and trying uh you know
some ideas and stuff
but um yeah i think that that's the
that's why he did
okay well we heard from team rajabov he
says that for alareza things just
weren't going well he felt like he
needed to play for a win and uh well it
was not a good day for the youngster but
it might not be a good day for the
number one player from china he just
moved his bishop to d7 and donya there's
problems all across the board all these
pawns on dark squares which means that
the bishop can put pressure on them
what do you think about his decision not
to take him before instead to bring his
bishop out well i totally get it because
as we were discussing if he takes on b4
then there is a very clear target on d6
right um and you also free up the d4
score for the queen as it stands at
least the d4 score is defended but now
you have a weakness on the c5 square the
h2b8 diagonal is opened up so the queen
from g3 requires even more power
it's bad this way in that way it is for
sure but
someone who's not having a bad day at
all is grand master jan napomishi who
won another game he leads the candidates
with eight of 11 and we have him here in
studio so
jan first of all how are you feeling
no idea
well i didn't really understand what was
going on today from his side like
um
i would say he played
very you know in an optimistic manner
yeah so the first surprise came on move
five the move c4 what has been your
experience so far with this move and is
this something that you expected from
anyone this tournament well c4 is the
line i wanted to play you know some some
moment myself because i thought it's
like quite curious
and i also think i had like this nice
game against anna sigurov here
c4 bishop p7 d4
uh
idea from daniel dubo uh like something
some trick like castles bishop d3
knight g5 knight c3
bishop g4
and here bishop g5 bishop g5 and bishop
h7 k7h4
yeah and suddenly here black is like in
a big trouble a beautiful knight g5 yeah
some some cheap player but
it was like uh
yeah it was a pleasure to play like this
yeah so i i have like some pleasant
memories about c4 line but in general i
i would say like uh
of course it's a serious line so you
should one shouldn't underestimate it so
black has
different tries but
i think like this 96 bishop e7 i thought
it's like the most the most solid
and uh
i wasn't sure like if i should play c6
first bishop g4 first so
uh
like yeah i guess castle is normal
so maybe it's not for c4 but bishop g4 i
mean it's more or less the same because
you have to play bishop p2
i believe software free
white shouldn't fight for something yeah
because i killed this weakness so i felt
like bishop d7 bishop e2 uh
here c6
castles
i felt like jake's takes and after
bishop b6 uh like this after queen b6 he
had to play something like rook b1 i
thought it's like very smart
and after queen c5 maybe i don't know
kingish one so
uh knight xd5 knight b3 and okay this
position i felt like it's slightly
slightly unpleasant for black okay this
engine like 93 knight c3 knight c5
like takes everything
yeah maybe knight have to check also
like a nice internet but it doesn't
matter i mean okay here like despite the
like spawn up it's practically could be
not so great yeah
uh but
yeah
yeah i mean especially white could put
bishop on it frequently but i thought
okay should be all right for me but once
he started to play like english one and
then instead of some normal move like a4
he went for g4
uh yeah at that moment
what were you thinking well i was like
expecting
waiting for more i would say yeah but
i mean i mean clearly after g4 you're
not going to play something like a4 yes
you're not going to move like onto some
normal
uh
you know return to some normal flow
and
yeah i believe this is like quite
unfortunate for for white i mean this
whole idea so i think like black easily
refutes all these playlists with g5
because okay l pieces are into play so
i'm surprised that he played g4 and
thought for a long time after you played
h6 well i like
i
you know i i don't know what transfer
because okay clearly
uh every game here he plays for a win
but
you know sometimes the way he plays is
yeah
a little bit artificial mm-hmm one more
technical question about this position
we thought maybe eloreza wanted f4
um
were you intending to take on g4 and
sack on e3 or were you intending knight
c4
i wasn't anything to think that's a
great answer no because i mean okay i
understood like okay of course like the
most unpleasant move would be a4 like uh
because basically g4 h6 i mean it's like
worse for white maybe okay this
inclusion of timos but i think nothing
critical happened there so far so a 45
uh bother the queen
and here okay i can play knight c4 maybe
maybe maybe i can play 16 c7 but in
general it looks like okay black is
already some something like very
slightly upper hand but
i i i don't know okay h4 so just just
let it be
and
yeah then i actually missed
some line so i had like the this rook c4
is a backup line but i of course i
wanted to deliver some mate here but
somehow he had this queen d2 trick and i
didn't know what to do yeah i mean later
in the game yeah f4 takes takes uh queen
takes knight e4
okay bishop d8 probably was the move
bishop f8 and
okay bishop d8 for one move and bishop
uh
fate here queen d3 yeah i think it's
suddenly suddenly all right for white
yeah yeah even even more than otherwise
suddenly i mean by a miracle he defends
everything
so there was the move bishop d8 knight
xd6 but uh
i mean i felt like okay like roxy4 is
some safe
safe agent
uh
i couldn't make myself you know
calculate some more lines so but you saw
this the whole way through like yeah
until i mean okay i didn't uh
i wasn't sure like about bishop d1 i
thought okay i'll write like like i have
three pawns
for an exchange and some attack on the
king
but then okay he had this
in the very end he had this rookie two
move and rookie two was
i mean here it was very unpleasant
because okay i felt like
it felt like i'm spoiling some some nice
game
because well i was giving all the
chances in this game yeah which i wish i
could only dream about
but here
well i i don't know bishop g4 doesn't
work due to group 23 by the way
and okay maybe i should
yeah maybe i should uh i don't know play
f6 or i don't know
maybe b6
maybe he has like no no ideas but
so i just slowly
you know
protect all my uh all my stuff and uh
should be should be good i mean of
course i can always make a draw but i
mean i wasn't sure like if it's if it's
a good result so far yeah after such a
game
yeah after bishop b3 it seemed like it
was a pretty one-sided affair you
brought your pieces in and here i felt
like uh okay here he would play rook b1
and sacrifice on b6 not to get mated but
yeah but after roxy one i actually
panicked for a moment because uh i
thought wow bishop f5 there is 96
but then okay i found rookies free
rookie 2 takes takes in bishop's segment
here finally i i managed to calm down a
little
so here like some uh some nice material
advantage should be
yeah yeah you've got it and just
convertible just want to remind the chat
please send your questions we'll try to
get the best ones in for yon but i mean
so
you know he
threw all his pieces at you you
withstood any pressure he
gave your way
now you have eight points i mean
you must be feeling i know you you said
just the last three games you want to
get done but you must be feeling good
i'm feeling better than it would be like
a draw or some some worst result but uh
yeah you're very correct there are like
three games
i have one more general question i
promise i won't ask you about magnus
again for the third time
but
uh i will ask you about everybody before
the tournament talking a lot about ali
reza and how high the expectations were
for him and maybe thinking only about
your world championship match and not
about your excellent results before that
do you feel like that gave you extra
motivation the like
abundance of talk about alireza and
about the fact that you
uh you're not necessarily a favorite
based on just one result
well i've i have you know listened and
read a lot during the image before they
mentioned after the image yes so it
wasn't like really extreme any extra
motivation
uh so for me i felt that maybe a little
bit you know
um
rather he just went with the flow yeah
once he like got you know some
very nice uh very nice tournaments
one after another yeah and he didn't and
he never stopped
and uh maybe that's why he slightly you
know
he was you know slightly lucky to reach
this 28
mark that easily but i mean of course
like this was like completely
outstanding achievement
and then okay somehow
i mean i i i wasn't sure why would he
just stop playing chess for uh for half
a year but uh i don't think it's
uh it wasn't anything like for good for
him yeah yeah so
i feel like yeah i feel like uh
he should have maybe played a little bit
more but i mean okay we we don't know
his
uh but
i don't think one needs extra motivation
for the candidates here well this is
your second candidate you won the first
one you're having a great performance in
the second
what is it about this tournament that
allows you to thrive so much
no idea i'm just i mean unlike maybe
some normal round-robin tournaments in
the candidates i'm trying really hard
right so i'm not doing some nonsense
yeah like uh try not to playing not to
play games like try to sleep try to
prepare for for every game yes sir
uh probably do what i'm supposed to do
every time but um
unfortunately
not every time you know
yeah
i can you know get my stuff together and
uh do
do everything correctly well last
question for you it's putting on the
spot a little bit and i'm we're not
gonna ask you about your thoughts about
whether you'll play magnus if you do in
fact win but is there anything about the
cycle or the world championship that you
know you would recommend change or do
you feel like the players should have
more of an input
uh
actually i think uh
i received quite a weird letter from
fidel with an idea to change you know
the mesh format
uh
to make it i think like three sets
instead of like one long match
uh which uh
i mean which was quite nice but uh
you know there are some some some inner
rules were like
uh
completely awkward but i would say uh
maybe
yeah i
i really like maybe for epic just i
really like the snooker system yeah so
you like play some long long match
and you have the sessions and like maybe
okay one or two sessions per day morning
and evening and uh okay first was course
whatever like nine points out of 17 yeah
passes through yeah but um
this would be something interesting but
regarding some classical world
championship i'm
i don't know i think it's quite it was
quite nice uh until they made it like uh
freaky free games instead of two games
uh because
i said uh i suppose they wanted to make
it like more games and uh they didn't
want to make uh you know more days on
the expo yeah so they needed to change
the schedule a little bit
yeah but
[Music]
it's a good question and i i think i can
talk forever
okay well we're going to give a chance
for the chat to get involved with some
questions we just have three for you
here so what kind of tea do you drink
oh nice like
p-u-e-h-r i think is
and what is what is that is it black
it's okay some special fermented black
tea i would say like it's more
i would say
i don't know
i know i don't know how to explain so
normally okay i
drink this
for
for quite some time already and i think
yeah it helps you not to fall asleep
yeah during the game okay i need to
adopt that maybe i'll play like
nevermind and the second part of that
question
you're asking
about
do you ever pretend to drink tea or is
there always tea in your thermos
sorry one the second part of the
previous question was did you ever
pretend to drink tea or do you always
actually have tea in your face i'll
always have tea totally done yeah
okay is that right no tricks are we
going for this question
uh
yeah go for it how does ian evaluate the
pre-tournament expectations of jan being
in the bottom half
slightly exaggerated
[Laughter]
didn't come true that's for sure whoever
predicted that but
yan
oh
okay well now that's a question putting
this about will you win tomorrow you
know are you gonna just play a solid
game that's you know i have all the
evening to decide
i like the quick answers john well that
was the last one for you it's been fun
having the studio you're playing
incredible chess so
it's great it's been a marvel to see
thank you thank you thank you thank you
wow that is grand master yon napomshi as
you see here eight points out of 11
games five wins six draws and zero
losses from the russian superstar who
competed in the previous world
championship he gave us some ideas on
you know snooker style format
you know just what an event this is for
him and
he gave some non-answers right he
doesn't like to give away
information he
when asked about pressure he just says
what pressure you know i just do my
thing one game after the next so it
feels like he's really trying to keep
his composure every single second
yeah i mean i think jan is just a great
example of the fact that experience
really isn't exaggerated the role of
experience because sometimes you think
experience okay but all of these players
are really are experienced
but not all experience is the same
experience specifically in a particular
tournament is completely different from
experience playing these guys in general
and someone like jan who's been through
a world championship match for goodness
sakes
i think that the effect of that is
tremendous it cannot be overstated and
this guy looks like a consummate
professional he's like this is another
day in the office for me for god's sake
three days away from winning the
candidates he's training this like any
other day he's disciplined and you know
what it's amazing to see
and almiro you know we have this game
between ikaru and richard report but
report to somebody whose openings by his
own admission may need a little bit of
work so when yon was here with us he
said that
i asked him what's different about the
candidates why do you thrive here how is
this different from other events he said
i prepare harder maybe i should do this
at other events as well and i guess the
question is you know
yan he comes the candidates he wins a
ton of games he's raiding balloons what
if he did this every single day
what would it be like well we were
talking about having this discipline but
here he has a world championship match
at stake you know
you didn't want once again to sacrifice
it all
every day of your life so i think he
need well what he's trying to tell us
like maybe he's trying to find this
balance and between uh well the real
real goal and uh maybe winning a
tournament especially that now there are
so many online tournaments i don't have
the feeling that the chess players
especially jan is so so much motivated
by the price fund and this is a huge
difference what motivates him
now is the
title especially and the title and
classical chess it's not that how much
did you win in a like in an online event
so it's a purely poker consideration i
would say so
for me the ethics of a chess player has
always been something different
yeah no i mean he does seem extremely
motivated and he wants to win he wants
to be the world champion and
well he's step one he's about to check
off
winning this event would allow him to
play a world championship match whether
or not against max carlson remains to be
seen but as we see the players still
struggling two games remaining and we're
going to head to a break but we do want
to make a special announcement because
chess.com is proud to announce the fall
2022 and spring 2023 collegiate chess
league season in partnership with nace
star league make sure to sign up to
represent your school in the premier
chess league for college students and
with that we'll leave you with the
players on screen this is round 11 of
2022 feed it candidates you see five
minute car one dingley wren and we will
return to the action in just a few
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand and most importantly of all
how many botes gambits has alexandra
botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
television
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
hey
[Music]
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
and he definitely knows that he hasn't
made his 40 oh no
oh my goodness
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
the candidates
certainly is about leaving a legacy and
akara nakamura he has his legacy set in
stone on twitch he's brought his chest
back over the board not just online
rapid blitz and bullet events he's
having a good event but unfortunately
for him he looks stumped as he tries to
win this end game jan napomshi won his
game hikaru nakamura looking to become
the second winner of the day but he had
an interesting opening and dania why
don't you take us through a cool
possibility thank you robert o'hikaru's
game against richard report featured a
fascinating variation of the sicilian
defense that might be a little bit less
familiar even to experienced chess fans
it's the sveshnikov variation and the
sebastienkov is defined by the following
moves white play z4
black plays the sicilian and after
knight f3 the most popular move here is
d7 d6 but in the svashnikov black
develops the queen's knight
this is the open sicilian white strikes
with d4
and after black develops the second
knight two f6 and white develops the
knight to c3 evgeny svechnikov the
swashbuckling and recently deceased
russian grand master invented the move
e7 e5 he wasn't the first to play it but
he basically developed most of the
modern day theory white swings the
knight over to b5 attacking that d6
square and black pushes out the pawn and
says no you aren't getting to d6 and in
this position hikaru nakamura chose the
most popular move bishop c1 to g5 but
when you want to know an opening you
also have to know all of the most common
opening traps otherwise you're going to
lose some pretty short games and there
is a second move which has been really
really popular recently and that is the
immediate knight d5 this forces a
nitrate because there is no other way to
stop the knight infiltration to c7
and after knight takes d5
e takes d5 this attacks the knight on c6
it has to swing back to e7
and now white expands his control of the
center with c2 c4 and if you're looking
at this very important theoretical
position for the first time you can say
okay that knight on b5 i'm gonna kick it
out of there
looks totally normal looks like the most
natural move in the world and yet a6
loses the game all of a sudden it turns
out
that c4 had another hidden idea
and that was to open up this diagonal
for the queen the queen swings on out to
a4 setting up a vicious threat of
discovered mate if you take the knight
on b5 that's relatively speaking the
best move you drop the rook in the
corner and you're down in exchange and
if black tries to cover the pin with
bishop c8 to d7
this will lead to tears and gnashing of
teeth white can still grab the pawn on
d6 and that ladies and gentlemen
is a smothered mate in the center of the
board and so that is why you always have
to be aware of all of the opening traps
if you play the smashing cup don't play
a6 in that position and that is just one
of the many fascinating lines that can
occur in the svechnikov sicilian
back to you robert unfortunately we
didn't see a quick checkmate in this
game well fortunately if you're a
richard report or has many fans but
hikaru nakamura he's still searching
this position he's shaking his head and
i'm not danny i don't read his faces as
well as danny does but i think we can be
sure that he's looking at this board
shaking his head because he realizes
that this game will be a draw but there
is another game still in progress and i
wanted to
point out that fabiano caruana plays
this move knight d5
quite often against the swesnik of
defense and he is actually
oh well having a slight advantage
against dinglaren
oh okay now we have the position on the
board
yeah that's over on your bottom
right hand side and i'll be here before
i let you continue one thing i want to
point out fabi already with 28 minutes
on the clock so he's already burned
through more than half of his additional
time control
i feel like he's starting to sour on his
position here as he's about to make a
move
he's been searching for a win and he
just pushed that pawn to d4
and that has a very clear threat so as
we bring up fabiano's game against
dingley wren the point of this move d4
is that if black were to make the
mistake of taking on d4 white wouldn't
just recapture it just because you stole
my piece doesn't mean i have to capture
right back bishop b4 skewers the queen
and the rook on the same diagonal
winning material and with it the game
so is there a defense because you don't
just want to allow white's pawn to
advance to d5 also the c5 pawn is
hanging but i do think that there is a
very very devious
defensive move here and that is queen e7
slots on over to d7 offering a queen
trade and saying hey i'm down to give up
your c5 pawn but you're not taking it
without either allowing a queen trade or
after queen takes c5 allowing my rook to
get to c8 and then the black queen
to get to c6 forking the bishop in the
e4 pawn this is out of the question for
white
and that means fabby would have to trade
queens with what i think is a pretty
dead drawn bishop end game
as a result
hi it's a very interesting suggestion
because i was looking at uh
very concrete bishop d3
with the queen on
the queen still on board
i'm not sure
this works because rookie one is still
possible
and
maybe now i can take on d4 yes right
because you distract the rook away from
the bfa which he's the bishop
after bishop takes d4
as long as you avoid this bishop c5 move
next hitting the queen of rook it seems
like black is just
trading pawns and still holding on to
the king side
but i agree with you you would want to
trade queens in this position because
white still has so many threats right
and once the queens are traded you could
stick the black bishop on this
stronghold on b5 that simultaneously
blockades the past c pawn but
robert if i may ask you to remind uh
remind rewind really quickly a couple of
moves i actually think fabby just might
have missed
i don't know what he missed but rook f1
to b1 really surprised me because
that allows the bishop to get to get to
b5 and then i think he made a second
impulsive move and that is h takes h
takes in queen f5
because maybe he shouldn't have taken on
g5 at all because by keeping the pawn on
h4 you give yourself the additional
possibility
of advancing that pawn to h5 and
creating for yourself a potential
stronghold on the g6 square
yeah that's true because it's not like
black is threatening to take on h4 so
leaving the pawns on the board it does
give white additional options and one of
those options could be to move e5 at
some point you might need to set it up
but that looks very scary for this king
on g7 so
with the pawn capture and queen f5
king to gm ding has played so many good
king moves in this tournament earlier he
played king to h8 here he plays king to
g8 and with the king
retreating it means that this pawn on g5
isn't under attack the pawn previously
was threatened because the pawn f6 was
pinned to the king now the king comes
back if you take on g5 you just give up
your queen so d4 played and now for
dingley red he is so good at calculating
your move queen d7 dania i think that is
necessary because when the queens come
off black's problems are less
significant in terms of checkmating
attack but there's still some
opportunity for fabiano to play for a
win as he will go up a pawn well but
that was a very concrete line i think
that fabiano uh went for h
takes g5 exactly because of this queen
f5 and d4 because if you would play
queen f5 without trying to know g5 then
queen d7 is even stronger
sorry i hung my queen
opening up the g file a positional
sacrifice yeah queen d7 is certainly
possible um
you can maybe even
take this one here
oh yes maybe you can even take on d3s
that's
it's funny because even if black wins a
pawn or two it still feels very unsafe
for this king on g7 but
for sure between d7 maybe queen g7 rogue
b7
yeah
yeah
it looks shaky
oh my goodness is there something crazy
oh my god and if queen of five would be
seven
check
and then i go up a piece and get your
queen next and if queen b5 this reminds
me of the nakamura ferrous again where
the queen is distracted from
the defense of the king and there's a
background check but it doesn't give you
anything right and this king on g7 are
going over
to h7 or something that's going to be
just absolutely crushed it looks like
but
is there the same idea
with the current position on the board
queen d7 rugby five ah no you played
so you don't want to play bishop takes
f6 here because if rook takes f6 what
you do want to do i think is give a
check on h5
and after king g7 e5 there's just a
really really cool line queen b1 check
you might think oh that's a problem
because after king h do i go rookie
chain and i pin your queen but the pawn
comes to the rescue ef king g8 if you
really want to be fancy you can even
take on h7
and then play h8 apologize in f7
followed by f8 equals queen yeah that's
a cool line
that one's fun
and it just goes to show that you know
with all your pieces aiming towards the
enemy king even though your opponent may
land a pin or a fork or something like
that you could just still
win the game because the king is very
unsafe so this e5 move instead of just
going for the pawn f6 right away
bringing another attacker in without
trading off the more powerful piece this
would actually just be decisive
wow so it looks like
no it all started with queen f5 but
which looked very suspicious
but what happens after queen bishop d3
then
i think bishop d3 is a a good move yeah
hitting rook
hitting pawn over here on e4 and
the rook can't come up to b6 this is
kind of what i was
implying that even if black takes two
pawns here it does feel like white is
very much in this game because the king
is not safe all sorts of pawns are
hanging so
what a mess this would be
yeah it appears that
white isn't worse even in this scenario
so
the heavy is still very clearly in the
driver's seat and what i'm curious about
if we go back to the current position
after queen d7
trade in dc
is this a dead drug because initially i
called this a dead draw but when i look
at this the different pair of eyes i
feel like
white has rook b6 as well as rook d1 d6
there are some questions that black
still needs to answer here
very funny you know what i mean a dead
draw i mean earlier in the event when
fabi played against rajab and he won
that game we were talking about some
obstacle bishop ending where five would
be up a pawn but they had knights on the
board i'm like this looks like it's
pretty lovely he was immediate in his
reply no i have actually good winning
chances here so i think a position like
this it does actually
look like a position where white can
play forever you have this extra pawn in
c5 it's a pass pawn f6 is a potential
target of rook coming to sixth rank
that would spell some trouble for black
and not only does it threaten black's
pawns but helps white's pawn start
pushing up the board this at least from
a distance i don't think dingley wren is
particularly happy about getting here
but it does appear to be the best option
and the engineer here is almost dead
equal and this really epitomizes the
danger of just parroting the engine
evaluation then asking why i didn't go
for it
because
the engine essentially calculates this
from the perspective of why there's no
way to make progress but that's not how
humans think why does a million ways to
try to make progress
and the engines don't feel like torture
and psychological torture of a certain
position to them does it matter if
they're a pawn down here or they have an
equal middle game it's all the same
but not for a human
right
the engines defend perfectly right
that's another thing and engines know
they will defend perfectly okay they
don't know anything
except that robert hess is a good
commentator oh well these two players
they are really
looking through all the possibilities
here trying to play like an engine
because they're tied for second place uh
yonda pamishi with eight points after
his victory today over ali reza farouja
so yan remains in the tournament lead a
richer report he's still in his 11th
round game against hikaru nakamura so
when this round concludes alireza
ferrugia may find himself alone at the
bottom of the standings
that is not where he thought he would be
after round 11 not in his wildest dreams
but that's again why we watch the
candidates if we already knew how
everything would unfold there'd be no
reason to watch it's such an
unpredictable tournament i think the
people who were most experienced i think
peter svidler made this point in an
interview i was listening to
the candidates is not only one of the
most fascinating and high pressure
tournaments it's one of the most
unpredictable it is literally impossible
to say who is going to win the
candidates beforehand
and john de palma she was not a popular
pick amongst the
people guessing you know when you looked
at all the odds makers
yan's name was somewhere in the middle
or towards the bottom not too many
things that i saw had him as a repeat
champion but jan has proved everybody
wrong who didn't believe in him because
he keeps winning but you know we do want
to mention
time and time again we have to that
fabiano carwana hikaru nakamura dingley
ren they're fighting for second place
normally in the candidates
first or last that's it
but here second place could be
very meaningful
absolutely and
bishop d3 by the way
was the move on the board but as we zoom
out
to our bird's eye view we have two games
left and rehard report continuing to
suffer in that pawn down end game with
ikaru his body language seemed to reveal
that he's basically
given up on hopes of winning the game
but richard
as long as you're playing hikaru when
the clocks are still taking robert amir
you guys can confirm this the game is
never over when you're facing hikaru
nakamura
well then i gave robert better chances
to survive against minotaur than against
the current right
now i know we're pretty wait isn't there
can we go to his game for a second
yeah if we go fg fg king g5 doesn't that
draw on the spot
king e2 is forced king f4 yeah that's it
if report finds this the game is over
right because he'll move his bishop away
and then it will take the pawn on g4 so
there's actually no way for hikar to
protect the pawn so why we can still
play knight d5 here and like g6 but it's
okay
please take me and then i get to take
your bishop and i win an extra pawn
ending but this king can even take this
pawn and this is exactly the type of
position that report has wanted from the
beginning where it's a knight in just
one pawn because this bishop no matter
where it is it will sacrifice itself for
a pawn and keep its eyes on the dark
square that the pawn is trying to go to
so whether it's the current diagonal or
if you put it
on a squirrelly d8 there's no way for
white to make progress there
if richard won't go for this i'll be
absolutely shocked
and he's taking quite a bit of time here
which is slightly surprising but again
he knows who he's playing and he knows
you have to quadruple check every single
option when you play nikaro
and hikar is going to be
pretty disappointed to make a draw in
this game i think he came into today
after yesterday's great victory of
raleigh razer fruga he came in wanting
to double up you know two in a row
have a chance to catch yon napomshi
continue his excellent form and he never
really had any chances today well you
can't win them all unless you're young
you're permission it's like i was
thinking about
this
you cannot squeeze water
from a stone i mean here
it seems realistically impossible
maybe f takes g4 f takes g4 king g5
knight e7
but then bishop c5 probably
or or
g4
yes once again
[Music]
that's exactly what you'd want if you
are
reported you always sacrifice your
bishop for the pawn as soon as it
marches to a dark square so i mean
hikari doesn't look very happy as he's
sitting in his chair well this is a
really really elementary line so
my guess would be the report sees it but
it's just like absolutely making sure
having the discipline to go over it
again and again
because once you take on g4 there's no
undoing that like you've committed
so if there's some freak line
then you could regret it
yeah but he's
analyzing that to its conclusion he
knows it's going to be a draw if he
plays it he just as you said is
verifying and searching through all the
possibilities but for hikaru nakamura
he'll be upset for richard report he had
lost two games in a row before today so
he'll probably be relieved to end the
losing streak but i mean you can see
hikaru he is
not happy right now he wanted to use the
first move to his advantage and he
really seemed to never get an edge but
why does report look like he's concerned
here like that's the one thing that's
almost concerning me report almost looks
disappointed himself
do you see what i'm saying
he seems a little concerned but i guess
you know it's it's impossible to draw
any
surefire conclusions on the basis of
that
ah but maybe
takes on g4 do i have well kingitsu
first
where do you retreat your bishop
ah so oh
that's the idea it's still a draw
against bishop c5 and i missed that
okay great final mira
so that's what's taking him
this time
right because this is a very committal
decision to clarify the pawn structure
to not have trades on the table and if
you get this with the pawns both
remaining on the board you feel like you
could potentially win and you know just
to show cars so tricky it's crazy some
kind of random uh line here that this
knight can walk back first and you want
to push this pawn to e5 but you struggle
with this because as soon as your pawn
goes to e6 the black king comes back to
f6 to win it and if your king ever moves
you lose the g4 pawn so
it does seem like a position where it's
really difficult for richard to lose
this game but when you think that it's
automatically going to be a draw and
then you realize oh no i need to
calculate a little more that can make
you feel uncomfortable so you're right
donna richard doesn't seem to be
particularly happy at the board right
now and for hikaru he would love to win
this game because as we look at his road
ahead
he needs this victory and a couple more
to be able to catch yon napomnishi so uh
he's finishing up this round 11 game
with the white pieces he gets to play
young apology with the black pieces
tomorrow unmissable game absolutely
unmissable game and if carl plays the
berlin
i'd be very very curious to see
i'm going to go for that drop i wouldn't
rule that out you think he is that's a
no-brainer
amir do you think that if given the
opportunity jan will just make an
immediate draw tomorrow well from a
mathematical point of view this is an
optimal decision yeah so i
i cannot question this yeah but
on the other hand what does he have to
lose he can still play on and then it
would put hikaru in a very difficult
spot because uh both dingli wren and
fabiana corona has played him already so
they have maybe an easier finish
yeah and as we see
hikara's last three so he plays black
kentian then he needs white against
yanchista duda and black against dingley
ren in the final game so i mean
considering how important second place
is at this tournament
that last round still has
us drooling over that pairing because
dingley runs form has been stellar so
has zakarus and
with all in the line for second place in
that last round
it might just come down to that if five
minute carwana can't right the ship
well
in the in the near future i'd be i'm
actually very curious to see which
opening hikaru chooses tomorrow against
jan because while the berlin has been
his main weapon
in recent years it's not the only
opening that he plays he plays the karo
khan he's played the sicilian i mean
hikara let's not forget as a 20 plus
year 25 plus year classical chess career
so
i'm very curious to see if hikaru is
fine with allowing a quick draw or is he
going to come in all guns blazing and
play something like the night or
uh to guarantee
uh that the game at least
is unbalanced i'm mildly ashamed to
admit this but while you were saying
that i was like how are you not going to
make the pun hikaru khan
and so i you know that's just a huge
donya pun that was a missed opportunity
there was a hanging queen and they
didn't take it you just
didn't have your eyes open i guess but
just two games remaining here it looks
like dingley ran the bottom right up a
lot of time he did just take that pawn
on d4 so
he was able to do that and
i feel like fabiano
again he's
okay earlier it didn't look very good
for him but then he was given this
opportunity and with the advantage it
just feels like he hasn't been as
precise as we've seen from him in the
first half of the tournament
well that's true but how much time does
he have
left
is
27. he's down he's down to well to 20.
okay so he has an immediate draw with
bishop before by the way
and quenches
but
i don't think fiverr is trying to make a
draw but it's good to show that if
the queen gets distracted away the black
king has no choice but the shuffle
between h and g and the white queen does
the same on h6 and g6
well it's pretty that you cannot play
here like king of two
to get that rook in the game first yeah
king of two
that's a pity
right you have the kunji too you'd love
that the king anywhere but unfortunately
so you're king of two as you're saying
queen d2 check and then this king just
got itself in trouble will lose the game
so
bishop b4
automatically a draw i don't think white
is risking anything by playing bishop
takes d4 nothing but i also imagine that
fabiano's look in this position like ah
no there's no win here that i see it
looks like with the pawns coming off the
board black's drawing chances increase
and while black's king previously has
been
out in the open now it is feeling a lot
safer talk to home on g8 yes but you
were talking about
king's safety i still feel that well
white's king is in my in a much safer
place so maybe i can play rookie three
for example like if i don't know what
what is going to be your next move yes
rookie three
well rookie three doesn't yes i wanted
to play rook g3 and e5 but uh
how to make this work
wow
it actually looks very annoying
but i guess black has to bring this
bishop back to d7 to get that queen out
of there and once your queen backs up i
think
black can push this pawn to g4 so this
pawn g5 has been a problem for so long
and at long last you can
keep it maybe i can start with e5 is it
possible because you don't have bishop
d7 i have e6 with the rook with a3
oh wow so bishop d7 runs right into e6
with a fork
i guess you could play f65 here
you simply take one
and that opposite card bishop n game
with just the g pawn is a dead draw
because
the other flank is fully under control
and black can
quite easily
deal with the g pawn with all of his
pieces right pawns coming off the board
good for the side down material in this
end game and
uh the obstacle bishops make it so that
it should be a draw but it's close it
feels really really close
oh i want to continue queen h4
queen h4 here oh wow
that's a cool mode
yes
and i have nothing you could play e d
and rook g3 and then d3 and give up the
queen and use the pawn as a
counterweight
but this is very scary like oh my gosh
this is very very scary i agree yeah you
don't want that but that's what fabian
is probably looking for i mean he's
thinking on this move i guess he's made
a move
he has made a move okay well
no he has oh he did he took on d4 yeah
you're right
so bishop takes d4 was played by
fabiano and by the way i know so many of
you are still watching here
in chat
so
come on shoot us your questions i might
not answer them but you still should
still send them our way uh the good ones
will undoubtedly be put on screen and
we'll
try to answer whatever
you throw away so
well i'm still on the learning curve you
know i just like you explained to me
today what was the twitch rate you know
so now i know
i wanted to ask if he carried us twitch
raids on our channel or it doesn't work
that way well hikaru is streaming right
now
so
i mean they're gonna stream throughout
essentially when somebody ends first
they can send it to whoever they want so
okay um but his channel streams usually
go pretty late and people are asking why
does second place matter i thought only
first place gets to play magnus that's
if magnus wants to play
the person who gets first place so
magnus it's up to him whether or not he
plays the world championship and if he
doesn't then second place really does
matter
yep and the origin of that controversy
the reason we're even mentioning that
possibility is because of i think a
radio show
um i don't remember when this was maybe
at this point probably six months ago or
magnus said at first everybody assumed
this was joking statement but then
people really wait a second what if he's
not joking he said that he wouldn't play
anybody other than alireza farouza
for the next world championship match
and i think he said this upon defeating
jan
nipomnishi so
that started it all and that is why all
of a sudden second place which was never
important in the candidates to date is
now of critical importance if as robert
says magnus refuses to play the winner
okay
and i mean both these two
they want magnus to refuse to play at
this point because
yonder palm street trying to run away
with this tournament
second place would be meaningful if
magnus says no no match for you and that
would leave one of these two players or
hikaru nakamura with that inside track
to second place
trying to
earn the right if magnus would decline
to play a world championship match
against jan if he doesn't like win this
tournament
who is the most likely to overtake eon
if that happens oh
who did we say is the best tie break
again going into this round i think i'm
ready yes i think uh
well if all the games were drawn i think
fabi have has a slightly better tie
break for the moment but it's of course
depends on the results
for the next three rounds
we cannot speculate on that one yeah
yeah of course that makes sense
and fabiano you know we see him playing
white against dingley wren but he'll
have three more challenging games in
front of him we can't assume anything
it's what you're saying is that
every single player in this field can
beat somebody else and as we see faveno
gets two blacks in a row after this game
black against rich report blackens timor
java white against ferrous in the final
round and while our first
reaction is ooh black two games in a row
that doesn't seem good i actually think
playing ritual report no matter the
color is a good thing not because we
don't think highly rich reports chess
but if you need to win games he's the
perfect opponent to play because he
doesn't just sit at the board and say
let's make a draw as we saw yesterday
against dingley rhett and that's exactly
well the same thing happened when he
played uh alive roger with black because
reside is always
ready for a fight
and fabiana won that game so maybe yes
this is not such a bad thing
yeah and he's a very good lifetime
record against rapport he has an amazing
record against
excuses for java as well and frozen and
here we see dingley wren his upcoming
schedule he takes on the job of tomorrow
with the white pieces
one
loss but two wins he's played foruger
very few times he gets blackens him and
then he gets white against icarus so
that final stretch for dingley wren
that's relatively favorable i think that
his
final three opponents that's probably
the most desirable list of pairings i
would yeah go ahead on the earth no
first i wanted to say that he needs to
survive today right and then i wanted to
point out his uh lifetime score against
hikaru
so he never won my game that's true
but there's always a first time for
everything and he gets the white pieces
so you are right the dingly wren seems
to struggle against the karnaka more
historically but it's a new event and
for ding he's been in good form and he
would like to use that first move
advantage but surviving this game that's
important and what is your favorite ever
world chess championship amir i feel
like you're gonna have the best answer
this question
well you know i grew up
watching these epic matches between uh
gary kasparov and anatoly carp so well
definitely the one which was won by gary
kasparov
because
it was such a historical moment and
i would
always remember the
the images from
to say the um column hall
where like
cues were formed and because people
wanted to watch the games and i was so
absorbed in
by what was going on analyzing the game
so i
i still have the vivid image of this
match
dania
well i i did go on a rabbit hole a
couple of months ago exploring some of
the early world championships because
we've all heard of fisher spassky and
you know we all know petrossian and
botvenic and the early 20th century
world champions but i think a lot of
people might not know that wilhelm stein
is the first world champion first of all
he defended his world championship
several times i don't remember exactly
how many times i think it might have
been four
and mikael chigorin one of the strongest
players to come from pre-soviet union
russia
he was a pioneer he started a chess
magazine he was a tremendously strong
player and he came very close to
defeating wilhelm steinitz in one of the
world championship matches i think he
had a two-point lead he was demolishing
him in a lot of the games and then he
choked massively he got nervous he
started blundering and i remember as i
was exploring the games from that match
reading chagoran's thoughts on the match
afterward
boy was the guy finding excuses he
didn't feel well and it was too hot on
the playing hall and then it and then uh
you know he touched the wrong piece and
there were too many reporters asking him
questions i think there were like six or
seven excuses on offer afterward and
this is like the late 1800s so it was
really funny to read that um because i
started exploring chi goran's uh the
chess magazine that he founded called
chess list
in any case chess history could have
turned out differently if the result of
a single game had been different i think
people really need to understand
how non-deterministic the world
champions are yes the world champions
are often the best players on earth
that's kind of the definition
but many of the greatest players on
earth have also never become the world
champions and some as you have said i've
never even made the candidates
tournament and i knew your answer was
going to be something like that i
thought you're going to give me like
schlechter
carl schlechter yeah and that's what i
thought you were going to uh or isidore
how many people shout out for that name
before he played for a world
championship i just knew that historian
and you would bring an older world
champion match but mine
i don't know the kromnic
onan match was really awesome and
uh i just thought the fight that those
two brought was
amazing and these they were like clearly
at that point deserving to face off
against one another
you know other matches of course are
great but there's something about the
vichy world championship win that was uh
very memorable for me and i was a
teenager at the time so maybe that's
part of it and oh this is a great
question from stodgy cloth saying which
candidate matches up best against magnus
ooh amira you want to take this one
first
is it somebody who's on camera right now
who am i dirty
well actually
um
[Music]
well i have to put you on the spot first
you are asking all the questions you
know i'm in this chair so i get to
determine who answers what i i think
that dingley wren is a very good pairing
for magnus carlsen um
you know
it's difficult to assess because
is hikaru nakamura the same hikaru that
he was and magnus has a winning record
against him 14 to one i mean if you
asked this question five years ago
people would say that's not a match
because mags always beats him their
lifetime stor score is ridiculously
one-sided but the hikara that we see now
you know he is more confident he doesn't
put as much pressure on himself so that
you know maybe gives him an outside shot
but if i answer that question you know
honestly it's the matchup that we see
here five minute carwano dingley ren i
think that favana proved to the world
that in a 12 game match he didn't lose a
single game he almost won
a couple of them he played really well
and he only lost in the quickest of time
patrols but i think dingley wren gets my
ultimate nod because i feel like when
he's well prepared when he's comfortable
when he gets to a tournament without you
know hassle i mean it's been really
difficult for him during the pandemic
but dingley wren is
a monster i mean the last couple games
he's shown here throughout this whole
event uh except round one which is
really holding him back
yeah thing
oh mira have you come to a conclusion
he's gonna throw it to me you're gonna
throw it to me no i was looking at the
game because i was thinking that this is
so true for all of these players but
just that we all
want we all secretly want ding to to
qualify for this magic list so he would
have a shot at the title at least once
there is that right some players never
get a shot as you were saying
yeah i think there's two ways to answer
that question you could
answer it from the pure perspective of
who matches up best in a chess sense and
i'd probably have to go with ding but
then you could ask who would match up
best in the very specific framework of a
world championship match
and you're talking about hikaru i think
one thing that would make kikaru such a
difficult matchup for magnus in a world
championship match
is hikar's confidence it's also the fact
that if magnus loses a world
championship matching at cicaro he's
never hearing the end of it not after
all their you know all their friendly
twitter jabs and you know all of the
friendly rivalry between magnus and
ikaro's fan bases so that would add
quite a bit of additional pressure on
magnus whereas for hikaru you know he's
got a flourishing streaming career
nobody expected him to get this far in
the candidates he's proven everybody
wrong and he would be playing with a
tremendous amount of confidence and a
man with nothing to lose well that's a
dangerous man especially when his name
is hikara nakamura
oh you've said it do you think that we
will get
as much media attention for this match
like if hikaru qualifies and plays
against magnus as like the top sports
event yeah
i i've said this before i think a car
magnus match would be the most watched
chess event in history and i think it
would the viewership numbers would
probably match
something like an nba round one of an
nba playoffs although dingley wren were
to play a match i mean china has a lot
of people that's true so there would be
many many eyeballs there but of course
you know hikaru nakamura brings
sponsorship opportunities he brings uh
the kind of the modern wave of chess
fans and the queen's gambit the twitch
fans all of the newer people who we
welcome into our community
they
would love to see hikaru versus magnus
so then you're more lenient towards the
entertainment factor
yes which is becoming more important
yeah i mean i think it's it's already
become incredibly important ooh this is
a good question who's the strongest
player that's never won the world
championship i can answer this one i
think maybe carius fabiano caruana
that's my answer he's the third highest
rated player of all time there's the
longevity argument you could say karis
that's a very popular answer for noye as
well uh but five and up caruana at his
peak
28.44 he went seven out of seven to
start that syncfield cup he didn't lose
a game to magnus carlsen i mean he's
proven that you know at his peak i would
say maybe his peak is the best player to
never roll won a world championship but
we have to see in terms of longevity
i just like keras games very much that's
that was awesome charis was ridiculously
strong yeah ridiculously strong
yeah he he really was and it's a great
answer right karis is uh maybe not known
to our newer chess audience but paul
karis i mean he was a top few player you
could count the players better on him
than maybe a couple fingers throughout
his really illustrious career and oh we
have another question how would you
describe jan's playing style the other
cannons all seem to have slightly more
distinct styles
i mean i want to start with you but i
feel like every time i try you're like i
don't want to answer first
well
i'm not sure that i also want to
describe jan's style you know i'm not
sure that i have my prison like is very
objective so
maybe dinah you know
well well
you know it's a fascinating question i
you know i'd have to think about it but
particularly because i don't know who to
draw a parallel to which i think is what
makes the style so fascinating now
obviously he tends to play fast and his
tendencies are undoubtedly tactical
uh i would characterize his style as
extremely dynamic and energetic he plays
with a tremendous amount of energy he
likes undefined positions
um
and he doesn't mind like slightly
objectively worse positions as long as
there are clearly defined ideas i think
we saw it today against elereza like
can't really argue that black is a
little bit worse in that position but
because he had that clear idea of
attacking alireza's queenside he was
like a fish and water you could tell how
comfortable he was in his position
during the interview so that's just a
couple of surface level thoughts it's a
question we could spend an entire show
arguing about and i would say it depends
on what term he's playing in he said in
the candidates he's better prepared i
think he's a different player in the
candidates than he is elsewhere and you
know candidates in the world
championship he's much more solid he's
tame he's regimented and non-emotional
so i think that for jan i mean he's
playing amazing chess and he did just
beat alireza ferrugia dina balakai
caught up with alareza so let's show
everybody that interview
alireza thanks for joining seems like
knight d4 was a novelty in today's game
yes
it's top engine move so it's not a
surprise for him i think but
yeah it's it's very
i think popular line now actually
when did your preparation uh
go the way that you started thinking on
your own
yeah after queen b6 i didn't check queen
b6 so
i think i am a little better there but i
couldn't find the way how to be better
so
g4 was very aggressive but still okay it
seemed like h4 was a little bit off the
edge
yeah h4 was too much but okay i couldn't
find a good plan there so and uh perhaps
uh one last question you uh defend it uh
still well do you think there were some
other ways to defend longer or it was
just already hopeless yeah i think there
are better ways to defend but my
position was very difficult to play so
i think
it was very difficult already
certainly was a difficult position for
that man alireza faruja he lost his game
against tournament leader ian de palmasi
and
what he said in that interview right it
was the preparation was a bit shallow i
mean he knew that white was better
because the engine says so but he didn't
know what to do afterwards and uh that's
not a good place to be when you're
playing someone as strong as yonder
promising yeah and especially how
important it is um
to know all the plants in the position
so
that was such a sad image he you had the
feeling that he was doomed mm-hmm so i
i really hope that um there is a fusion
will come back stronger
might take some time
and
gain
some self-confidence
in other by winning other tournaments
that certainly will help
yeah i mean it just it just strikes me
that early reza chose the the top engine
move but like omira said position like
that where you have a big space
advantage and you've got lots of
weaknesses d5 and b2 you've got to know
what the ideas are you've got to know
whether to play g4 whether to play f4
there were so many decisions for white
to make and the moment jan deviated with
let me be completely honest robert a
move that ali reza had to take into
account his preparation it was the most
natural human move by far after ian
played it and threw alireza off his prep
he just didn't know the plans omira i
think you nailed it it was bad prep he
jumped up on the wrong foot and then g4
merely exacerbated the already difficult
position yeah we can see on screen the
0-1 in the top right that was yonder
palmishi taking that game home against
el erisa first we still have two games
remaining we have dingley ren on screen
richard report looking at that game
finding it quite interesting and ding
doesn't look like he's that comfortable
um while
report and nakamura shuffle a bit
after the last move queen back to f3
ding he's now on the clock and
maybe this gives fabinho some good
chances to continue this game and so he
played queen h7 and fabi retreated his
queen to f3
yeah so queen h7 so
i think he was a bit concerned with this
rookie three maneuver
undoubtedly this uh rook lift is gonna
be a problem e5 all this kind of stuff
so ding goes queen h7
queen comes to f3
and
if i'm reading his facial expressions
correctly he really looks out of sorts
i think i know what he missed
so here's the interesting thing if you
play bishop b5
the candidate moves our bishop b5 and
bishop c4 you can't take on f6 because
of queen h7 to a7 check and at the very
least black as a perpetual queen a7 to
h7 that's very nice geometry that ding
definitely saw but after bishop b5 white
suddenly strikes with e5
the center is blasted open queen d5
check becomes very dangerous he might
say okay
i'm just going to go to c4 rather than
bishop b5 let me go to c4 but then the
bishop on an undefended square
this i think ding failed to account for
when you played queen h7 queen f3 to c3
for king the bishop and the pawn on f6
big trouble for black
oh oh well now he's looking at the board
and he's got his hands to his face
fabiano has a bit of that perch where he
doesn't necessarily think he's winning
but he knows that he has dingler an
uncomfortable spot so while ding works
on figuring this position out and
nakamura still presses against richard
report we are going to take a quick
break and when we return it's the final
stretch of round 11 here at the feeder
you can candidates top chess events
right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more try it for yourself at
chess.com events
i figure it's time for me to really
blend in you know dress like a local
i don't
i obviously wear jackets all the time
okay
so
we're ready for the candidates every
local madridian visits the chessboard
on a daily basis i hear they visit and
kind of
pay tribute
to queen isabella herself this is a
i hear that uh
this is
this is a statue of queen isabella
herself
yeah we are here at the 2022 candidates
tournament in madrid spain and we have
our man on the inside danny wrench who's
been with the players a lot going to the
players meetings and he's here to tell
us about some special requests that a
few of the players made danny what have
they been talking about yeah well
obviously we want to and always ask the
players and get them in the spirit of
the city right the uh the place that
they're playing from so a couple of
actually kind of unique ones that have
been that have been thrown out there and
i'm going to try to represent these as
well as i can to fit a okay but the
first one was
a lot of bonus requests if you play and
win with the spanish on either side
makes sense right makes sense um
there was a uh
a suggestion you know that anytime you
move the queen you you drop a dab for
queen isabella yeah yeah she's the one
that made the queen power makes sense
okay um but then the players were
unanimous on one in particular which was
that every two hours into every round
they'll have now a required siesta well
we'll see if any of these rules are
implemented for the tournament uh
especially if somebody plays the spanish
they got some money coming their way
yeah it doesn't seem likely but uh i
don't even want to know which players
made these requests but i've got a
couple ideas in my mind yeah well you
know and uh if and anything that gets
the players to play something more than
the berlin right the most exciting draw
in the world now that we have some money
on the line perhaps we see some exciting
some exciting spanish games so i'm i'm
actually excited about that one there
you go you need some alex honold on us
the alex honold of chess folks climbing
without a rope oh wait i can do it
i don't know why i'm doing this but i
feel like a little kid when i get around
big things slowly checking our insurance
like chess parkour
oh did you catch that on camera
can you tell he's a dad of a teenager
always move like a night guys i think
i'm gonna go ahead a siesta over there
with the uh seems like the thing to do
with the locals you do you baby girl
yeah yeah okay i'll see you guys in a
couple hours
yeah
it's a long day dan you deserve it buddy
you deserve it
go ahead and throw that down and
just
buckle up buddy
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey copy dancing
that wasn't supposed to happen
we were talking about paul cares the
strongest players to never become world
champion paul kerris is high on that
list and i was talking earlier about
opening traps well paul karas won one of
the most famous opening miniatures of
all time this won't take long i promise
karis had the white pieces against a
master named erlemofsky and mr arlemoski
in response to e4 chose one of the most
dependable openings the karo khan he
thought this was going to be a long and
drawn out game
um d4 d5 happened paul kerris responds
with knight c3 the open caracan
black trades on e4 this is standard fair
known theory for many many years and
here black played one of the three main
moves there's bishop f5 knight f6
and one of the oldest line knight b8 to
d7 the point is you want to play knight
f6 but you don't want to double your
pawns and paul karis makes a weird
looking move here he shifts his queen up
to e2
he blocks his bishop on f1 garrus was
young at the time his opponent was
experienced and he probably thought well
what is this fool doing i'm going to
show him and i'm going to get an
advantage out of the opening
and played the normal knight gf6 of
course as many of you in chat know
what followed was tears and tragedy as
paul cares checkmated him on d6 the same
square as that sveshnikov checkmate know
your openings folks and never forget
that checkmate's gonna happen as early
as move six paul karis
won this game against arlemovsky and of
course he also beat many many stronger
players in an incredibly illustrious
career that featured incredible results
for decades
and that is a really important line to
know as we have hikara nakamura on the
screen because richard report actually
won a game in that same exact sequence
several years ago and so you got to know
your stuff hikaru nakamura he knows his
stuff and he's still slugging it out
with that very man-rich report i was
wondering is there a
chess educational show on american tv
no not that i know of okay so now i have
a perfect candidate or are you both you
know
that
the hess show there is uh
where people
and one of my name's donya who you know
they have these channels where they put
educational contracts really that exists
youtube channel education uh
[Music]
that's awesome
yeah well
uh lots of instructive content out there
hikaru nakamura you know he leads that
charge he is always drawing many arrows
winning many blitz games and producing
recap videos after every game he plays
here
takes takes takes takes takes that's all
i have to say and what happened in this
game so we have e5 on the board and ding
played queen d7
that's right so ding reacts i think
properly in this game in fabiano and now
he's back thinking hard about the
position but
we're just speaking about how e5 looked
very scary if you were to take on e5
then queen comes into d5 check and the
problem for black is that this bishop
not only will attack it defends the f2
square because after queen f7 blocking
the check queen takes e5 you don't get
to f2
i on the other hand with the white
pieces of threatening to go to h8 also
threatened to win this pawn and actually
white's completely winning
yeah that's literally game over
so an incredibly cold-blooded move
by ding who took quite a while and for
very good reason after e5 he shifts the
queen to d7 straight away he hits the
bishop now the flaw seems to be bishop
c5
but here there's an incredibly important
resource and only move rook f8 to c8
hitting the newly undefended bishop and
it appears the black is surviving
wow
and after e6
i guess queen d
two
oh going for the rook there also might
be queen cc this is the annoying thing
about opposite colored bishops this
forces the queens off the board because
if you move your queen you lose your
bishop with check and it would seem that
you're just winning because you have a
past pawn but you can never promote it
with the bishop and the rook covering
the square and the king will join the
party soon so somehow queen c6
looks like it might be the easiest way
to defend you can take an f6 because
quincy five is a check exactly point f6
queen c5 check and now all of a sudden
black gets to have the fun because this
bishop can come back to e8 stopping your
checks here and here while the queen
protects the pawn in g5
and ding's not having any fun in this
position but
it seems like he's only a couple of
moves away at last
from securing the half point
i think you have to play bishop cfo
otherwise
you know what's the threat
god be burning through
all of his time here as he drops below
20 minutes as well that doesn't help his
cause
no it doesn't especially you need to get
some 60 and only move 51. so rook c8
what an important move is there another
move that fabiano can play besides e6
which seems to
allow queen trade by force maybe he can
just retreat his bishop i don't think
black really wants to take on e5 at this
point maybe you can't get away with it
but the bishop will take this pawn but
then i go rook f8 and i can
swing my queen to g7 and the problem is
this f1 square is extremely vulnerable
for white
right so the queen comes to g3 looking
for an attack but this queen can do that
same thing that you mentioned earlier
it looks like almost you know just going
back and forth or there it is queen of
g7 they have bishop c5 rook c8 on the
board
wow
yeah but quincy six is such an important
defensive resource of 36.
yeah everything hinges on
just like only moves basically i just
really want to take this pawn you know
it's like i want to take the pawn go for
checkmate after pawn takes rook takes c5
rookie 7. let me go and check me your
king the problem is that the white king
has no shelter either after rook c1
check the king has to run this way and
then black gets his queen d6 check and
unfortunately for white your king is
actually
getting hounded first yep sacrifice
turns into a blunder
i have a funny story in regards to
blunders but i don't know if this is the
right time for it
how funny is it
i mean
i would say it's a five out of ten
a five out of ten it's a five out of ten
i'm definitely on time for it
tell me after this i'll be quick really
i'll make a compromise can you make it a
six by telling you i'll try making it a
decision okay so the one piece of
information you need to know is that in
russian the word or blunder is the same
as the verb for yawn i blundered and i
yawned
is the same word okay
white so the story goes that an older
gentleman was playing chess
and during the game
uh he yawned and he yawned
so widely that his jaw actually broke
and he had to be transported to the
hospital
that's true when he woke up from the
operation let me finish the story from
the operation they told him you yawned
and he asked what did i yawn
what did i blunder
this is true story i think so my coach
told it to me i i don't know if it's
true i have no idea but um
sounds a little far-fetched i'm trying
to think of yawning so much that my jaw
breaks
that sounds
that sounds skeptical rather strange
ailment yeah was that a six or was that
a false advertisement that was like a
three
well i have another true story but which
is true
[Music]
all right let's see what mirrors no we
were we were talking about art and
marcel deshawn actually it was a very
funny story because at some point he
abandoned everything and he played chess
and studied chess for years
and he well his first wife was so
annoyed with his passion that well
before leaving him let's see the story
goes that uh
he was analyzed in a position during
like their i think honeymoon or
absolutely very much as one does yes
so she will she was all so annoyed with
that that she glued the pieces so on the
yes to the board so see that's not
actually heard of that one yeah i had
never heard of it
and then they sold it for millions of
dollars so it's good artwork and
actually who told this story i think
it's man ray you know so it's like
it's an interesting twist well marcelo's
rob also has a sculpture of a urinal
right that has
sold for
valued at it's a regiment
yeah
marcel duchamp the legend
i mean nothing is worse than jeff koons
uh basketballs and the and the like uh
aquarium like a fish tank
i've never seen that oh my gosh he just
sells this stuff for so much money oh
it's honestly crazy yeah
is creative i was at a banksy exhibit in
san francisco a couple of months ago and
i could not believe how much some of
these paintings are like the fact that
art can be valued at like 50 million
dollars it's
it's just mind-boggling anyways what is
new in the world of hikaru's end game
k9 and
i think no progress has been made i mean
how long is gary gonna play this do you
think
when did uh when was the last bomb move
so uh there's a trade yeah
that looks like the last one but what
hikaru needs and i'm gonna let this
happen because i know we can give a
check but if we just make moves that
aren't necessarily good
and this knight comes to f3 this is the
start of how hikaru could win this game
because he needs to keep this king back
and the reason why it's so important is
that this king coming to f4 and putting
pressure on the pawns overloads white's
pieces so if you can start here
and then
get the move e5 in
and then you're going to bring your king
here give this check like this is how
hikaru can possibly win this game but
richard's not giving him any chance to
do so all of his moves have been keeping
the king out
and if the king if the knight goes here
with check the king goes right back to
e5 or even the g5 and there's no
progress to be made here this white's
king is stuck protecting the pawns
there's an even an iota not a scintilla
of doubt left in the result of the game
no this is uh
in sturdy defense by report
and now plenty of time to boot 30
minutes plus the question is just when
hikaro kind of acknowledges that there's
no more progress to be made i know when
that will be when he puts his jacket on
ah good one well i know when little is
going to be moving 109
because
you have to move upon
oh you think he's going to make 40 moves
man oh man you have to make progress at
some point that would be a lot of fun to
commentate
carver makes 15 moves
okay there's a check on d5 i think
that's right king g5 is going to follow
and report scurries back to the board he
was probably
enjoying the game between fabiano and
dingley ren as he undoubtedly finds that
more interesting more pieces on the
board more tactics available and here
their task is richards to defend so why
don't we just
maybe show everybody how we got here
it's been quite a long game we're
already a movie 71 but as we go through
the moves
we had especinikoff and dania was at the
telestrator showing some cool tactics
that are available and the
d6 square being
vulnerable and that's why black plays
move your line and the telescooter was
with knight d5 but as the game continued
i mean the critical moments
i think
were when richard played this move a5 i
think that was a very important moment
amira you were suggesting that move and
you found it
oh they're meeting the most so we don't
think we might skip over to them to the
end
i think they might have exchanged some
eye contact there
or are they repeating moves because he's
just got knight c4
yeah the knight was on d5 and went back
to e3 and then now to c4 so maybe it's
not a repetition but
richard's task is just
play bishop c7 yeah don't blend to the
bishop and
and this is probably very precise
because it keeps the knight out right
the knight could jump around
be
a nuisance but from c7 it keeps the note
that way of course it keeps it out this
way as well so
and knights can never lose a tempo
that's always an annoying thing in end
games you would like to just
pass the turn back to black but you
can't do that with the knight so
yeah and i mean there are end games
where like there are three or four
tricks
and
let's say the opponent has figured out
those tricks but you can keep trying
them in various iterations and in
various situations in this end game
there isn't even a single trick like
there isn't even a way to set a trap
black literally just moves the bishop
back and forth or the king from g5 to f6
and hikaru is he's annoyed but
let's see when he you know sort of comes
to terms with it
there's really not much he can do you
can keep trying to move his king up and
forward but the king comes to g5 and
says get right back to f3 if you try
something else where's your knight going
to go we can put it on any square but
black can go back and forth as long as i
don't walk into a fork then i can just
keep my king going here putting pressure
on
g4 otherwise stopping the pawn push from
e5 and the bishop keeps the king out of
f4 so
this is the perfect defensive setup for
report
yeah not much left to say here and he
car removes his knight again and he
moves it back to d2
and i think rapport will play bishop d6
he's bored back and forth
he's bored
he's like all right
let's get on with it yeah he knows that
this one is
going to be richer board
at the end of the tournament his hair is
going to be longer than mine i think
i
i like the luck
okay bishop d6 richard come on
you know it's
you just want to be careless
it's
getting late in the day
you play bishop b6 guys are playing
tricks on you yeah
and they both know the game will be a
draw but
you just stop thinking for one moment
and something can go wrong they're also
gaining 30 seconds per move because
they're so deep into the game of 74 was
just played so they passed move 60 which
is uh the part of the time patrol where
they get 30 seconds added to their clock
with every single move
yup
wow in the other game though
stuff's going down
stuff is changing but the evaluation is
not between dingley wren
and fabiana caruana let's have a look
as we pull that one up we see that
fobby's queen
after the move rook to c8 it decided to
swing over to b3
with
check and i like this decision by
fabiano because he's trying to keep as
many pieces on the board as possible
because black's king is less safe
ah but so queen of seven
uh he will play e6 here uh-oh and
what do we do this looks nasty actually
it says zeros but this is looking really
challenging for black
yeah i mean guess queen c7 uh you will
use the same idea yes in the previous
line i think there's also the idea of
going to rook c8 h8 like e7 check in
g7 let's say bishop f2
oh wow oh also a5 is hanging so
white does need to be a little bit
careful
right so if i go bishop b6 just to keep
that
safe and sound queen f4 and this e8
square
very well covered by black's pieces and
rook to h8 could turn the tables with
queen h2 check to follow
and there's a report behind him
report has been very interested in this
game but optically it looks very
dangerous
and somehow the computer's evaluation
and the objective evaluation of this
position is equal
yeah like you can play like king h8 so
you don't want to allow e6 for that kind
of tempo it looks
quite worrisome and dingley wren you
know he's had
two
straight victories before
he's met his match here in five minute
carwana but it's getting late in the day
it is past eight o'clock here in madrid
in the palacio de centonia and i moved
like king h8 i mean that just doesn't
look like a move you want to play i
understand that for now e-ticks have
succeeded you really want to play this
move don't you but it looks like d1
right it looks really scary no matter
where your rook goes up or to the side
here
and i would say that i think one of
ding's strengths is actually that he's
not he's rarely influenced by the
appearance of a certain position he
banks very heavily on his specific
calculation so i think my vote is with
queen f7
as long as you understand that e8 is
fully under black's control
e6 loses a lot of its luster and
queen f7 is a lot more forcing and it's
a lot more clearly defined than king h8
white just has less options
and he plays queen to f7 so you are
correct ding he doesn't
get bothered by the appearance of the
position he calculates at every turn
queen f7 i think e6 is
almost automatic unless um quick e3 also
yeah five minutes believes that leaving
the tension is good because maybe
eventually he'll get to the g5 pawn but
he plays e6 you have to i feel like
eventually it's gonna be played so he
plays e6 here
and we'll see how dingley run reacts but
queen c7 feels like a very good move it
just seems like a position where black
could make one mistake that looks very
logical and just lose but let me offer a
uh
an absurd sounding thought
if after queen c7
white gives up eight five then all of a
sudden you're playing for three results
so i think fabi with nine minutes on his
clock for the next six moves
has to be
very careful about how he manages the
situation
and we're being informed as we
they haven't talked about the other game
between hikaru nakamura and rich report
there might be a three-fold repetition
so that would end the game as a draw
between hikaru and richard and i will
check move 60
okay
that is this position position move
70 let's see what's up there
and move 72.
yep
and after this move here okay
and that looks like the third time so
let's go back tomorrow but wasn't it
no no no no but look look sorry i is my
fault king f6 was going to be six that's
the first time then we'll go forward
to move 70. and 7 is number two
and here is number three wow so yes he
had to stop the clock to write the move
king of six and to claim a draw
incredible i think he just didn't
realize that at all yeah it's a kind of
a weird pattern it's been ten moves
since it's happened but
are are not are ours allowed
to clown i don't think so never
okay carl looks like he's about to offer
a draw but he's just like not
he's just shuffling around but there's
it's aimless
it's totally aimless there's not even a
single idea like we were discussing
uh-huh so i knew the arbors can't step
in but it's only after a five-fold
repetition so it's gonna be a while
before we have that
the players it's their responsibility to
know when the position has been repeated
and for richard report i don't think he
cares that much because he knows the
defensive pattern he's not worried but
sometimes that comes back to cosplayers
where they're not
focused on the repetition they assume
it's gonna be a draw something
eventually changes and they're like wait
wait wait wait on move 30 there was that
repetition right
that's an infuriating feeling and i've
been witness to many incidents where
players claim repetition in the wrong
way they'll make the move first press
the clock and after you press a clock
you forfeit your opportunity to claim a
draw with the move that you just made
you have to write the move down stop the
clock but you can't actually execute the
move and press the clock well you're
talking about claiming a draw i have a
friend who played in the
european individual championship and her
opponent moved the rook and then went
eventually to castle
well she lost this game instead of
winning and she realized only that her
opponent made an illegal move while she
was um entering the game into the
database it wouldn't let her do it i
wouldn't let her do it and she was
absolutely destroyed can you imagine
like
yeah sometimes you just forget what
pieces have moved and how they legally
can but richard report not too many
pieces remaining here he knows what's up
the other game there's a pawn on e7 so
this one's an end game looking like a
surefire draw and the pawns e7 the king
went up to g7 so we might see a rook h8
type of move and the a5 pawn is hanging
i think this one might finish before
nakamura report at this rate
because richard is
now
again in the tank
and we were looking at bishop b6 here
queen f4
okay he's moved
after queen f4
maybe it's in favila's best interest at
some point just to get the queens off
the board i don't know if he actually
needs to be scared you can also play
some bishop d8 that's actually kind of
annoying it might force the bishop back
to e8
and this rook is free yeah rook c1 is a
huge positional threat
yeah this is simply a drawing bishop
where did he go
it should be d4 okay
putting pressure on f6
yeah queen f4 looks pretty good here
just attacking this bishop protecting
the pawn and there's no rook f1 ever
because the bishop covers the square so
wow it looks so scary for black right if
you looked at this position you would
say white has to be better maybe not
with a winning edge but you're like i
would if you ask 10 people which side
would you rather play with they're all
going to say white
so you mean that
well if you play queen f4 here and i
play bishop b2 you simply go for rocket
shade
i think so that looks pretty good
and there's
well i don't have a bullet left
and there it is no hesitation from ding
at all
queen f4 by dingley wren
king safety i think that's that's what
it boils down to
white's king is just a little bit too
unsafe to allow him
the ability to divert all of his
attention on pressing f6 and trying to
make use of the e-75
and all game we were talking about how
black's king was the one that was less
safe and at the end of it when you push
your pawns forward when your bishop has
to stay towards the queen side rather
than helping the king it's white's king
that can't find the shelter so
fabiano
i think that
maybe there could be some slight
disappointment if this game does end in
a draw because he has been pressing for
the second half of the game but early on
something went wrong for him and dingle
wren seemed to have
uh good chances and whoa wait a second
wait a minute what did i say oh my gosh
queen g3 queen g3 did he forget about
queen g3 because the queen on b3 is
unprotected oh gosh and there could be
an attack later here and fabi with five
minutes now for three big moves oh
oh my lands what is bishop e3 he lets
the queen sink its teeth into g3 and the
problem for white is that all the pieces
come to play oh my gosh checkmate in one
you might have to make a knight at some
point oh to distract the piece that
could be true which is a good thing to
remember everybody you don't need to
promote to a queen look when i do this i
can get a knight so at some point i may
need to promote to a knight to check the
king and distract black spiders
queen g3 he completely missed it oh my
gosh i mean just to continue this like
queen d2 here comes the rook to h8 with
queen h2 check coming because this pawn
is losing its defender
fabiano he probably just thought there's
nothing wrong with any of my moves and
now look at his face and he's changing
postures and he's panicking and he has
to keep his composure
he's not losing but he has to be very
precise and not get checkmated here oh
my gosh and at some point i do think
that e8 equals knight will be an
absolute necessity we'll go back down
that variation queen b4 played to keep
the rook on e1 safe you need to keep
that rook uh on the e file and bishop c6
queen d2 rook h8 let's say you make any
other move um bishop to d4 here comes my
queen into h2 with check king f1 i go
queen h1 check if your king moves i get
this pawn if your bishop goes to g1
my bishop covers the promotion square in
comes a rook lift here comes rook f4
check
oh my god bishop on c6 that's the hero
the bishop allows the rook and the queen
to fully invest themselves in the attack
against white's king amazingly the e7
plan isn't powerful enough and ding gets
up from the board he's got to be feeling
amazing right about now
and i know before the round i predicted
that dingley red would win the game with
the black pieces but not like this as
they say on twitch i mean how it looked
like white could never lose i was just
saying how 10 out of 10 people would say
they wanted the position from the white
side now mira one careless move and here
comes that queen of g3 well it's not a
careless move it's simply a sign of
fatigue i think that his brain simply
disconnected at this point in the game
because what did he think black would do
right
i completely agree with the owner it's
fatigue
exhaustion frustration probably with the
fact that he couldn't pull it off in
this position he's had now two games in
the second half of the tournament the
one against nepo and now the one against
ding which he might actually lose and
against nepo he came pretty close to
being worse as well that's true but in
this game now he's in mortal danger of
losing and he's spent a minute he's got
less than four minutes on the clock now
does he have it in him to save this game
and sometimes you press and press and
press thinking that you're still the one
in charge and you miss that moment when
it changes where you need to actually be
on the defensive you need to look out
for threats and he played a move with
two minutes and 40 seconds remaining he
still will have two more moves to make
and they're not easy moves uh for
example as we keep highlighting if
bishop c6 is played you know checkmate
and one is the threat but after bishop
c6 queen d2 rook h8 to
uncork e8 equals knight with check just
so you can distract black's pieces from
the mating attack if the rook takes in
comes his queen to f2 black is up a pawn
can play for a win but at least the king
is feeling a bit safer with the queen
nearby
but we couldn't imagine that there would
be some last minute drama crazy
in this game no i
mean it looked like
dingler and playing perfect defense but
then sometimes you turn defense into
offense and fabiano i mean he plays
queen b4 and ding what he's calculating
do i start with rook h8 do i start with
bishop to c6 maybe one is trickier than
the other
rook h8 of course the idea is to get
that queen down to h2 bishop c6 idea
give checkmate in one so both moves are
very appealing and maybe one is just
like i said more challenging
yeah bishop c6 looks
more human to me it looks more to the
point
but rook h8 is trickier in the sense
that
it sort of keeps the options more open
it threatens queen h2 check but you can
also then play bishop c6
let's see if ding plays fast here to try
to keep the pressure on fabby's clock
well dean with 31 minutes remaining he
has an eternity
for this position and he looked at fob
you saw that he glanced and read him he
senses this moment and this is important
because
earlier in the tournament even magnus
carlson was talking about it where you
have to turn into a shark well you don't
just say all right the worst is behind
me i can just make a draw that's a good
result you have to turn to shark and
now fabiano unfortunately for him he's
the one who has to watch out for that
bite yeah well as we all know jing is
such a kind person
so so soft-spoken but
that was a glance of an assassin
no he's the babyfaced assassin he has
let a few people off the hook this
tournament richard report the first time
they played was on the ropes and dingley
run couldn't find the knockout punch and
then when playing his team over java
right before the time control he made a
capture then spent the remaining time
and
was inaccurate and allowed timor to
escape and we're being told that in the
game between a car and report there's a
second threefold repetition that was not
claimed again i don't think that
richard report is scared about missing a
draw so he'll
claim it eventually i don't know what to
say so this one here though with this
queen on g3 and oh ding looked like he
was about to move
he glances over at the clock and he
hesitated now he puts his hands back
down
ah he looked ready
he still looks ready
and the car went richard a very
different game there between the one
between
five minute caron and dingley wren
and
ding needs to figure out do i bring my
bishop back first or swing my rook over
to h8 oh a little head shake there
maybe he saw something that he didn't
like maybe it was e8 equals night yes
the the possibility to throw in this
promotion with
check when you get a knight and forcing
black to deal with that threat but
ding must be
you know he must be feeling this right
now he's he's clearly
i think he knows that he's better like
matter of factly speaking yeah it's it's
he knows the fabby mist queen g3 and now
he goes to okay chain and he goes for
the more flexible move which i really
really like
again from the perspective of
exploiting fabby's time pressure to the
maximum and there's no way fabiano wants
to play e d e equals night so that's
this has been white's
chance at winning this game so to give
that up for free that's really difficult
to do psychologically and if fabiano
can't get rid of the oh oh
he grabbed a queen okay that's good news
for all the five-minute carwano fans out
there because if he sell the mindset of
you know i'm trying to hold on to that
pawn because i've been better
no he decides to get a queen and
block can just take it of course we have
a heart attack with the your
commentary you know like every time i
look at the board something tragic
happens
like i'm like
i cannot breathe anymore
well
hopefully it's a breath of fresh air but
the
e8 equals queen two queens on the board
for white one for black and now ding
once again sitting and thinking because
he could throw in this check on h2 or he
can just capture this queen and i think
he should capture with the bishop
because by capturing the bishop he
leaves alive the threats down the h file
and
the real benefit of
jettisoning this pawn giving it away is
that you've given your queen the e7
square at some point that might be what
white needs to
hold this game so maybe it's a slight
difference between uh
rook h8 and bishop c6 that you are
simply taking on eight and you're not
losing the tempo
that's true oh
the bishop didn't have to stop so bishop
b8
yeah bishop e8 i think ding is gonna
play
and then fabi with
one more move to make until the extra 15
minutes and it's a critical move and i
don't think you want to give a check on
e7 i think that's the pitfall that
fabian has to avoid the problem with
giving this check is after bishop f7 if
you now play bishop d4 the bishop is
going to be undefended and black can try
to pick it off with a check on h2
followed by a check on h1
or no sorry check on f4 that's it rook
h1 and you start streaming in with
devastating effect ouch and this is
another check on c4 this king has to go
on a walk it's not going to be very
happy this isn't a you know on the
promenade it's out into the open where
uh everything is aiming at you so
let's see e8
and ding is thinking here which
on one hand is good because you want to
make the right move but on the other
five mode doesn't have time so capturing
right away could put pressure on fabiano
and i think it's pretty clear that rook
takes e8 is undesirable because bishop
f2 can be played attacking the queen
opening the rooks up to one another and
a rook trade would be very helpful for
white strong chances because your king
will feel safer with fewer pieces
remaining on the board i guess there is
queen h2 check which is an intro mezzo
and fabi should have made a knight
that would have been a check and it
would have forced black to recapture
unless he thinks queen h2 is a mistake
and he wants to bait him into it wow
that that would be fascinating if he
realizes the queen issue is actually not
the correct move and it's tempting to
draw that king out more towards the
center but
fabi gave him the option to give that
check and ding is going to use some time
to think about it i think there is a
problem with queen h2 because in the
variation that we were analyzing before
then you can sacrifice on g5 game queen
e7 and queen g5 ah
[Music]
so as digler calculates we'll show some
analysis here of queen h2 check
king f2 so you take with the bishop then
maybe i can take on g5 and q in a seven
queen g5 it's a draw after bishop takes
it bishop takes g5 already oh my gosh
yeah queen d4 check
this king is just being hunted you can't
go to the back rank because of
this bishop hanging if you go to f8 over
here this queen has a bunch of queen f6
actually is a mistake it says just zeros
but instead i mean that's tempting and
don't play queen d6 forgetting that this
queen can go backwards but queen c5 and
this pawn will hang with check this rook
comes into e7 i was only looking for a
draw yeah but there's more it's
incredible
wow this king is just quit i mean
it's running out of moose so you cannot
take on g5
so if you can't take it back on g5 then
it's clear that no you don't have
anything like bishop g5 then you have to
make another one you have to play rook
takes e8
but then there might be still bishop
takes g5 amazingly because rookie one
queenie one
then the queen travels to es7 if you
take immediately then it's easy right
you taking queen e7 etc
yeah the queen will just give a bunch of
checks but if you take on e1 the queen
takes back and similar idea right you
lose your bishop yeah and then you go
queen e7 right once the king goes up you
go queen e6 check and
if king h5 win f7 king g4 and now queen
back to e6 and you can't go down four
it's so tempting to go to f3 if it's a
mistake because
you have no more good checks if you
check here we interpose with check
training the queens exactly queen e6
well but it's absolutely fascinating oh
you played queen hd he did
oh my goodness could you imagine if
fabiano after queen hitchhike king f2 if
ding is still playing for a win and we
see bishop takes g5 which we don't we
don't he when rook takes e8 okay fabby's
gonna find bishop takes g5 and that's
how the game is gonna end and fabi gets
15 more minutes so he doesn't have to
worry about flagging just yet that's a
big moment for the top player from the
united states who's been in second place
throughout this event and he needs to
remain in second place hikaru
akara's face is like what in the world
has happened here yeah he can't believe
that is on the defensive and his jacket
is on by the way he knows it's over
because report is one move away from
drawing the game
he's still taking
a lot of time but
i think we're going to get some new
social media content out of that
reaction by hikaru i mean he he can't
believe what happened to fabulous
position fabinho was the one who's
pressing this whole time and now it's an
extra pawn for black it's crazy
but fortunately for fabio bishop takes
g5
is a saving grace it's probably not the
only move you could also drop the bishop
back to you i'm very surprised by ding's
choice i personally thought that
the immediate bishop c6 might have been
the best chance
but
second best would have been to take with
uh the bishop in this position forcing
fabi to find a very difficult 60th move
yeah though i think back here you're
saying that rook h8 made it a little bit
easier than bishop c6
which forces this queen back to d2 to
help and then rook h8 and the attack
which is just getting started i mean e8
knight moved 60. can you imagine how
hard that is to find
first of all look at fabi you know how
difficult it it was for him to survive
through the time trouble
and now he has to calculate once again
he's given only 15 minutes he has to be
extremely precise
and to find the only move not to lose
bishop g5 and he needs to find hikaru
nakamura's approval because a car who
keeps coming back to the board shaking
his head he cannot believe what has
happened to fabinho carl in his position
but you know what hikar is doing he's
calculating bishop takes g5 he is
looking at this game
he can't help it and you can see it you
could see the calculations in his head
then he shakes his head i don't know if
he's more upset with fabiano's game or
his own but i can tell he's looking at
bishop takes g5 and trying to see is
that a force draw
yeah
that's exactly what he's doing
fabi will probably take maybe even
i mean if bishop takes g5 is not hard to
calculate because
the variations are so forced the black
king doesn't have that many pathways
that it can take
due to the
queen skewer on h8 so the king can never
escape to h5
right and i do want to draw our
attention to that hikar nakamura game we
saw his jacket is on it looks like he is
ready to go so as we bring back the
multiple board view here we see that
report has grabbed the g-pawn hikaru's
e-pawn is running up the board
and well
we talked about this earlier
the bishop just covers the square the
the dark square and even if you had some
defense of the score of 95 you
sacrificed the bishop for that pawn and
then white does not have mating material
but there's a nice line here 95 track
report
is intending king g5 looks like a
terrible blunder
oh wow but the king makes its way to e7
this is what he spent so much time
calculating
wow wow wow king f6 knight takes and it
looks like white's about to win and is
one move away from victory if the king
were on d5 but for king e7 either you
move your knight and lose your remaining
pawn and fab or you lose your knight i
think fabric grabbed on g5
okay
so while hikaru makes the last few moves
of his draw uh we'll bring up or diddy
whoa queen no we did not is that a queen
on g4
he didn't see it
oh my god
oh my goodness and now dingley wren can
try to play for a win
like queen e5 win h2 to e5 just get it
back and enjoy your extra pun
oh my gosh fabi is
completely out of sorts
and
i guess after queen e5 this queen can
come to d4 and you just start offering
trades but
ding for the moment he can avoid those
trades and if this rook
ever gets into the action if this rook
can come up just for e5 or e4 and the
king doesn't get checked a bunch this
could be really really bad for fabiano
yeah
so let's have a look at queen d4
by 25 queen d4
queen f5 king g1
bring this rook up i guess and okay four
[Music]
yeah queen a7 check just king g6 that
king has a great little
spot on g6 where you can
ride out the storm
this is
scary
white
might very well lose this oh my gosh
unbelievable oh my god oh yes and i
cannot leave the like the first strong i
cannot play rook c1 or c7 because you
always have queen f1
yeah that's right this this
this queen e5 move is so annoying
and if you play bishop d2 which i think
is a tempting move trying to trade right
the queen comes to c5 with check and if
you play bishop to e3 the queen comes
down to c2 with check i keep checking
you your king comes to the first rank
and i think already i have this move
take stakes queen f1
check queen see one rather queen d2
bishop c66 queen d2 and
you have a problem your king just stay
attached to the rook which means king f3
and then bishop c6 check those kings out
in the open you are going to lose this
rook
oh my gosh
i can't believe it
what an unexpected
turn or twist
i don't usually say this i feel like i'm
usually defending top players for
missing moves
but i can't believe fabby miss bishop
takes g5 i mean that is a move you
consider
that's the first thing you consider what
happens if i liquidate and sacrifice and
try to force the draw
and
time trouble is going to be a theme once
again because 500 is 14 minutes and 29
seconds he will get 30 seconds per move
but his king is so
wide open
in trouble vulnerable that
oh it's going to be difficult
well ding's going to play queen e5 no
question in my mind
i think we're going to say queen e5
queen d4
and then queen f5 check and thing is
going to try to win that position
incredible
and it looks like rajaba okay
yeah report and hikaru
they are making their draw so just that
one pawn pushing on the board until
hikaru takes it and that will be the
draw so
report kind of laughed he said ah come
on do we really need to do this all the
way but the top players they do that now
in the old days they just agreed to draw
really early now they play it out the
last piece is captured right
well the knight's going to remain on the
board but as we know
king and knight versus king there is no
checkmate as he takes the final pawn and
as the players shake hands what a
dogfight a 95 move affair disappointing
for hikaru but richard report he isn't
exactly
you know the weakest link pretty decent
player
yeah i think the most frustrating part
for a car was would be that he never had
an advantage that it looked pretty nice
for him at certain points but he never
could press he never could make richard
suffer so that typically is what bothers
these top players most is not
necessarily the result of the game but
if they couldn't actually exert any sort
of pressure on the opponent
oh
and they're just talking to each other i
guess they're
trying to
figure out where things could have gone
differently
uh really long game but i would say for
the last 40 moves of this 95 move game
it wasn't
exactly that interesting not too much to
talk about but they're talking about the
opening stage it seems pointing to
squares and
two players friendly but it's been a
long day so time to go time to eat and
then come back tomorrow so you're
getting better at it
treating those conversations
i'm just saying things and hopefully
hopefully
hoping that it's accurate but he car
with his plastic bag
he goes away and he is in second place
so
with dingley wren and fabiano caruana
in the middle of their game or well
towards the end but still fighting
hikaru is alone in second and he
probably hopes that this game is not
decisive in dingley wren's favor because
dingley run would leapfrog him in the
standings and there is now trading at
the bottom of the standings
wow that's such disappoints and results
yeah and and jan is watching the car
wanna ding game with horror
because this was supposed to be a
surefire draw and then his lead would
have been extended to two points if
dingle run wins this game
it's a one and a half point lead still
huge queenie five on the board but that
makes the possibility of a miracle just
a little bit bigger it's annoying it's
annoying for yon to have to deal with
that and i know that fabinho caruana's
the player who went seven out of seven
the sinkfield cup but i think as the
players are just registering who's in
the best form at the moment they're all
looking at dingley ran like this guy
could win every single game he plays
right jan
wisely made a draw against ding hit the
white pieces he'd never even allowed
ding to have a chance
the game's over as soon as it starts and
that since then dingley wren has been a
man on a mission and
right now after queen to d4 i mean this
position is really difficult for fabiano
maybe he will find inaccurate defense
but with that g2 pawn being on a light
square black having a light square
bishop we just saw queen f5 and ooh king
g6 played i actually really like that
move by ding i feel like the slow play
is the strong play
yeah rookie four
looks very appealing as well and he
might still go rookie four but he's
reserving for himself the option
of playing differently maybe bishop c6
first he's trying to be as flexible as
possible when you're in time pressure
these types of moves like king g6 are
the hardest to face because they give
you the most amount of options
well but on the other hand you cannot
exchange rooks you cannot play bishop f2
you cannot play bishop d2 because i
simply take only one and i win a piece
that's true
queen f1 so
queen d2 looks basically forced
i suppose so quincy two and rookie four
now
yes yeah
okay now bishop f2 that's
g4 ah and then there's queen d8
and somehow you're holding on bishop c4
yeah because if you get
this check here that's going to be
a
draw over here so you don't have time to
play bishop c6 which you really would
like to do bishop c4 acquired bishop f7
but then black is
going backwards and then this queen can
just
venture all the way down here in defense
a6 is threatened in some positions if
you move your bishop queen goes right
back to e8 it feels like bobby barely
holding on there and did he just play
queen to d2 yesterday he did
oh a card just won the high accuracy on
chess come game analysis that is what
happens when players play 95 moves kind
of skews the data because the last 50
moves were just shuffling back and forth
but this game i mean this hasn't been
perfect
it has had its fair share of
inaccuracies one of which came right
before the time patrol right
what an unbelievable turnaround i'm
still wrapping my head around the fact
that ding is the only one who can win
this game now
i mean if you told us that after the
opening i wouldn't be surprised knowing
what the middle game looked like
this is just nuts and i wonder if ding
is going to try to play relatively
quickly here i said this right before
the time control i think it's true again
that'd be not a lot of time here
and if didn't can get us whittle his
clock down to five or six minutes
that additional factor could cause fabby
to panic even further
but it almost feels like dingley wren is
not trying to punish fabian the clock
maybe he believes in fabi's blitz skills
which does make sense because fabiano
currently is the number i think three
rated blitz player on the planet he's
gone to something like 2840 in blitz
which will come as a surprise to many
because that was the part of his game
that people most criticized they said
maybe he can play magnus in the
classical chess but rapping and blitz he
has no chance but he's actually improved
greatly his rapid and blitz play so i
think ding maybe a few years ago he
would think let me try to pressure him
the clock more and ignore some of the
subtleties on the board and now he's
like no fabiano he can really play in
time trouble let's just try to beat him
or cause the most problems here from the
position oh but maybe it also depends on
the position you know if they would
start a blitz game well
from the initial position that would
certainly be true but it's very
difficult to defend those
well
in a time trouble because just
you can try and penetrate
the h file
put your bishop on c6 once again so
there's so many options for uh for black
so many options this bishop at any
moment can switch diagonals there's no
ability for white to trade queens
because as soon as you try to over here
eve we're going to ignore the bishop was
hanging just the bishop can just come in
d3 so what white wants to trade pieces
and black can avoid that for
the foreseeable future
yeah but what is the most precise move
now for black
um
ca rookie four
these two are very tempting so the
difference between rookie four and
king just six is that now king g6 allows
all kinds of perpetual the king and g7
was actually standing much better from
this point of view so you can you could
play rook e4 and rook g4
safely
now um
maybe ah maybe he can start with rook c8
and rook c2
yeah that that is a very annoying move
but roxy there is rook c1
and let's not forget that another
pathway
is through the h file
which where the rook was previously so
you could go rooks you could induce rook
c1 and then go rocate shade i'm not sure
how that impacts the position
but
lots of different angles to explore for
the rook well speaking of angles we have
so many good camera angles our
production team working so hard
that's
one angle
enjoying that one oh
we got a different
oh
uh-huh and so many cameras fourth one
would be nice wow there we
go and a fifth one
oh my goodness well modern technology
ladies and gentlemen they must feel like
models because all those cameras
snapping shots of them but they are
fully focused so even if cameras were
being clicked they would not be able to
notice because this one has their
undivided attention and rook c i like
what we were just talking about rook c8
rook c1 you definitely do not want to
trade rooks and rook h8 makes a lot of
sense because now that the rook is no
longer on e1
i may be able to get my queen over here
to e5 and then go back to the plan
on the h2 square but no it looks like
dingley wren
started with bishop c6
and the great thing about his position
elmira is that he can just like shuffle
and do a bunch of things and fabiano
will continue to have to defend well
actually i was thinking that we have so
many angles and we have access to so
much information the one information
actually want to have now is their heart
rate
i know that at some tournaments uh well
players accepted that their heart rate
would be measured during the game
and i think this would be a clear
indicator like how they actually feel at
this very moment
i would imagine that fabiano's heart
rate is
pretty intense i think that dingley run
he looks like he's hanging out he got
exactly 30 minutes remaining earlier i
saw the hikara had an exactly one hour
on the clock so you don't really see all
zeroes
too often but dingley ran
30 minutes fabiano 13 and less than
13 and a half minutes he's thinking on
this move and we know he would love
nothing more than to trade these rooks
here for one another but he needs to
make it work and he
plays bishop
d4 good mo no
no but bishop d4 because now that the
bishop has left the uh well the f1 a6
diagonal rook f1 was possible oh my
goodness that's true right the bishop oh
that was a big threat so bishop f2 also
looks
pretty sound
but there is the move
queen g4 in response to bishop f2
because another difference between the
two bishop placements is that on f2 it
intercepts the contact
between the white queen and the g2 pawn
allowing four mate threats but bishop b4
does that almost force the rooks off
because rook effect is a threat which
means that you either play a very
passive move like rook f8 just to keep
them on
or you trade the rooks and try to win
that end game but that doesn't look so
good so dingley wren i mean he
has been benefiting from some
inaccuracies and let's take a look at
the player
it took some good fortune but dingley
wren arrives at the candidates with some
very legitimate reasons to think he can
secure a bid to challenge for the world
title for the very first time
a visa issue originally kept ding out of
the last opportunity to qualify but when
a spot opened ding was next man up based
upon his hot streak of late
the timing couldn't be better for ding
an entertaining and unpredictable player
ding enters the candidates rated higher
than any player in the field
the chat went nuts they love their man
dingley run we said this is an engine
move humans don't find it and he found
king f1 i am absolutely stunned once
again this is such a difficult move
the strongest player in china's history
ding is the only player from that
country to earn a 2800 rating
launched by an undefeated streak across
100 straight classical games ding has
sat amongst the world's top five for the
past five years
once out of the tournament completely
deng now aims to bring china into a
world chess championship match for the
first time in his native lands history
ding lee wren the number one player from
china he's still fighting for a win in
this 11th round he's won two games in a
row before this and he has two whites in
his remaining three games so
i mean what a player he is we know what
he's capable of and unfortunately for
fabiano caruana he's finding it out once
again i'm not saying that this game is
in the books this win is not secured but
fabio has a bad lifetime record against
stingley wren and his position is not
good right now well actually what i was
thinking is like can we have a look at
the standings if ding wins
his four games the remaining four games
and if jan uh draws all of his remaining
games yeah like what is happening
because i cannot then dingle wren will
finish with nine and a half points and
jan will finish with the same with the
nine and a half years also we have a
queen trader we have like
a possibility of a tie break if nobody
can stop dingley rendon yeah we
certainly would but right now five
minute carana doing his best we just saw
the queens come off the board bishop e4
queen g3 and the move queen takes bishop
takes an f5 played by dingley rennan
this is a position where
white should be capable of holding a
draw we know that based on the
evaluation but
the issues are not going away this king
is about to go king h5 king g4 this pawn
might play f4 and f3 at some point if
this king remains here so black can
create a pass pawn black can also free
the rook now and maybe go for that a5
pawn while also threatening to put
pressure on the g2 pawn
yeah i would i would estimate
black's drawing chances as at least
equivalent to white's winning chances
and the reason why is because
there is just no way for white to force
anything black can maneuver for 50 moves
and then black and choose to play f4
essentially whenever he wants to and on
top of all of that there's a very clear
plan of action for black it's not like
one of those positions where you're just
shuffling forever you want to push your
kingside pawns and white has to be very
precise to do something about it i think
fabi played bishop c7
that appears to be a very accurate
defensive move well i i was thinking
that you should start with king h5 and
bring your king to g4 before you play
well
something very concrete like a four
maybe then king h5 king g4 then rook c8
rook c2
and then f4 so uh what move for white
after kh5
are you going to play g3 here this looks
very scary no it's like a move i would
never want to play but i can understand
it king of two would say the king runs
away so king f2
here king g4
right
well
you cannot wait forever so let's say
you're um
you'll play something like rook c1
yeah rook c1 because anytime you play g3
here
it's important to point out that you're
opening up the h2 square for the black
rook right
so
you said rook c1
okay
now
the question for black is when do you
play at four because you don't want to
play too early because you might walk
into rookie one
i need to bring my rook first so here i
cannot play rogue d8 so i will start
with rookie 7 and rogue d7 then god this
is so nasty rook d7 is coming then rook
d2 is going to be a big threat
and
i really have no idea what white's best
defensive setup is here
it's just super super nasty
wow
and fabiano still with a decent amount
of time here 12 minutes 45 seconds the
clock is ticking but he gets those 30
seconds with every move played and the
problem i guess is that every move for
black is so easy to play and every move
for white is so hard
geez
is there a way that you can um
replace your bishop
somewhere to d8 and bring your rook to
c5 so you will not allow me to advance
to attack the g5 phone you can do that
but then then you'd open up the second
rank
so
then i try to get my rook to d2
i feel like whichever defensive
construction you choose there's always
going to be
one of two things either you'll allow me
to push my pawns or you'll allow me to
infiltrate with my rook to the second
rank
big questions for five minute car wanted
to answer he has enough time dingley
wren bringing his pieces forward but we
are going to take a quick break we'll
leave these players to it the game will
continue it's going to be close to see
if dingley rank can win but for now
we're going to head out for just a few
minutes this is round 11 coverage of the
2022 feed a candidate brought to you by
chess.com
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botes gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com
insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
[Music]
a
we always say we are a family the people
who come here
say that it is like being home
everyone is very comfortable here empire
[Music]
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing but chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kit helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it is night time here in madrid the
people are out and about it's a very
lively city
some of the chess players wish they
could be out and about but they're still
struggling with the defensive task but
as you see so many people in this
beautiful city enjoying the night life
and we're enjoying
the end of this game move 72 between
dingley wren with the black pieces five
minute carwana with white and as a
reminder to everybody i'm joined in
studio by international master amira
skripchenko grand master daniel
naraditsky i'm grand master robert hess
and we're watching these two
grandmasters slug it out they're giving
it their all here at the palacio de
centonia well i think talking about
players we are hanging here on the
thread you know
i'm not ashamed to be drinking coffee
well i'm not asking for sympathy from
the chat but i will ask you to give your
questions we're happy to answer any well
not any i shouldn't say that but plenty
of the questions you throw at us and as
you see we have three games already done
with yonda palmishi the big winner he
keeps on winning other players drawing
and he is trying to extend his lead in
this competition two points ahead of
hikaru nakamura and he will remain two
points ahead of his nearest competitors
if this game between dingley rand and
faviano karwana is drawn but right now
dingley wren the number one player from
china the number two rated player in the
world he is trying to convert an
advantage into a full point i mean the
fact that we even have this end game
is absolutely unbelievable and remember
that as fabi defends it as his time
takes down to nine minutes and counting
he still has that voice in his head that
says i could have been eating a
delicious paella right now with my team
win or drop but the fact that i allowed
this end game is unbelievable so not
only is this almost indefensible from a
human point of view even though this
should be drawable he's got that voice
in his head he's tired after six hours
of play
and what an unbelievable turnaround
we've seen in this game simply
incredible and fabi
with less than nine minutes plays rook
c3 and apparently that was a big
oh my goodness bishop d3 bishop d3 wins
it oh my gosh because after bishop d3 if
you take this bishop on d3 when he
missed it oh no dingley ren didn't say
way too fast he had so much time
oh my goodness ding i still think he's
gonna win this game though no i i i
don't disagree with you there but
anytime very findable if we just show
really quickly g3 played by fabiano
because rook d2 check was the threat as
black takes over the second rank but
just there after rook c3 and inaccuracy
because bishop d3 allows the rook to
infiltrate and if you say whoa
whoa that's a free bishop no it's a
bishop trade the active king the extra
pawn win this game for black rook c5 is
one threat rook c2 is another if the
rook leaves the third rank so this would
have been
winning for it and i can understand that
rook d6 it looks like you're going to
get this pawn but after f4 this is the
issue you gain the a6 pawn the rook
swoops down to c2 the king returns in
the first rank and after king g3 it's
all over when he was playing instantly i
thought it was going to be bishop d3
that is
a very uncharacteristic miss for ding
and the reason he missed it i think is
because he wasn't looking for it he just
didn't realize that a tactic could have
existed in such a position
fatigue only our fatigue six hours
but fabiano missed it as well you know
how many moves
the players have missed
well
during this game a lot and i i think
that what we were talking about earlier
dingley wren he wasn't rushing he wasn't
speeding up he wasn't trying to win on
the clock and then suddenly he did make
a really fast move and that's what's i
think uncharacteristic is in previous
games in previous moves within this game
it's felt like he's always been
deliberate he's methodical he's not
playing something just for the sake of
making a move and in the most critical
moment of his game here that he could
have played bishop to d3 and he still
can and i agree with donya that winning
chances are very high for black just
because the king's activity and the
extra pawn but he had a chance to secure
victory it looked like on that last turn
and then after bishop d3 here
yep as we analyze bishop to d3 right now
sure what is the useful move for
white
great question because you're just
trying to keep the bishop on okay bishop
b6
should b6 bishop b5 rock c2 rock h7 and
you're going to resign oh no rooksy four
check then i was thinking of rook to d3
but rook h7 also i was here
okay rook c5 is totally inhuman oh my
gosh nobody plays that
you probably rook c3 but even still like
with this rook just going everywhere in
the position
let alone the fact that black can play
f4 at any moment and it's not like if
black plays out for it's a draw no
trying to get that pawn going up the
board because the king the rook the
bishop all towards the f-file here wow
this is not easy at all
for
fabiano caruana and he is playing quick
moves he played g3 didn't spend too much
time to do so
but almera do you believe in fabi's
defense well the only miracle saved that
i found here is that the bishop is
well of the wrong color so if you trade
rooks and sacrifice your bishop for for
the two pounds f and g then this would
be a draw
but
right
let's let's find
how to
all how to do so because it's not an
easy task
yeah it seems difficult to imagine a
scenario where i mean i don't know how
to win this pawn but in the event that
we do and the rooks get traded that's a
really really good point uh by almira
there so that's what black would like to
avoid and
i just i think we need to show that line
with bishop let's do it because ding is
now thinking the one move in this entire
game which he played instantly he should
have taken his time bishop d3 and it's
not like white has to take right white
can move this bishop somewhere let's say
bishop b6 but the problem is once this
rook comes in your king does not want to
be in line with this enemy bishop and
this bishop will just go back and your
king eventually will have to move anyway
to g1 and once the king goes to g1 in
comes the bishop to e4 the rook and
bishop team up if you play bishop to f2
now the rook goes to the other side of
the board and i actually had one to make
this point earlier that getting your
rook to a2 is the dream come true for
black because you're aiming along the
second rank at this weak g pawn also at
this pawn a5 and if you try to defend
for a little bit longer i think that
white essentially isn't supesvong after
king f4 you don't have a rook move on
the fifth rank to keep this pawn on the
side you push your pawn you're just
inviting the king into f3 and you know
your king action on g1 probably will get
made at some point soon so bishop can't
move g2 is hanging wow what a one
fascinating little zoom song there
incredible white seems to have so many
moves and yet everything loses the game
if i may go on a very quick detour just
to finish the topic of why ding this
bishop d3 when he played rookie 7
he has this crystal clear idea of going
rook d7 and i think the important word
here is the word attention he's just not
paying attention to the fact the c7
bishop
uh is being made contact with by the
rook this reminds me of this like very
famous psychology experiment
where they showed a group of
participants a video and we're having
some moves here bishop d3 bishop b8 so
nothing crazy happening for now they
showed a video a bunch of people passing
basketballs and you were supposed to
count the number of basketball passes
that were made a very difficult task
because there were 100 people and like
five different basketballs and the point
is
there was a person in a gorilla costume
walking across the screen throughout the
video and the point is that something
like a third or even a half of people do
not see this gorilla person even though
they're right in the middle of the
screen because they're not paying
attention to it so very often when you
think how could a player of ding's
caliber miss bishop d3 he's just not
paying attention to the pertinent
tactical factors he ain't seeing the
gorilla man because he isn't looking for
him yes he's too fixated on his existing
idea but we've got some moves and the
bishop is back to b5 and we should
always contextualize it of course it's
much easier to see these moves when you
have a swinging evaluation bar going up
and down when a player makes a mistake
so without that it becomes much more
difficult and still dingley wren presses
on here and he is trying to get his rook
into
the second rank force the king to the
first rank and his
pawn on g3 protected by the bishop
long live the long range piece and i was
wondering uh just hypothetically if uh
black sacrifices the rook on g3 is this
a winning position ah okay so you're
saying if the rook takes this pawn and
you get the bishop and the pawn for this
rook would this be winning it depends
maybe on why it's on the position of the
white's king at that moment and the
white rook because rook takes b5
and a6
is also in play
and i also think that if this rook
sacrificed itself for these pawns in
that like if we take away all the pieces
that i have highlighted in red
that's the draw that that's the miracle
scene that's the miracle save
oh rookie seven rooks
he allowed the rook to make contact with
the bishop oh my gosh rookie seven the
rook just goes am i right rookie seven
rook c2 bishop d3 oh love when that
analogy forces the rook off the second
rank it's unbelievable bishop d3 ding is
gonna play it quickly this is unmissable
oh my gosh
oh dingley wren has been given several
chances on a golden platter but it was
from his tenacious defense that's where
it all started and then he turned that
defense into offense as soon as fabiano
missed i'm gonna bring back that
position to show everybody where the
tides started turning it was right
around here the bishop came to d4 for
car one you have a pawn on e7 for
goodness sakes pressure against this
king but the queen swoops into f4 the
bishop comes back to save itself and
then queen g3 you see the evaluation bar
dipping this turned from a position
where black's king was in trouble to
whites fabiano he never quite seemed to
get his feet underneath him with the
pressure and rook e7 was in fact just
played and this is a winning position
for dingley wren the evaluation bar has
gone all the way down
minus six territory with the threat of
rook e2 check oh my gosh and fabi you
can tell he's one of the most
unemotional one of the most professional
players of the chessboard but even he
you can sense the consternation you can
feel it
and let's be real with seven minutes for
the rest of the game defending this
position
after such a miss as he as he committed
earlier in the game virtually impossible
well you guess you're going to kill me
one day
[Laughter]
oh well the chat is saying yes that some
dingly wren fans here we have a clap for
ding and oh my goodness this threat of
rook e2 check this is lights out for
five out of caruana who started this
event he was on a winning streak five
points out of seven games in any other
event with any other player besides john
nepamashi that would have led the
tournament but jan was
really just on his form has been
throughout this event that put pressure
on fabiano finally lost first dakar
nakamura couldn't beat napalm and she
lost the game to yanchistov duda and it
looks like dingley wren is going to win
his third game in a row and he will be
the only player to win three in a row
that is a feat that
doesn't happen very you know how hard it
is to win three in a row at canada to
win one game at the candidates even
that's a feat that not everybody manages
to win three games in a row
and were two of them with black
yes
two in a row you're like in a row with
black you beat carolina today you beat
duda on the first day oh my god and
yesterday he beat richard report and he
was so close
well to winning against tim or jabba yes
yes
i mean we know that yonder palm she is
in the lead in this tournament and he
deserves to be there but i've said this
numerous times where i think dingley ren
might be playing just as good of a
tournament he doesn't have the same
score but the quality of his play
in this game he actually made a huge
mistake right he had a better position
after the opening stage and he allowed
fabiano to gain control of the game and
he then he played good defense but
throughout this tournament he's had like
two games where he's been worse game one
against the underpants that he lost and
this game today which he has turned
right back around so
he has really played some stellar chests
in this tournament and as you look at
fabiano caruana i think the lights are
leaving for this one i think he realizes
that he cannot stop the infiltration and
once this rook gets to e2 this king is
forced to the back rank there's all
sorts of checkmating threats that are
going to be available and five and a
quarter he knows that this game is out
of hand
we talked a lot about why it seems the
ding is a second half player why does he
struggle so much in the first half of
the tournament when this is what his
real level is like i think we can't
forget about nerves i think he looked
really really nervous during his first
round game against nepo he was
completely unrecognizable he was
literally going back and forth the delta
between how he played then and how he's
playing now is absolutely massive let's
not forget one sting had that bad start
the pressure was off his back nobody was
expecting him to make a push people were
saying he would be in last place and
that i think actually motivated him
there's no discussion about you nobody's
really looking at your games quite as
intently that's when he started firing
on all cylinders and look at him go now
yeah he knows that he's winning and the
opposite side of celebration jubilation
is heartbreak and you can see it in
fabiano's eyes i know him very well
we've been friends for a long time and
you can see that fabiano who started
with three wins and no losses in the
first half he's about to have three
losses and no wins in the second so this
has just
not been his last few rounds if you want
to call it a mini tournament he wishes
it never happened and this king is about
to come into h3 or bishop d3 by the way
bishop d3 as well to cut the rook off
but once this king gets to h3 there are
all sorts of mating nets and traps with
a rook coming to g2 this bishop cuts the
king off from walking towards the center
oh my goodness i cannot believe what
we're witnessing robert what did you
taint during the break because like
you're
you're full of life
am i not always full of life
but compared to us you know
i just you know this is really
mesmerizing d3 bishop d3 that threatens
king takes g3 oh my god the reason
that's a threat is because that in
itself creates the mate threat on d1
bishop d3 bishop d6 is forced and now
the king sidesteps the pawn and moves to
h3 the threat is rook g2 check and
bishop e4 the one thing that black has
to be careful about is stalemate but
there is no way for white to actually
give up both the rook and the bishop by
force yeah and i just gotta finish the
sequence over here rook g2 check because
the bishop covers f1 the king goes to
the corner and after bishop to e4
this is threatening all sorts of things
including a rook check here rook takes
pawn with mate oh my gosh ding he smells
blood he has become the shark he has
become the shark in the second half of
the tournament
and
almira you asked what happens if dingley
wren wins all of his games i think that
yon napomshi we had him here he said i'm
focusing on my next game because
i believe that people think dingler can
win every single game he plays i
actually resigns he resigns the game is
over dingley wren in clear second place
fabiano carwana's lifetime score drops
to two wins for carwana six for dingley
ren and it's really unfortunate for fabi
he i mean he came into this tournament
with high hopes and expectations for
himself and dingley wren who
in the first half had a minus score he's
come out of nowhere and he's come firing
well and fabiana looked at
the board in complete disbelief
she's like what have i done
yeah and he left
the playing hall immediately so
yeah
when a player of fabby's caliber loses a
game like that
you can never really believe it i mean
bishop bishop e3 baby lost his mind but
it was ding's dogged defense it was his
persistence his resistance the fact that
he didn't let things go out of control
when ding made that initial mistake
taking on b3 with the rook the guy as a
professional never quits and he is
finally getting awarded here in the
second half of the tournament and jan
napomnishi he must be feeling mighty
annoyed that this game did not end in a
draw
i mean dingley wren three wins in a row
we see here he was the last game to
finish he's the last game on our graphic
and the only other player to win
unfortunately for dingley ren is yon
napomshi who played an excellent game
with the black pieces he let ali riza
faruja go too far and once frozen threw
his pawns up the board jan said you have
no attack i'm going to counter and he
scored that full point
it was an incredible game by jan it was
essentially a perfect game even though
he was pretty critical of himself
amazingly the yandapamyushi solidifies
his one and a half point lead and if you
heard us say that dingley wren would be
in clear second place
after round three after round four you
would ask what alternate reality are you
living in
it's our current reality dingli ren is
the hero of today's round but yon
napaneshi he is still ahead of the
tournament by a country mile
i just can't believe it right because
dingley wren he
is the first player since 2013 to win
three consecutive games at the
candidates that's an accomplishment in
and of itself but as we look at the
standings he is in clear second fabiano
caruana drops all the way down to fourth
that seemed impossible when everyone was
calling this a two-horse race between
caruana and the palm street but dingley
wren three wins seven draws and only
that one loss
maybe is there is there
something said that it might be meant to
be
well when we were talking about legacy
what legacy that would be if he wins all
of his games and he forces yamnipumnishi
to hit tiebreak
i mean that would be something right if
dean keeps winning and there's no
guarantees that jan can just draw his
next three games because the road ahead
for all these players we're
half joking about ding winning all of
his games but the form that he's in
doesn't matter his color he went two
games in a row with the black pieces but
we know that the matchups ahead for for
these players i mean it never gets
easier because every player is so strong
so as we head into the next round we
know that yon napomishi will be in first
place dingley run in second nakamura now
clear third and he gets his crack at yon
napomishi
the
importance of this game simply cannot be
overstated and the big question as i was
talking about earlier is going to be the
opening of hikaru places patented berlin
will yan take the quick draw and will
ding's result from today influence jan's
decision might he have taken the draw if
ding had drawn his game and the lead
over ding was at two we will never know
that but we will be watching very
intently because hikaru nakamura he's
won a lot of critical games of the black
pieces he is writing some very good form
in the second half and he might not be
willing just to give jan an easy chance
to draw the game we will keep a close
eye on that one and of course on dingley
run's chance to defeat timur ajaba for
the fourth straight win with the white
pieces
i mean almira i feel like dingley
randy's the perfect style to win a game
with timor jabba who's been very solid
but in that first game that they played
he was able to outlast for java almost
win and then made a critical error
well this is of course true but i think
that timur has been struggling this
tournament with black and well if
ding uh will well he will start most
certainly study his opening repertoire
and if he finds a hole in the line
because
remember against fabiano caruana timura
job of 144 c5 knight f3 a6 this is a
very rare line and that was a long
struggle but fabiano managed to win at
the end and he had like a clear edge
after the opening so
i think that
timur has to come up with well
at least one idea tomorrow yeah he needs
to survive the opening and if that's the
case maybe we'll see dingley run play a
rare e4 from him if he thinks that rajab
doesn't have a good opening in response
but dingley wren has three opponents
left as does everybody in this field up
next is team over java we were just
talking about the possibilities in that
game dingley rand gets the white pieces
he has a good lifetime record against
him but then he gets alireza farouja and
hikaru nakamura so
we said he can perhaps win all of his
games that's going to be very
challenging against that level of
competition there well you take it one
step at a time
yeah and tomorrow's game against
tomorrow's job of that will show us a
lot
dinner time for everybody but tomorrow's
round is going to be an absolutely
fascinating one yes for sure so we'll
see what ding can do with the white
pieces if you can continue this momentum
three wins in a row we haven't seen that
since 2013 candidates really
unbelievable stuff but yonder pomeshi
that's the player that dingly ren and
everybody else is chasing and look at
this upcoming slate two whites in a row
for yon napomnishi so almira does he
take it peacefully tomorrow against
ikaro nakamura he knows that akaru will
try everything to beat him but sometimes
with the black pieces you just have no
options well if you would tell me before
the tournament that scoring eight out of
11 is would not be enough to secure the
victory in the tournament three rounds
before i would really
well question your sanity
but now here we are he
he he's probably going to try tomorrow
with white against hikaru nakamura i
agree i think i think ding's result
will give him some butterflies in his
stomach and i think the nepo is going to
play something solid but that will give
him some chances to win so
not quite as drawish as what he played
against ding
but i think he's going to
prefer to err on the side of being too
solid
but we'll see there's only one way to
find dad we'll have to wait until
tomorrow at three o'clock and we have to
wait to see how
uh opportunistic how optimistic hikaru
nakamura plans to be but that's the end
of the 11th round here at the feeder
candidates
elmira daniel
i'm roberta it's been a long long day
six and a half hours of play and as you
see people are just now leaving the
tournament hall probably gonna wait for
uh some autographs i know yesterday
dania everyone was asking you for your
autograph but
we're gonna say goodbye to round 11 of
the 2022 feed of candidates enjoy your
evenings if you're elsewhere enjoy the
rest of your day but until tomorrow
we'll see you then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you